Die Enttäuschung ist ja für alle natürlich jetzt so groß.
Wir haben uns alle was anderes erhofft.
Ich habe eine hohe Enttäuschung.
Jeder fällt jetzt in ein tiefes Loch. Die große Niederhaut, die ich geschlagen hatte, ist fast körperlich zu spüren. Alle sind total enttäuscht und da braucht man jetzt nur eine Zeit, um aus diesem Loch wieder rauszukommen.
Berlin, fertig machen zum Trauern.
Die ersten Tränen fließen. Natürlich ist man sehr traurig als Deutscher.
Wir sind natürlich alle enttäuscht und auch traurig.
In der Kabine fließen Tränen.
Das war ja alles so sorgfältig vorbereitet.
Das müssen wir sehen, wie man das in Zukunft dann auch besser machen kann.
Ich glaube, wir haben nicht das umgesetzt, was wir eigentlich können. Wir haben uns mehr erhofft, deswegen sind wir schon enttäuscht.
Ja, natürlich sehr, sehr bitter.
Da kann man sich ja vorstellen, dass man eben immer zutiefst, zutiefst enttäuscht ist.
Stress, Malenthanen, Stütz und Verzweiflung.
Wir haben heute fest verpult, heute werden wir fließen natürlich. Über diese Enttäuschung da die Tränen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum, Zack, Return.
Was soll man noch mehr dazu sagen?
Tim, reich mir noch mal die Taschentücherbox darüber.
Wann können wir eigentlich mal ein Leistungsschutzrecht für Podcasts, damit wir die endlich mal abmahnen können. Das wäre noch mal endlich mein Geschäftsmodell hier.
1, 2, 3, Moment.
Damit hätten wir das Thema ja auch schon durch.
Das Podcast-Thema, genau. Warte mal, mein Telefon ist zu laut und dein Mikrofon ist zu schlecht ausgerichtet, Dennis. Man hört dich gar nicht richtig atmen. Sag mal was.
Also jetzt mal, also bevor wir hier richtig lossturmeln, bevor Tim gleich Luft ansaugt und loslegt, kannst du mein Kopfhörer noch ein bisschen leiser machen.
Wir sind heute alle ein bisschen entspannter als sonst.
So ist es schön. Wer von euch hat denn erwartet, als ihr die Headline gelesen habt, dass es diese Podcast-App geben wird.
Ich dachte, jetzt geht es über Fußball.
Wer von euch hat denn gedacht, dass diese App auch wirklich signifikant was zum Podcastuniversum beitragen kann? Hand hoch. Also bevor ihr sie gesehen habt.
Ich finde, sie trägt auch etwas dazu bei ihr, aber egal.
Ja, was denn?
Also ich dachte, ich hab's gesehen und dachte mir, okay, es ist halt so eine Podcast-Brause ab, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nichts für Power-User.
Apple ist noch nie was für Power-User gewesen.
Also Tim hat seine Hand nicht gehoben.
Also ich begrüße erst mal alle hier herzlich zur neunzigsten Ausgabe von Moga Max im Studio, wie ihr sicher schon mitbekommen habt. Alle dabei, außer Roddi, also Max und Huckel und Dennis.
Max.
Max spielt wieder mit seinem iPhone.
Ja, ich guck mir gerade nochmal die Podcasts.
Ey, das ist schon ein 5-mal Prototyp. Ach nee, nicht ablegen jetzt.
Ja, wie ihr seht, wir bereiten uns hier, wir bereiten uns hier ausreichend vor.
Ich hab mal Artikel gelesen und hab Screenshots gesehen.
Ich hab's sogar ausprobiert.
Ich hab's ja auch ein bisschen ausprobiert.
Die gibt's jetzt schon.
Ja, die gibt's schon. Es hat hier bloß jemand gemeint, dass die, dass sie auch, dass sie auch.
Wir sollten mal erst mal sagen, was überhaupt passiert ist, auch wenn sowieso schon alle wissen, aber ihr wisst ja, man muss ja die Chronik auch fortschreiben. Also nachdem es sich jetzt schon abzeichnete dadurch, dass dieser Rektions-Support in iOS 6 so jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr sichtbar war, aber man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt davon hat ausgehen können, dass sie jetzt Podcasts von heute auf morgen komplett vergessen, kam dann doch, glaube ich, sogar noch ein Funken eher, als das jetzt alle damit unbedingt gerechnet haben, eine Podcast-App, die eben auch unter iOS 5 schon läuft.
Das heißt, es ist wieder eine App von Apple, die nicht beim US dabei ist, sondern die man getrennt herunterlässt.
Das Ding ist so ein bisschen auf dem Level von iBooks und was noch, Find My Friends und so weiter. Also so ein bisschen so Systemlevel. Ich mach das mal ein bisschen lauter an, Dennis. Bisschen leiser heute irgendwie, ich weiß nicht warum. Also es ist ja schon eine privilegierte App. Ist ja nicht eine App wie jeder andere. Naja, weil sie kann ja, wenn du die startest, dann sieht sie sofort die von iTunes gesüngten Podcasts und kann denen ja auch was hinzufügen und so. Was es sich teilt, weiß ich nicht, auf jeden Fall hat sie zu einem anderen Zugriff auf diese Mediathek als andere Apps. Und sie ersetzt insofern schon eben die alte Funktionalität. Also sie geht mit denselben Daten rum, bloß sie tut es eben innerhalb einer anderen App. Also tatsächlich haben sie diese Funktionalität aus dieser iTunes App heraus. Beziehungsweise aus dieser Music. Also genau genommen ist es ja eine Melange aus der Music App und der iTunes App. Also sie haben, insofern ist es ja schon mal begrüßenswert. Also es gibt hier durchaus begrüßenswerte Schritte. Sie haben jetzt so diesen ganzen Subscription und Directory-Browse-Kram zusammengeführt mit dem eigentlichen Abspielen. So, und insofern, so weit kann ich das jetzt auch erstmal begrüßen. Also mir geht es jetzt hier, ich weiß, alle warten jetzt, dass ich explodiere. Der Punkt ist nur, ich versuche herauszufinden, was sie sich damit gedacht haben. Ich weiß, dass sie irgendwie ungefähr vom Dreivierteljahr mit der Konzeption dieser App angefangen haben. Oder vielleicht haben sie auch schon vom Jahr angefangen, aber so vom Dreivierteljahr hing das Ding wohl irgendwie noch konzeptionell. Ich hab ja früher schon mal gesagt, dass ich da ein paar Glocken habe Leuten hören, dass da was mit Podcasts geht, bloß da habe ich nicht selber draus schließen können, dass es sich vermutlich eben genau darum handelte. Also dass sie geplant haben, diese Funktionalität auszugliedern. Wenn wir jetzt erstmal bei dem Guten bleiben, das Gute ist, einerseits ist der eigentliche Podcast-Behandlungs-Flow konsistenter auf dem iPhone, das ist quasi ein Schritt weg von iTunes, weil derzeit konntest du ja eigentlich nur, wenn du jetzt rein in dem iTunes-Ökosystem bleibst, musstest du ja irgendwie de facto eigentlich alles auf dem Mac machen. Also du konntest ja noch nicht mal Subscriptions richtig starten, weil du auf dem iPhone eigentlich nichts anderes tun konntest. Also du konntest zwar Podcasts aus diesem Store heraussuchen, du konntest auch Episoden herunterladen, aber damit hattest du noch nicht automatisch eine Subscription. Du hattest lediglich den Feed dann quasi in der Liste von Feeds in deinem iTunes nach dem nächsten Sünken, aber der war dann noch nicht automatisch subscribt, sondern der lag da nur so rum, damit da eben ein Container da ist, wo diese Episode, die du manuell runtergeladen hast, auch irgendwo sein könnte. Aber sie war halt de facto erstmal nicht abonniert.
Okay, ich hab das nie benutzt, so scheinbar.
Also ich mein, bisher war es eine totale Katastrophe. Und jetzt ist es so, dass es zumindest, wenn man jetzt von dem Blickwinkel Experience auf IOS schaut, nicht mehr eine totale Folkkatastrophe ist, sondern es ist halt einfach nur so ein... Ja, es ist halt so ein normaler Gewittersturm, wo ein paar Häuser abbrennen. Vorher war es halt irgendwie Earthquake. Na ja, vorher war es wirklich schlecht. Ich meine, ich bin da extrem gespalten, was Apples Support für Podcasts betrifft. Man hat sie ja keine zugezwungen. Sie haben das halt anfänglich getan, schlicht und ergreifend aus der Erkenntnis heraus, dass das natürlich eine tolle Sache ist für Leute, die eine iPod haben und für sie quasi etwas, was sie günstig featuren können. Sie haben es einem einfach gemacht, Podcasts zu abonnieren und auf diese Geräte zu sinken. Ihr Interesse ist natürlich, die Gerätegattung als solche interessanter zu machen, dadurch, dass es da eben noch mal so ein kostenloses Angebot gibt, für das sie im Prinzip nicht viel tun müssten, außer so ein Verzeichnis zu unterhalten und ein paar Subscribe-Buttons in ihre Software einzubauen, in dem Fall halt iTunes. Potenziell wird natürlich der iPod damit voller und zwingt die Leute oder motiviert die Leute eben auch tendenziell zu Geräten zu gehen, die dann eben doppelt oder dreimal so viel Kapazität haben, wie der Vorgänger oder... Ja, naja, ich meine, da bin ich mir sicher, dass das jeder bei Apple auch gleich so unterschreiben würde. Na, warum sollten sie es sonst tun? Also nur weil der Pot drin ist, haben sie es nicht gemacht, sondern das ist halt etwas, wo sie ganz klar gesehen haben, einerseits können sie da so ein bisschen die Lufthoheit gewinnen, eben auch über diesen Namen und vor allem war es aber einfach, dass es etwas ist, was ihre Produktgattung unterstützt hat. Genauso wie sie eben diesen Music Store betreiben, um iPhones und iPods zu verkaufen. Nicht weil sie mit dem Verkaufen von Musik Geld machen wollen, sondern das ist ja, das ist zwar so erfolgreich, dass sie da mittlerweile auch Geld verdienen, aber im Vergleich zu dem Geld, was sie mit allem anderen verdienen, insbesondere ihrer Hardware, ist das ja alles Pipifucks.
Ich glaube, die haben die Podcasts eingebaut, weil sie so cool fanden, dass das wirklich so ein ganz banaler Grund ist, dass sie sich da gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel bei gedacht haben, sondern dass das so irgendwie wahrscheinlich damals fantastisch irgendwie noch cool und hat gesagt, so Podcast will ich haben und dann haben sie halt Podcasts eingebaut.
Naja, aber dann können sie sich nicht sehr cool gefunden haben, weil nämlich der Umgang damit...
Das Interesse war, ist einfach wiedergesunken.
Der Umgang damit war aber nicht cool.
Am Anfang schon.
Als iTunes das plötzlich konnte und so.
Naja, als allererster Schritt. Es hat sich ein, doch, also es gab genau einmal ein Funktionsupdate. Nach Jahren, nach zwei Jahren oder so. Ich weiß nicht mal ganz genau, wann das war. Da hat iTunes neue Funktionalität bekommen. Das war so, dass du eben für jeden Podcast einzeln mal sagen konntest, wie die Download-Strategie sein soll. Vorher war das nur global. Und danach war es so per Podcast. Also ich meine, mit dem Anspruch, den wir an User-Interfaces legen und an User-Experience, ist dieses iTunes-Gebimse, wie du da mit Podcast einstellst, das ist einfach unterirdisch. Und das hat sich jetzt einfach nicht geändert seit 2005.
iTunes ist sicher so unterirdisch.
Sieben Jahre! Ja gut, aber das ist nochmal viel... Das ist sozusagen die U-Bahn in der unterirdischen Welt.
Es gibt unglaublich viele Leute, denen es reicht. Also so wie iTunes im Augenblick funktioniert. Ich finde...
Was heißt, denen reicht? Die wissen nichts von dieser Funktionalität. Das ist die Realität. Wenn ich auf einem Spielplatz stehe und den Leuten Podcast erkläre, dann gehen mir grauenhafte Bilder durch den Kopf. Was sage ich ihm jetzt? Am Ende sage ich ihm irgendwie, ja, tipp das und das in iTunes ein und drück auf Abonnieren. Weil das ist die einzige User-Experience, die man mir erklären kann. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, auf deinem iPhone tue das und das. Weil da wirst du bekloppt bei. Das ändert sich jetzt ein bisschen. Obwohl sowas wie, lag dir die Podcast ab von Apple runter und dann benutze es um zu suchen und so, ist auch so ein bisschen so, hm, shady.
Ach, die Leute können mit dem App-Store umgehen. Also ich meine, wenn der Erfolg vom App-Store eins bewiesen hat, dass die Leute das auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute du schon versucht hast, Podcasts zu erklären.
Ich bin selten auf Spielplätzen und wenn dann probiere ich die Leute auf.
Wie auch immer. Aber ich denke, wir sind uns einig, es hat jetzt nicht besonders viel Liebe bekommen. Der ganze sonstige Store, das hat eigentlich am laufenden Meter immer wieder irgendeine Ergänzung gefunden, nicht unbedingt immer welche, die wir jetzt besonders mögen.
Cashcrow.
Ja, aber die Cashcrow ist es deshalb, weil es dafür sorgt, dass die Leute Geräte kaufen, nicht weil sie mit dem Verkauf selbst besonders viel Geld machen.
Aber die machen damit schon auch Geld.
Mit Musik?
Ne, auch mit dem normalen App Store.
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Das ist so angeblich plus minus null Geschäft, der App Store im Augenblick für Apple.
Die müssen ja auch schon Aufwand treiben, so ist es nicht.
Die haben doch da keine Milliarde Aufwand getrieben. Die haben doch da schon wie viele Milliarden jetzt eingenommen, wenn sie fünf ausgezahlt haben oder was?
Ich kann dir das nicht auseinanderkennen, aber es ist im Vergleich zu ihrem Hardware-Revenue ist es alles Pipifax.
Aber immer noch tausendmal größer als in anderen Firmen.
Ja, aber das heißt, die Motivation, es zu tun, um ihren Geräteverkauf anzukurbeln, ist viel, viel, viel größer, als jetzt da in diesem Bereich eine große Marge rauszuhauen. Und bei den Podcasts gibt es keine Marge, weil da wird halt auch nicht verkauft. Zumindest derzeit nicht. Anderes Thema.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum Apple da jetzt mit einer eigenen App vorprescht, damit sie halt, wenn da in Zukunft das mit der Kohle losgeht, damit sie den Markt auch gleich schon in der Hand halten. Wenn es dann nämlich dann 1000 andere Podcast-Apps gibt, die das irgendwie managen, dann steht Apple ein bisschen doof da und das haben die ja schon immer so gemacht.
Da kann man gleich nochmal drüber diskutieren. Lass uns erstmal bei dieser komischen Abbleiben. Habt ihr die alle ausprobiert?
Gerade eben kurz mal. Aber ich bin ja kein Podcast-Hörer, deswegen.
Halt dich raus. Du darfst auch was sagen. Aber nur wenn du es ausprobiert hast.
Nee, ich halte mich raus. Nee, du hast ja ja noch zwei andere, die Podcast hören.
Aber ich höre Podcasts ja ganz anders. Ich hab so einen kleinen iPod-Truffel, der heißt Willi. Und dann, wenn ich sonntags zum Sport gehe, dann steige ich den Willi an meinen Notebook und dann gucke ich mal, ob's...
Komm, den hast du jetzt nur so genannt, Willi.
Nee, das hat den Grund, weil der Typ, der quasi da bei diesem Fitnessstudio, wo ich da irgendwie dahin gehe, der Typ am Telefon hieß Willi. Und dann hatte ich diesen Shuffle gekauft, nur um dann halt beim Sport auch irgendwie Musik zu hören.
Nur, um mit dem nicht reden zu müssen, oder wie?
Um mit dem nicht reden zu müssen. Und dann... Dann musste ich halt dem Shuffle Namen geben und dann blieb noch dieser Name Willi hängen. Deswegen heißt der Willi. Ich fand ihn auch ganz putzig für so ein kleines Gerät. Anyway, und da guck ich dann einfach kurz vorher, ob es irgendwie bei den Usual Suspect-Postkasten eine Folge gibt, die mich interessiert. Lad die runter, schieb das einfach vom Desktop quasi direkt auf den Willi drauf und fertig. Und dann mach ich einfach hier Play irgendwie und dann war's das mit meiner Podcast-Akküle.
Für die meisten Leute reicht das, was iTunes spielt.
Ich lade mir das sogar von Webseiten runter, nicht mal über iTunes. Weil ich will in iTunes, hab ich immer so die Sorge, dass wenn ich dann auf irgendeinen Podcast klicke, dass das gleich abonniert ist und er mir dann automatisch irgendeinen Scheiß im Hintergrund runterlädt und ich klick lieber so eine Folge mit Weget, am besten schön, gleich auf den Desktop und fertig.
Damit er auch keine Cookies hinterlässt.
Genau, alles ganz clean. Das ist meine Podcast-Experience. Auf dem Willi habe ich halt auch keine Coverbilder.
Na gut, es gibt ja auch noch Leute, die haben ein höheres Komfortbedürfnis als du.
Das ist super komfortabel. Ja, egal, erzähl weiter. Also jetzt ihr, die ihr da alle geklickt habt.
Ich bin entsetzt. Ich bin entsetzt. Was für ein furchtbares Design sie da aufgerufen haben. Bandlaufwerk? Ich meine, bitte? Was in aller Welt wollen sie mir damit sagen? Ich meine, weiß überhaupt noch irgendjemand auf diesem Planeten was ein Bandlaufwerk ist?
Offensichtlich, sonst würden sich ja nicht alle so furchtbar darüber aufregen.
Musst du irgendwie der Vorgänger der Kassette gewesen sein, oder?
Also, um ehrlich zu sein, als ich das allererste Mal dieses User-Interface aufgerufen habe und von meiner Nase gesehen habe, und Gott sei Dank habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht irgendeine Diskussion darüber verfolgt.
Oder Milch im Mund gehabt, ja. Dann hättest du die gleich durch die Nase direkt auf deinem Telefon exhaliert.
Naja, für Schaum hat es gesorgt, sagen wir's mal so. Nee, es ist, ich meine...
Das geht doch aber hier alles nicht.
Es ist furchtbar langsam, es ist unresponsiv und es ist vor allem... Ich meine, wie sieht denn das aus? So ein angeschnittenes Bandlaufwerk, wo oben so komische Dinge rotieren. Alles in so einem grau-mellierten Tonage, wo dann so einzelne Schräubchen dann hellgrau sind. Genauso hellgrau wie unten diese komischen, hässlichen Tasten, die aussehen, als wären sie direkt aus so einem Windows-95-User-Interface heraus operiert worden mit Cut und Paste. Fehlt noch, dass sie an den Rändern die Transparenz nicht richtig hinbekommen hätten und es dann so ausfranzt. Und auch so ein bisschen blau vom Windows-Desktop irgendwie noch mit drin ist. Das hätte jetzt noch gefehlt. Aber die Tasten liegen viel zu eng beieinander. Ich bin fassungslos. Ich bin wirklich fassungslos, wie hässlich das ist. Dann gibt es da drüber auch noch so eine komische Spule, die dann auch noch aussieht, als wäre das so ein Radio-Frequenzeinsteller, also mit dieser roten Marke. Mit zwei Pfeilen, weißt du so Pfeil mit Strich, die keine Funktion haben.
Na doch, die sind zum Durch-die-Kapitel-Springen.
Die sind zum Für-die-Kapitel?
Offensichtlich, ja.
Wann, wo, wie was?
Kapitel?
Klick auf Nächste Kapitel, Kapitel ist da.
Diese Funktionalität ist bei dir vorhanden?
Wo?
Na, in der Podcast-App da, wo die...
In welchem Podcast?
Also in dem Fall jetzt, hab ich jetzt mal einen hier runtergeladen, der wurde gerade auch im Chat gesagt, schöne Ecken.
Ja.
Und?
Das geht.
Was und?
Na, ich hab hier auch einen Podcast mit Kapitelmarken und davon ist nichts zu sehen.
Ich hab keiner...
Die sind disabled.
Was, was, was?
Also ich sehe nur, in dem Podcast hier sind sie da. Was, was, also ich meine, das ist jetzt...
Hier, gib doch mal Tim kurz...
Nein, ich geb doch nicht mal ein Telefon.
Doch, gib mal bitte.
Nein, nein, nein, du machst das doch wieder kaputt.
Jaja, aber trotzdem ja. Und was hast du da für ein Muster?
Wie war's für ein Muster?
Na du hast da so ein komisches Sinienmuster.
Na da sieht man, wo die Kapitel alle sind.
Really?
Also ich hab's jetzt auch das erste Mal gesehen.
Plötzlich ist gar nicht mehr alles so schlimm.
Na das sieht schon extrem hässlich aus. Das muss man schon sagen.
Also abgesehen davon, dass es irgendwie immer noch... Ist ja krass. Das heißt, sie unterstützen nach wie vor Kapitelmarken, aber sie haben irgendwas geändert. Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich das Ding überhaupt mit Kapitelmarkeninterface sehe. Heidewitzka. Das heißt, irgendwas hat sich auch noch an Dateiformat geändert.
Die werden einfach noch nicht so weit sein.
Aber der springt ja überhaupt nicht immer nach vorne. Also ich drücke hier immer nach, geh mal ein weiter, und dann springt er vor und zurück.
It's crap.
Ne, mal ehrlich hier. Also ich kann hier irgendwie auf Kapitel 6 gehen, dann geh ich auf Kapitel 7. Gucke mal.
Wir können nicht gucken. Du hast mal mein Telefon weggenommen, darum kann ich es weder sehen noch ausprobieren.
Okay, pass auf.
Jetzt bleib mal entspannt, Max.
Der hat mein Telefon an.
Ich hab's jetzt mal auf Kapitel 5 gespult. Spul mal vor bis Kapitel 8.
Mach mal.
Und dann versuch mal auf 9 zu gehen.
Geht da, sagt da irgendwas von...
Und dann springt er wieder zurück. Okay, also erstens, ich hätte jetzt fast behauptet, sie ignorieren Enhance Podcasts komplett, tun sie offensichtlich nicht.
Sie können's einfach nicht.
Mit Logbuch Netzpolitik, wo auch Kapitelmarken drin sind, geht's nicht zusammen. Das heißt, da ist irgendwas fisch.
Dann frag doch mal bei den schönen Ecken nach, was die richtig machen.
Ich vermute, wenn ich's richtig in Erinnerung habe, verwenden die Garage Band. Wahrscheinlich setzt Garage Band wieder das Apple-Bit.
Ja?
Vielleicht, weil die Bilderunterstützung...
Alle Daten sind richtig, aber wenn du das Apple-Bit nicht setzt, dann funktioniert dein Scheiß einfach in der nächsten Version nicht. Aber sie sagen mir natürlich nicht, wo dieses Bit ist.
Die haben das Tim-Bit einfach nicht gesetzt.
Es gibt kein Tim-Bit.
Na klar, gibt's ein Tim-Bit. Was meinst du, warum sein Mac Pro immer abstürzt?
In description vielleicht, aber nicht implementiert.
Mein Mac Pro stürzt nicht ab, das Bluetooth stürzt ab. Von meinem Mac Pro. Das ist noch ein anderes Thema, aber Bluetooth sollten wir auch noch mal reden. Also ich finde auch dieses User-Interface wie Shady vor allem, weil das ist alles so hellgrau, dunkelgrau, brau und dann noch schwarz und ein bisschen weiß. Und ich wollte ja eigentlich gerade erzählen, wie mir das so rüberkam, als sie das erste Mal gesehen haben. Ich hab das überhaupt nicht verstanden. Ich hab das überhaupt nicht gesehen als ein Tapedeck. Ihr etwa? Habt ihr das aufgerufen und das erste, was ihr gedacht habt, ist geil, ein Tapedeck?
Also ich hab nicht gesagt, geil, ein Tapedeck.
Aber ich meine, war das sofort klar für dich? Weil ich dachte nämlich, dass dann diese komischen hellgrauen Knöpfe auch irgendeine Funktion haben.
Das dachte ich am Anfang auch.
Ja, dann hab ich da drauf rumgetippt und ich wunderte mich, worauf ich da jetzt eigentlich rumtippe. Nein, nein, aber es sind die dunkelgrauen Knöpfe da drunter, die irgendwas tun. Dann gibt's jetzt auch noch so einen bekloppten Geschwindigkeitsschalter an der Mitte mit so Hin und Her-Schalten. Was ist denn jetzt ein Debierer schlimm? Die muss man so hin und her sliden.
Wieso?
Kannst du einfach draufdrücken.
Ja, wenn ich draufdrücke, geht er in die Mitte.
Nee, wenn du draufdrückst, geht er dahin, wo du hin tippst.
Wenn ich draufdrücke, drücke ich einfach nur drauf.
Wenn du aufs Häschen tippst, dann geht er aufs Häschen. Wenn du auf diese Schildkröte tippst...
Ach so, wenn ich aufs Häschen tippe? Ich dachte auf diesen Schnupsel. Ich hab auf den Schnupsel getippst.
Tim ist so doof, ein Telefon zu bedienen.
Das ist kein Telefon.
Hasen und Schildkröten hab ich jetzt hier. Vorher gab es, meines Wissens, zwei Geschwindigkeiten. 1,5 und 2,5. Also zusätzlich zu normalen Geschwindigkeiten. Jetzt gibt es nur noch einen Hasen.
Kann man nicht zweimal auf den Hasen tippen?
Du meinst, die vermehren sich dann?
Der wird schneller dann halt. Hase schneller und Igel langsamer.
Man muss einfach so 10 Mal pro Sekunde auf diesen Hasen drauf tippen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein anderer Farbe.
Okay, dann gibt es einen Sleep-Timer. Meinetwegen. Aber es gibt keine Kapitelfotos mehr. Der Titel taucht nur oben in diesem Minititel-Dings. Die Kapitel-Bilder?
Ach, doch klar.
Na, wenn du die Klappe wieder zumachst, quasi.
Guck, hier, Kapitel-Bilder. Klappe zu, Kapitel-Bilder.
Und dann musst du aber erst wieder hoch machen aufs nächste Kapitel, hast du ein anderes Kapitel-Bild?
irgendwie so, keine Ahnung.
So, und natürlich gibt es keine Dokumentation darüber. Jetzt haben sie ihre iTunes-Specs ja neulich Mobile-Max berichtete, haben sie ja irgendwie aktualisiert. Aber nichts dazu. Also... Annex hat jetzt immer noch diesen alten Scheiß drin, dass wenn du eine Liste von Podcasts hast, also eine Liste von Episoden hast, dann kommst du ans Ende von der einen, geht automatisch in die nächste und du kannst das nicht abschalten. Der iPod 5G hat das irgendwie.
Das heißt, wenn du mal eine alte Folge hören willst, dann laufen gleich alle anderen auch wieder durch, ja?
Ja, oder wenn du einschläfst dabei.
Dafür gibt es einen Sleep-Timer.
Ja, dafür gibt es einen Sleep-Timer. Dann bist du halt eingeschlafen, bevor du deinen Scheiß-Sleep-Timer gemacht hast. Auch der Sleep-Timer endet nicht bei der Episode, die du hörst, sondern geht dann noch so lange in die nächste rein, bis dein Sleep-Timer abgelaufen ist.
Und Siri erkennt nicht, wenn man schnarcht?
Das wär mal...
Scheiße, hätte ich mir potentieren lassen sollen.
Nee, aber ich meine, das ist einfach unpraktisch. Ich find das wirklich schlimm. Und es macht einfach die Adoption neuer Features irgendwie jetzt nicht einfacher. Es gibt ja auch noch dieses Gerücht, dass sie jetzt irgendwie angeblich da irgendwo in irgendeiner amerikanischen Version sei ja mal ein... so ein Redeem-Button aufgetaucht. Habt ihr das irgendwie verifizieren können? Also ich hab da so Screenshots gesehen, aber bei mir sah das immer anders aus. Gewiss da nichts von, ne?
Redeem, Redeemed hab ich bisher nur per Mail an Apple.
Was meinen Sie mit Redeem? Ist das diese Code einlösen? Oder ist das was zurückgeben?
Redeem ist, glaub ich, Code einlösen.
Ja, was auch immer das bedeutet. Ich mein, das kann auch einfach ein Bug gewesen sein, dass sie da irgendeine, weil sie ja in den, sie gehen ja in diesen Store rein. Also sie haben so dasselbe User-Interface, quasi wie so kaufen von Musik, haben sie ja auch für Podcasts. Und da würde ich jetzt mal nicht ausschließen, dass ihnen da irgendwie so ein Template-Fehler unterlaufen ist, dass sie da diesen Redeem-Button drin hatten, weil sie den eben bei iTunes brauchen. Bei Podcasts macht da eben keinen Sinn und deswegen ist er ja auch nicht da.
Das klingt total plausibel.
Kann aber auch sein, dass sie einfach ein Feature schon mal gepreviewt haben, was später kommt. Und dann stellt sie natürlich die Frage, was bedeutet das?
Wäre natürlich mal interessant, ob dieses Interface, mit dem man hier auf das Podcast-Interface von Apple zugreifen kann, ob das dann mit iOS 6 auch anderen Apps zur Verfügung steht. Es gibt ja hier dieses Interface drinnen, zum Abonnieren, über das wir gerade geredet haben, dieses iTunes-Interface.
Ob man das sozusagen so SDK-mäßig direkt ansprechen kann, mit hol mir mal einen Podcast aus dem Verzeichnis.
Na es gibt ja in iOS 6, das war ziemlich sicher in der Kino drinnen, dass man auch aus Apps heraus Apps kaufen kann.
Was?
NDR gebrochen.
Und das gilt garantiert auch für den Rest des iTunes-Stores. Und warum dann nicht auch für Podcasts?
Also ich meine, liegt ja eigentlich nahe.
Im Sinne von kaufen oder im Sinne von abonnieren? Also API-Zugang zum Podcastverzeichnis gibt es schon.
Nein, dass du hier dieses Interface kriegst. Also dass du diese Drehbewegung hinkriegst. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, was du hier in dieser Podcast-App hast.
Ach so, wie so eine geheime Schrankwand.
Warum ist das jetzt eigentlich so breit? Und kommt das jetzt bei allen Apps so? Soll das Standard werden oder soll das halt wirklich die Schrankwand nachmachen?
Das ist bei...
Keine Ahnung.
Ist das die erste App, wo das so breit aussieht?
Nein, bei iBooks ist das auch so. Das ist das Bücherregal, was sich dreht.
Das ist voll hässlich. Das macht das alles so ein bisschen klobig. Mein iPhone ist doch gar nicht so tief. Das, was sich da dreht, sieht doch viel dicker aus.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das bedeuten soll. Irgendwie soll das das Gefühl geben, dass man jetzt im Store ist, sozusagen. Das ist wahrscheinlich so Drehtür, mit du bist jetzt in den heiligen Hallen des Apple iTunes Podcast-Verzeichnisses. Nicht, dass einem das irgendwie klargemacht wird.
Du bist in zwei verschiedenen App-Body.
Finde ich kann man machen.
Also ich finde das Ding hässlich. Ich habe auch schon Leute gehört, die fanden das irgendwie toll.
Gibt's ja immer.
Also ich finde die ist sehr einsnullig. Da muss ich dir leider recht geben. Also sie hat sehr viele Bugs. Es langsam stürzt zu oft ab und ist auch sonst nicht richtig fertig. Ansonsten finde ich den Ansatz, also dass es im App-Store ist und nicht mehr in der Music App, finde ich grandios, weil das gibt ihnen endlich mal die Möglichkeit, das zu aktualisieren, ohne extra auf ein Betriebssystem-Update warten zu müssen. Die Entwickler, die daran sitzen, die sind unabhängig. Die sind jetzt nicht irgendwie an das Music-App-Team hinten irgendwo dran gebunden oder so was. Also zumindest können die ihren eigenen Release-Cycle im Zweifelsfall machen und wenn sie einen Baccar haben, dann können sie den fixen, ohne dass sie jetzt auf die nächste Version warten müssen und so dieses ganze Zeug. Das finde ich prinzipiell nicht verkehrt. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass die sich dann um nichts anderes kümmern als um diese Podcast-App und dementsprechend da dementsprechend viel Priorität rein geben können. Hoffentlich. Also ich hoffe da auf regelmäßig Updates bei der App. Ich finde, dieses allgemeine User-Interface-Element, über die haben wir gar nicht geredet. Also jetzt sagen wir mal in dieser Listenansicht, in dieser Podcast-Liste, wenn man reinkommt. Das scheint so der neue Look von iOS-Für-Medien-Apps zu werden, habe ich das Gefühl. Ja, kann man machen. Das ist halt so das, was mit Musik zu tun hat oder sowas. Das sieht alles irgendwie so ein bisschen ähnlich aus. Und hat halt diesen Look. Und ich finde, das Bandlauf ja klar ist total überflüssig, aber ich finde es irgendwie ganz putzig. Und ich weiß nicht, ob man an der Stelle, also es ist jetzt nicht, dass deswegen irgendeine Funktionalität fehlt wegen diesem Bandlaufwerk oder sowas.
Doch, das macht alle anderen User-Interface-Elemente total klein. Was ist mit den Show Notes zum Beispiel? Also Show Notes sind da total zweiter Klasse.
Ja, aber es ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ob Show Notes da so eine hohe Priorität haben.
Offensichtlich nicht. Naja, das ist aber schade. Du kannst auf diese Liste gehen und dann machst du i und dann kriegst du irgendwie die Show Notes. Genau. Ich meine, immerhin haben sie dadurch mal einen Weg gefunden, mal auch den ganzen Titel anzuzeigen, bevor, weiß nicht, kann man das eigentlich, bevor man es abspielt, machen dadurch? Jaja, okay, dadurch kannst du i draufgehen und dann siehst du eben so die Daten.
Naja, aber dass die Show Notes nicht in der App drin sind, ist ja eigentlich jetzt auch gar nicht so schlecht. Dass man sich vorher nochmal angucken kann, was erwartet mich denn da überhaupt? Ist das denn überhaupt spannend? Ja, also es ist ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Es ist kein sonderlich großer Schritt, aber es ist ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Ja, na ich wäre halt mal froh, wenn sie jetzt endlich mal dieses Enhanced Podcast Format publizieren können. Offensichtlich haben sie ja jetzt wieder irgendwas geändert oder irgendwas haben sie an der Interpretation geändert, weil Sachen, die vorher gingen, gehen jetzt nicht mehr.
Vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur ein Bug. Die haben das wahrscheinlich mit Garageband erstmal getestet und haben damit, bis es damit funktioniert hat. Und haben es mit nichts anderem ausprobiert und das kommt jetzt so nach und nach. Das wäre jetzt so meine Vermutung. Und ich finde dieses Bandlaufwerk, das ist auch wirklich liebevoll gemacht. Garnot hat sich das stundenlang irgendwie angeguckt. Also erstens, die Spulen, wie heißen die Dinger beim Bandlaufwerk? Diese Rollen, diese Magnetbandrollen, die werden ja unterschiedlich voll im Laufe der Zeit. Bedruckelt sogar so ein bisschen.
Also links ist ja diese, die werden unterschiedlich voll.
Je nachdem, wo dein Band voll ist.
Wo sieht man denn überhaupt, wie voll die sind? Ich sehe gar nichts. Kannst du da überhaupt irgendwas erkennen? Ach so, jetzt springt das hin und her. Aber ich meine... Das hast du doch in Progress Bar da unten.
Das bringt keinen Mehrwert, das Ding. Das sieht einfach hübsch aus und ist liebevoll gemacht. Finde ich okay.
Liebevoll gemacht. Das sieht aus wie hingekackt und hingeschissen. Nee. Also irgendwie so ein Dieter Rahm-Spandlaufwerk, da irgendwie so hinzukopieren. Also ich weiß nicht, die können es doch besser als das. Das ist doch nicht der Weisheit, letzter Schluss. Das ist doch nicht der Anspruch von Apple, so ein komisches Gimmick-Gefrickel-Interface da zu bauen.
Doch, genau das ist der Anspruch von Apple. Das machen wir ja alle schwer.
Das ist doch nicht die Speerspitze der digitalen Revolution. Ich finde das auch ganz schön dünn, das sieht nach nichts aus.
Was ich mich frage ist, wird das mit iOS 6 dann ausgeliefert oder nicht?
Ich glaube, das wird immer ein App-Store bleiben. Warum?
War bei dem iBooks auch so, dass man das immer nachinstallieren muss?
iBooks, iTunes, University sind so alles Sachen, die du nachinstallieren musst. Es gibt ein paar Apple Remote, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, es gibt Sachen, die sind dabei bei dem Telefon und es gibt Sachen, die musst du ja nachinstallieren. Und ein Podcast wird dazu gehören, zu den Sachen, die du nachinstallieren musst. Ich glaube, die wollen auch gar nicht so großartig die mitgelieferten Apps so massiv erweitern. Das ist so... Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so Sachen wie der Compass und so sogar eher verschwinden werden. Aber ist jetzt wirklich noch einer.
Aber dieses Scrubbing, ey, das ist wirklich so ein Dreck. Na ja, dieses Vor- und Zurückspulen mit der Hand. da weiß ich echt nicht, was sie geritten hat. Das ist immer noch genauso wie vorher. Das ist immer noch genauso scheiße. Nimm mal diese rote Linie. So, und dann spulst du mal vor.
Genau.
Und wenn du das halt langsamer haben willst, dann musst du halt mit deinem Finger über den ganzen Bildschirm bis nach oben gehen und dann die Bewegung nach rechts machen. Womit sie natürlich dann auch nach wenigen Zentimetern der Fingerbewegung auch nicht mehr fortsetzbar ist. Also du kannst nicht längere Zeit langsam vorspulen, sondern eben nur so viel wie gerade auf deinem Bildschirm Platz ist. Danach musst du den Finger wieder runternehmen, wieder aufsetzen, wieder nach oben führen. Dabei total aufpassen, dass du das so vertikal wie möglich machst, weil wenn du irgendeine horizontale Bewegung machst, spult er natürlich sofort schnell vor. Ich meine, wenn überhaupt macht man den Default andersrum, dass du erst langsam spult und wenn du es schneller haben willst, machst du es schneller.
Das ist aber leider, wenn du YouTube-Videos guckst, bei den Videoplayers ja genauso. Wenn du oben slidest, geht es ja voll schnell. Du musst erst runterziehen, damit er es langsamer macht.
Genau, das ist durchweg im ganzen System, ist es bekloppt und hier ist es immer noch bekloppt. Und davon abgesehen verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, warum sie das überhaupt so machen. Ich meine, mal ehrlich, wie würdest du das machen? Wie würdest du ein User-Interface-Element machen, mit dem man beliebig schnell vor und beliebig schnell zurück spulen kann?
Ich würde einen Slider machen, der in der Mitte erst mal positioniert ist und je weiter du ihn nach rechts ziehst, desto schneller.
Umso schneller läuft es und in die andere Richtung rückwärts.
Das ist wie bei einer Bandmaschine so ein Ding.
Wie bei einer Bandmaschine?
Gibt es doch bei Videorekordern so dieses Dubbing-Dings? Das ist so ein halbes Rad, das so ein bisschen rausguckt und das ist in der Mitte in beide Richtungen gefedert. Und je mehr du das in die eine oder andere Richtung machst, desto schneller.
Das ist vor und zurück, genau. Das ist das absolut selbstverständliche User-Interface dafür. Und das hat auch den Vorteil, dass dir das nicht aus der Hand geht, weil du machst halt ein bisschen schneller, so.
Oder ein bisschen mehr oder noch mehr.
Du kannst es dann vor allem auch in der Position halten und behältst diese Geschwindigkeit dann bei. Und dann läuft es so lange, wie du hältst. Und hier kannst du halt nur so lange in einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit vorspulen, bis du halt am Ende des Bildschirms bist. Und vor allem, was ist das überhaupt für eine Denke, dass ich meinen Finger quer über alle anderen User-Interface-Elemente, die ich überhaupt nicht benutzen will, in dem Moment rüberschiebe und vielleicht sogar auch noch auf irgendetwas, was löschen heißt oder so, verweile. Ich meine, das soll Confidence geben beim User? Ich weiß nicht, was die da für Zeug nehmen bei Apple. Das ist mir völlig und völlig unklar.
Bubble Tea bestimmt.
Ja. Die sitzen da, ich glaub auch echt langsam, in Cupertino und vielleicht auch in Hamburg sitzen die jetzt einfach und schlürfen den ganzen Tag Bubble Tea. Sind total überzuckert.
Die gibt's auch direkt neben dem Dada, zum Bubble Laden.
Das sprießt jetzt überall. Wahrscheinlich hat ein Cupertino auch gerade einer aufgemacht und seitdem läuft irgendwie alles quer. Na ja, also there's good and there's bad. Ich bin nicht glücklich mit dieser App, so wie sie ist, weil sie macht das Benutzen von Podcasts nicht sehr viel einfacher. Da sind so zwei kleine Dinger drin. Okay, es gibt jetzt einen Kapitel, wie war denn das vorher? Vorher gab es Kapitel nur über die Kapitelliste. Es gab kein User Interface Element dafür. Jetzt hast du zumindest eins.
Also ich will jetzt sagen, es ist besser oder schlechter als vorher.
Aber die Elemente sind auch dann da, sie sind zwar ausgegraut, aber sie sind trotzdem sichtbar, selbst wenn es gar keine Kapitel gibt. Und es gibt keine, gibt es eine Kapitelliste? Hast du, hast du, kannst du mal gucken, ob du eine Liste der Kapitel kriegst?
Ich weiß es nicht. Da war doch dieses kleine Buch.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie 25 Kapitel hat, muss man dann 25 mal vorwärts drücken.
Ja, aber nimm das doch einfach.
Da gibt es doch diesen Button links, doch dachte ich da, diesen. Da gab es da so ein Lesezeichen-Button irgendwie. Ist der da nicht mehr? Machen wir mal diesen Podcast auf, der da. Irgendwie habe ich hier gerade im iTunes-Store hatte ich so einen Screenshot gesehen, hier den da.
Achso, das ist ein Bookmarks-Button. Keine Ahnung, haben sie ihn vielleicht vorher noch gewechselt? Und was gibt es nicht?
Das kann doch wohl nicht so schwer sein. Zumindest in diesem Info. Auch nicht in dieser Info-Show-Notes-Übersicht.
Aber was ist denn daran?
Ich meine, es gibt Fanboy. Du warst nämlich auf dieser Kloppenveranstaltung da.
Und die haben sich das Hirn gewaschen.
Es gibt in diesem App-Store...
Und da steht nämlich drin, du darfst nie wieder was Böses über Apple sagen.
Das steht da nämlich drin.
Es gibt in diesem App-Store ungefähr 100 verschiedene Podcast-Client. Sehr gute und sehr schlechte.
Und keine einzige fühlt sich jetzt in irgendeiner Form herausgefordert, irgendwas zu verbessern. Das ist der Punkt. Apple hat es geschafft, nach sieben Jahren eine Podcast-App rauszubringen. Und sie ist schlechter als alle anderen fünf, die da sind. Nach sieben Jahren? Ja, nach sieben Jahren, die es Podcast gibt. Seit 2005 gibt es Podcasts.
Es gibt überhaupt erst seit vier Jahren Apps.
Ist doch scheißegal. Sie haben sieben Jahre danach gedacht, nachdenken können, wie sie ihre User-Interfaces dafür machen. Sie haben doch schon vorher ein User-Interface dafür gehabt. Auf ihrem iPod. Da war es ja auch noch okay.
Da war alles noch okay.
Na okay, fünf Jahre Zeit gehabt, dieses Podcast-Interface hinzubekommen. Und das ist das Ergebnis, ich bin enttäuscht. Und das geht einfach nicht. Weil ich meine, ich würde mir doch verarscht vorkommen, so als Third-Party-Entwickler, da kommt dann Apple, fünf Jahre zu spät, fünf Jahre haben sie Zeit gehabt, über alles nachzudenken und dann kommt das. Ich meine, was soll man sich denn da bitte abgucken?
Hase, Schildkröte?
Demnächst wird nicht der Trappatoni eingespielt, sondern Tim.
Also, dass man einen Schieberegler hat, um die Geschwindigkeit einstellen zu können.
Also, das man dem was vorschlagen.
Das hat keine andere. Die haben alle immer brav von der Music-App dieses, du musst den Button fünfmal drücken, bis du wieder bei einfacher Geschwindigkeit zurück bist. Da haben sie nachgemacht. Insofern, so ein bisschen, ist das schon drin.
Total innovativ, ein Schalter, der von nichts an rechts geht.
Was sollte denn jetzt großartig Innovatives kommen?
Ja, einstellen, wie schnell du einen bestimmten Podcast normalerweise hören willst zum Beispiel.
Das interessiert, die meisten Leute hören Geschwindigkeiten auf Podcasts auf normaler Geschwindigkeit.
Das ist keine Innovation, das innovationsbefreite Software ist das.
Sowas von Apple, das fürs Giss halt nicht.
Es sind scheiß Podcasts, das hat keine Priorität bei denen. Da sitzen zwei Leute dran, macht mal eine Podcast-App, dann mach ich mal eine Podcast-App.
Ich meine, wenn ihr scheiß iFoto oder iMovie so aussehen würde, im Vergleich dazu, dann wäre das ja sozusagen, als möchtest du noch mit einem Filzer deine Bilder selber malen und mit einem Cutter aneinanderkleben mit Thesafilmen.
iFoto und iMovie hat auch Priorität bei denen. Das ist die Podcast-App.
Das ist einfach nicht gut. Das ist schlecht. Ich meine, was soll denn aus diesem Laden werden, wenn sie solche Absprache ausbringen?
Wenn sie keine Podcasts ernst nehmen.
Ja, dann sollen sie es lieber sein lassen.
Peek Apple, zwei Monate später.
Das ist durch der Laden. Bubble-Tea-Drinker. Na ja, sie sollen zumindest mal ihre Scheiß-Doku jetzt aufmachen. Man soll ja nicht mal erklären, was in ihren fucking Enhanced Podcast jetzt wirklich drin sein soll. Ich meine, jetzt kann man das wieder alles re-ingenieren und rausfinden, wie man die ganze Kacke auch noch für diese bekloppten Software da irgendwie hinkriegt. Wozu? Wozu eine Spezifikation eines Mediodaten-Formats, was aber im Internationalen Standard auf...
Ich meine, wenn das so scheiße ist, dann nutzt es doch eh keiner, dann sagt doch einfach, nehmt Instacast.
Ist doch okay.
Man muss die Software nicht nehmen.
Du, eine Menge Leute werden diese Software einfach nehmen, weil das was da drauf ist und was kostenlos ist.
Nee, das ist nicht drauf.
Ja, dann haben sie keine Kapitelmarken und dann kommen sie zu mir und sagen... Nee, dann sag ich nicht nur Instacast, sondern dann würde ich natürlich versuchen... Oder Downcast. Verstehst du das nicht? Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, den sie da definieren und sie definieren noch nicht mal, wie der ist. Das ist doch einfach schlecht. Ich prangere das an. Hart. Ich prangere hart. So, jetzt können wir vorspulen. Achso, was noch unklar ist. Also irgendjemand hat gesagt, man könne direkte Podcast-URLs abonnieren mit diesem Teil. Wenn man das in das Suchfeld eingibt, hab ich so recht nicht nachvollziehen können. Wenn ich das jetzt hier mit... könnte das mal einer überprüfen mit irgendwas, was nicht im Store ist, weil ich das Gefühl habe, er nimmt zwar die URL, sucht dann aber nach der URL und findet mir dann einen ähnlichen Feed, der so eine ähnliche URL hat. Ich hab jetzt bloß gerade kein Testszenario, mit dem ich das sicher überprüfen könnte.
Was macht der Chat in der Zwischenzeit vielleicht?
Dann bräuchte irgendwas, was sozusagen MP3 und Dings hat und danach weiß man auch, was man abonniert hat, weil das sagt der einem natürlich auch nicht, in welchem Dateiformat der ganze Kram ist.
Aber was man mal sagen muss, was mit dieser App geht, was vorher definitiv nicht ging, man kann den Client so benutzen, wie man so einen Podcast-Client nämlich benutzt, nämlich dass man ihn startet und er lädt alle Podcasts runter, die man so hatte, die sich seitdem angefunden haben. Das ist dramatisch besser als vorher.
Jaja, kann ich selber runterladen, aber er macht natürlich bei 50 Megabyte Schluss, also wenn deine Datei nicht... Auch über WLAN? Nein, nicht über WLAN, aber über 3G lädt er halt nicht mehr als 50 MB runter.
Wie das halt bei Apple so ist, ne? Ich meine, die haben halt ihre Verträge mit ihren Providern. Immerhin 50 MB oder was?
Ja, aber streamen kannst du es oder was? Kann der streamen?
Habe ich nicht geguckt.
Warte mal, kann der streamen? Woran erkennt man überhaupt, ob das Scheißteil geladen ist?
Und Huckel, was sagst du dazu?
Hab ich das schon gesagt.
Willi, ja.
Willi ist die Lösung. Die Podcast-Lösung.
Ja, streamen kannst du.
Streamen kannst du. Also du kannst irgendwie drei Stunden lang streamen im 3G, aber du kannst nicht runterladen.
Genau, macht doch auch irgendwie Sinn.
Ja, total. Es sind natürlich genau dieselben Daten, die dann runterkommen.
Moment mal, wenn sie es runterladen über 3G, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass es dir versehentlich passiert ist. Und zum zweiten, wenn du dann irgendwie anfängst... Wenn du anfängst, gigabyteweise Daten runterzuladen, also wirklich die Podcast runterzuladen, oder ob du in Echtzeitgeschwindigkeit so einen Podcast streamst und danach so einen 3-Stunden-Podcast fertig hast, ist doch ein großer Unterschied.
Ja Arsch, das sind meine Daten, ich zahle dafür. Ich hab mir extra so einen fucking Vertrag gekauft und lass mich da offiziell ausbluten lassen hier von dem Telekom Provider. Da will ich nicht noch, dass Apple mir noch kommt und sagt, ich darf das noch nicht meinen Anspruch nehmen.
Ach du bist jetzt Telekom-Opfer?
Nein, das ist doch alles Telekom. Ich meine das als Überbegriff. Telekom Business, wissen schon.
Ich dachte bei O2 gibt es gar kein Internet, kein mobiles.
Das kommt doch dazu, ja. Da muss man jede Sekunde nutzen, wo es mal geht. Da kann man nicht bei 50 MB aufhören.
Aber ich werde gerade darauf hingewiesen, es gibt keinen Coverflow.
Das stimmt.
Weite Schade, oder? Ich benutze das auch nicht.
Jetzt gucke ich erstmal, was hier überhaupt Top-Sender ist. Top-Sender. Im Bereich Neues aus der Technik. Mobimax auf Platz 2 hinter Bits und so.
Was? Hinter?
Aber immer noch vor Talkshow.
Die Fanboys gibt es auch noch, oder?
Klar, aber die sind in einer anderen Kategorie. Die trauen sich nicht über Neues aus der Technik zu reden, sondern die reden nur über Geräte. Die haben sich sozusagen in eine andere Unterkategorie geschoben.
Raffiniert, weil sie da dann uneingeschränkt Platz 1 sind, ja? Die wollen sich der...
Das ist spitz, finde ich.
Die wollen sich dem, wie sagt man...
Dem Mainstream entziehen.
Dem Kampf nicht stellen, der Auseinandersetzung.
Feiglinge.
Oder auch geschickte, gewiefte Taktik. Meine Taktik öfters mal ein Tic Tac.
Na ja, gut, also ich weiß nicht. Ich finde auch dieses komische Teil, da muss jetzt hier durch alles durchgehen. Irgendwie Wirtschaftsnachrichten.
Gut, dann jetzt Deckel drauf über dieses Thema, bei dem Max gefühlte 20 Mal einen demonstrativ tiefen Seufzer von sich gelassen hat. Perlten an ihm nur noch ab.
Ich weiß nicht, also mir fällt es irgendwie schwer, den Untergang einer Firma an einer kleinen App, die sie irgendwie rausbringen, zu erkennen.
Max, Max, Max, das ist alles nicht ernst gemeint. Wir machen nur Spaß. Wir wollen nur ein bisschen spielen.
Die Firma untergeht es mir an der Stelle vollkommen egal. Mein Nervenkostüm, das ist das, was hier passiert. Das passiert keinen. Toll. Mal sehen, was ihr davon habt.
Der Tim steigt jetzt auf Windows 8 um.
Ah, mein Bluetooth ist jetzt schon wieder kaputt. Toll.
Toll. Der Podcast wird jetzt umgenannt in Tim Tourette oder Mac Tourette.
Ich meine, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß hier irgendwie? Da stürzt einfach das Bluetooth komplett ab. Und der denkt, es wäre nicht mehr da.
Vielleicht hat der Gebrauchtwarenhändler, von dem du den Mac Pro hast, ein gebrauchtes Bluetooth-Modul dir eingebaut.
Ich finde in dem Zusammenhang auch diesen Lerneffekt. Jedes Mal stürzt das Bluetooth ab. Und jedes Mal regnet er sich so auf, als ob es das erste Mal passieren würde.
Ich habe gerade auf Ebay so eine Kabel-Tastatur gekauft. Und da ist es angestöpselt, damit da weniger Bluetooth-Geräte dran sind. Und wir sind heute auch nur zu viert. Das heißt, es sind zwei Bluetooth-Geräte weniger als sonst. Und jetzt stürzen sie schon wieder ab.
Das heißt, es liegt gar nicht an der Anlage.
Ach scheiße, vielleicht habe ich noch den Bluetooth-Jammer in meinem Rucksack.
Du hast das letzte Mal schon gesagt, dass du das nicht ausmachst.
Tim, achte mal ein bisschen auf deine Gesundheit.
Das ist ja gar nicht gesund, dich so aufzuregen. Du solltest immer so einen Bluetooth-Herz-Dings-Rhythmus testen.
Apple sollte sich mal Gedanken über meine Gesundheit machen.
Du meinst, deine Frau könnte Apple verklagen, wenn du dir immer tot umfällst am Rechner. Weil die die Sicherheitshinweise nicht beachtet haben.
Schlimm. Jetzt habe ich leider noch keine Kabelmaus gekauft. Ich dachte, so schlimm kann es ja wohl nicht kommen.
Back to the Kabel, ja?
Ja, Kabel ist auch das Einzige.
Ist deine Gamer-Maus dabei?
Nein, leider nicht.
Schade, die hätte ich jetzt gebrauchen können.
Naja, nächstes Mal bringe ich sie mit.
Seufz.
Ein schönes Diablo 3 auf dem Beamer zocken.
Aber guck, vielleicht kann ich ja irgendwelche anderen Maßnahmen ergreifen. Aber meiner Meinung nach muss ich das Ding hier wieder rebooten. Ja, ich muss den ganzen... nicht mal rebooten helfen, sondern nur ausschalten und wieder einschalten. So sieht's nämlich aus.
Du kannst auch nicht mal Bluetooth aus und wieder an und dann geht's? So der Windows-Trick? Nicht mal der Windows-Trick geht ja.
Naja, der Punkt ist, er zeigt mir, dass in den System-Preferenzen das Bluetooth-Symbol schon gar nicht mehr an, weil er mittlerweile davon ausgeht, dass er gar keinen Bluetooth mehr hat.
Das ist ein Hardware-Defekt.
Als hätte ich die Karte aus diesem Rechner herausgezogen.
Das ist ein Hardware-Defekt, den hatte ich bei meinem MacBook Pro. Hatt ich den mal. Nachdem da, ich glaub, was da reingelaufen ist.
Ist das eigentlich bei MacBook Pro noch eine Option? Bluetooth, das war doch mal eine Option.
Vielleicht, glaube ich nicht.
Vielleicht musst du mal reinpusten.
Genau, steck doch einfach mal so einen USB-Dongel rein.
Ich glaube, die verbauen ja schon noch einigermaßen Standard-Motherboards, oder? Dann ist das schon eine Karte.
Aber es passiert nur, wenn ich viele Geräte angemeldet habe.
Das spricht total dagegen, dass es ein Defekt ist.
Na, es klingt nicht so sehr nach Hardware, es klingt mehr nach Software.
Aber vielleicht wird es aber zu heiß und klar.
Das ist natürlich auch alles nur Software in dieser Hardware heutzutage.
Gut oder schnell?
Dann muss ich die Aufnahme und den Stream unterbrechen.
Oh, dann könnten die Hörer glatt ein halbes Stunde weiteres Podcast gerannt und verpassen. Wollen wir nicht mal über interessante Themen reden?
Was denn?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Nimm dir eine neue Podcast ab.
Was gibt's denn von Google? Habe ich auch verpasst.
Wollen wir nicht erstmal beim iPhone bleiben?
Nein, diese diversen Sachen. Egal.
Nüscht, wichtiges. Aber es gibt ein paar neue Sachen. Wollen wir noch mal beim Mac oder iPhone bleiben? Podcast ist ja im Prinzip beide. Eigentlich haben wir ja iPhone als Thema. Fünf Jahre iPhone.
Wieso?
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen? 5 Jahre iPhone, 5 Jahre... Ach, bis denn auf damals.
Ja, du hast dich nicht so gut gehalten.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so spannend.
Ich hab auch Runde Ecken.
Eine Menge Geld in den 5 Jahren gewandert von Richtung Nokia und Rim in Richtung Apple. Mir ist ja eigentlich nicht passiert.
Nicht nur eine Menge Geld, sondern das gesamte Geld.
Noch nicht ganz.
Das war eine galante Untertreibung, ja.
Ich meine jetzt von den Firmen an sich. Die sind ja noch schon so ein bisschen da.
Ja, aber sie kriegen kein Geld mehr.
Ja, aber sie haben noch ein bisschen was.
Ja, über, von früher. Das wird auch nicht mehr so lange halten, denk ich.
Tja, wo soll es hingehen mit dem iPhone?
Da interessieren mich schon in 5 oder in 10 Jahren so die Interviews mit den Jungs.
Okay, hat die richtige Frage gestellt.
Wie sieht es in 5 Jahren aus quasi, ne?
Das hab ich doch gerade gesagt. Nee, nicht wie es aussieht, sondern dass mich auch interessieren würde, wie die Interviews in 5 Jahren, so wie jetzt von dem, von dem der BIO erst gemacht hat, der gibt doch ab und zu mal Interviews und erzählt so ein bisschen von früher und so über seine Entscheidung und was er bereut und was nicht. Genau der und die Interviews will ich mal von den Rim-Jungs in 5 Jahren lesen.
Ich glaube, die werden nichts bereuen.
Die waren ja schon auch mal gut vorne, also die werden schon mal was zu erzählen haben, wo ihr Kardinalsfehler gelegen hat.
Na die haben, einer der Rim-Entwickler, der von den beiden Rim-CEOs, ich weiß nicht, welcher, hat ja in einem Interview gesagt, dass so, und das war eigentlich sehr weitsichtig, so es gibt so, es gibt unglaublich viele Firmen, gehen dran pleite, wenn sie, wenn sie Plattform wechseln. Also ein Plattformwechsel ist schwerer als gedacht, es gab überhaupt nur eine Firma, die einen Plattformwechsel geschafft hat bisher und das war Apple.
Und die gleich zwei Mal.
Und das war dann, kurze Zeit später fing Rim dann mit ihrem Rim, wie heißt es, Blackberry OS 10 und weiß der Teufel was, und probieren die Entwickler auf das neue System einzuschwören, was ja jetzt offensichtlich auch wieder nicht pünktlich kommt, sondern noch später als gedacht, bla bla bla.
Das sind sogar drei Wechsel eigentlich.
Fünf Wechsel hat Apple geschafft.
Fünf sogar, ich wollte gerade noch einen dazu nehmen. Also einmal von 68K nach PowerPC?
Nein, einmal von 65002 auf 68K.
Aber es war nicht wirklich ein Wechsel, oder?
Es war ja ein komplett neuer Schuh.
Also vorher haben sie nur Apple II und III gebaut und dann haben sie Macintoshes, ein kompletter Plattformwechsel.
Ja, aber sie mussten keine User mitschleppen in dem Sinne.
Ach nee? Nö.
Sie sind jetzt zur Amiga an einem Plattformwechsel.
Wir können uns jetzt die Haare da spalten, es war ein Plattformwechsel.
Du meinst, wir können die nicht spalten, weil es war ein Plattformwechsel.
Es ist nicht so, dass sie mit derselben Plattform gearbeitet haben, wie vorher, oder? So, und dann haben sie... 68K gemacht.
Dann PowerPC.
Das war der zweite Wechsel.
Dann erst mal überhaupt alle User nach OS X umgezogen.
Der dritte Wechsel.
Also so eine Art Softwarewechsel. Und dann haben sie noch mal nach Intel gewechselt.
Der vierte Wechsel. Hab ich fünf gesagt?
Ja, fünf gesagt.
Eins, zwei, achso, ja, okay, ich meinte fünf Plattformen, ja, okay. Vier Wechsel.
Wobei, bei dem ersten waren es ja noch nicht so viele User, ne?
Und Microsoft ist eigentlich irgendwie immer noch da, wo sie am Anfang auch schon mal waren, ne? A5-Gate, meinste? Richtig viel hat sich nicht geändert.
Na, sie haben immerhin das DOS dann doch irgendwann mal abgeschüttet, ne? Als Basis von allem.
Haben sie schon?
Aber die Wechsel gehen ja heutzutage so smooth, dass 32 nach 64 Bit bezeichnet man ja schon gar nicht mehr als Wechsel.
Ja, das stimmt, und eigentlich zu unrecht. Insofern hat Microsoft zumindest schon mal den 16 auf 32 Bit Wechsel vollzogen und sind irgendwie dabei jetzt auch den 64 Bit Wechsel zu vollziehen, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Mit sehr viel Anlauf und...
Man hat sich Zeit gelassen.
Ja, sehr behäbig, ja, aber sie haben es dann doch am Ende.
Es ist halt der Microsoft-Way, ich meine, das ist...
Also, den muss man ja immerhin zuguteilen.
Sie haben es überlebt, und sie haben dabei sehr oft sehr oft ausgesehen, Dana.
So viele Leute, die halt Snow Leopard fahren oder jetzt noch demnächst Line, wenn Mountain Line rauskommt, die sich dann ärgern, dass es von Apple keine ordentlichen Updates mehr gibt. Das sieht da bei Microsoft schon echt ein bisschen anders aus, muss man schon sagen. Ne, dass Microsoft länger ihre alten OS...
Ach so, das meinst du.
Also klar, kann man sagen, es liegt da drin, weil die alle nicht wechseln vorhin. Aber trotzdem finde ich es auch schon ganz okay, dass sie es halt machen. Ja, weil die halt wahrscheinlich doch schon auch eine Menge Enterprise-Zeugs oder Bürozeugs haben, wo die Leute keinen Bock haben immer.
Ja, die homogene Microsoft-Umgebung in so einem Mittel, also Mittel des großen Unternehmen mal zu upzudaten, das ist kein Zuckerschlecken. Da hat man erstmal ein bisschen abgehangen sein.
Ach, das ist ein Rauchbier, okay. Geräuchert oder was? Das riecht auch sehr geräuchert, äh, das schmeckt auch sehr geräuchert. Also man schmeckt es deutlich. Ich wollte gerade sagen Meta-Ebene, wo ich lernte, auf das Verfallsdatum von Birkwald.
Tja, an den fünf Jahren iPhone kann man sich auch irgendwie immer noch nicht so richtig vorstellen, was jetzt noch, also wenn man jetzt die letzten fünf Jahre sieht, was jetzt in fünf Jahren dann noch so, also es kann alles noch, und irgendwann hat man nur noch so eine Glasscheibe in der Hand und alles ist da mit drin, aber wann soll da eigentlich jetzt noch so viel toller werden?
Na die eigentliche Frage ist ja, was brauchen wir? Was wollen wir gerne machen?
Na man will natürlich den Star Trek-Kommunikator haben, ist doch klar. So und eigentlich brauchen wir nix weiter außer Display, Mikro, Kamera.
Also die totale Umgebungserfassung hätte ich ja auch gerne. Strahlendichte, weißt schon, so die ganzen Temperaturen, so den ganzen, ja diesen ganzen, ich will einfach so hier hinhalten und dann bin ich alle Infos, so wie wenn der Terminator in Teil 2 in die Bar reinläuft, so 50 Jahre Lederjacke, Sonnenbrille, falsche Schuhgröße, Scheiße, Nächster. Android-User, Android-User, iPhone-User.
Mir würde das schon reichen, wenn es mit Klamottenläden so geht, dass ich irgendwie auf so eine kleine Stange gucke und ich sehe sofort, was mir passt.
Du gehst noch deine Klamotten einkaufen, ich habe gehört, das ist modern, das ist alles online zu bestellen.
Nein, ich gehe noch nicht meine Klamotten einkaufen.
Das macht man alles online heutzutage.
Ich habe es gesehen beim Kumpel. Das passt nicht.
Das kann man zurückchecken.
Das will ich aber nicht.
Das wird zu stressig.
Das wird viel zu anstrengend.
Habe ich auch gedacht, wird so gemacht.
Ich meine, Computer könnten ja wohl mal locker selber rauskriegen, ob es mir passt oder nicht. Das ist nur echt eine absolut quantifizierbare Nummer.
Woher sollen die dann wissen, wie viel du in den letzten drei Wochen schon wieder gegessen hast?
Du gehst halt in deinen Scanner-Shop, der sozusagen der direkte Nachfolger des Kumpels ist. Na ja, dann halt einmal alle fünf Jahre. Das ist dann deutlich weniger. Moment, meine Füße nehmen jetzt nicht so häufig zu und die Schuhgröße ist relativ konstant. Und wenn du da wirklich das Gefühl hast, alle Schuhe, die du bestellst, passen dir nicht mehr, dann weißt du, dass du in diesen Scheißladen nochmal reingehen musst und kurz deinen Fuß in so eine Mulde reinstellst, wo es in 0,0 mit Laserstrahl abgetastet wird und dann kriegst du einfach auf dein iPhone direkt diesen Datensatz, mit dem du dann irgendwie online mit deiner App einfach sagen kannst, hier alle Schuhe, die mir passen, bitte anzeigen jetzt.
So.
Und dann kriegst du einfach mal nur Schuhe, die einfach passen bis zu einem bestimmten Level, wo du dann so einen Slider fahren kannst.
Und je weiter den du nach rechts schiebst, kannst du dieses Scrapping-Interface hier einbauen.
Und dann hast du aber irgendwie dein Schuh. Ich mein, das kommt. Ich mein, das ist einfach zu naheliegend, als dass es nicht sehr bald da ist.
Da hab ich einen schönen Vortrag von Gunter Dück drüber gehört. Der hat hier damals auf der Republika, letztes Jahr war das, 2011 hat er diesen Vortrag erhalten, diese berühmten.
Letztes Jahr oder vorletztes Jahr, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Auf jeden Fall hat er da einen relativ aufsehenderregenden Vortrag gehalten und den hab ich mal gesehen bei der Metro-Mittwochs-Gesellschaft, wo er vor dem versammelten Berliner Einzelhandel gesprochen hat, also so Einzelhandelsvertreter. Und da hat er genau über solche Sachen geredet, also wie das jetzt ins Netz wandert. Er hat das verglichen mit der Einführung der Waschmaschine. Das war ganz spannend, weil er hat so, also Online-Handel ist jetzt, wo die ersten Waschmaschinen sind. Und zwar war das wohl so, als die ersten Waschmaschinen kamen, da hatten die ganzen Klamotten noch nicht diese kleinen Zettelchen hinten drin, wie man die waschen darf. Und du hast halt die Wäsche reingeschmissen und die kamen raus und war kaputt oder eingelaufen oder wie auch immer, weil es gab keine Waschanleitung, weil das war auf Handwäsche ausgelegt. Und jeder, der gefragt hat, der hat gesagt, diese Waschmaschine setzt sich doch nie durch, weil macht ja alle Klamotten kaputt. Und dann haben sich einfach die Hersteller, haben sich dem angepasst und haben die Waschanleitung reingepappt, die Hersteller von den Klamotten. Und jetzt ist das absoluter Standard. Und er meint also dieses, das ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie das mit den Klamotten aussieht, aber das wird kommen und wir werden vermessen werden, wir werden in irgendeiner Form vermessen sein. Und wir stellen uns vor unsere Webcam und die macht ein Foto von uns und sagt uns alles klar, du hast die und die Größe und zwar nicht nur so irgendwie XL, LM, sondern so richtig mit allen Maßen und dann bestellst du den Scheiß und dann ist das viel besser, als du es im Laden jemals haben könntest.
Genau, Belto Order ist der nächste Schritt. Eigentlich möchte ich ja wieder richtige Schuhs da haben, die mir einen Schuh einfach auch auf den Leib schneidern. So richtig mit Handwerk und ja, gibt's schon, aber...
Klar, kann er bezahlen.
Naja, du hast halt ein Problem da irgendwie einen kompetitiven Preis zu bekommen. Wenn du aber deinen Scheiß-Fuß-Abdruck da dein dreidimensionales Netz stellst, dann kann ja halt jeder irgendwie sagen, ja hier...
Und Make a Bot erstmal eine Kopie und dann...
So und etwa.
Aber es gibt so einen Laden, wo du dich einmal vermessen lässt und danach machen die dir Anzüge nach Maß. Aus der Maschine, aus der Nähmaschine, also aus der...
Ja, gibt's den Computer gesteuert Nähmaschine.
Genau, der hat irgendwie 5 oder 6 Läden, haben die mittlerweile.
Na gut, also 5 Jahre iPhone, das ist jetzt sozusagen, aber ja noch nicht vielleicht das Ende.
Hey, die Frage war ja, was brauchen wir eigentlich, was uns Kommunikations- und Informationstechnologie irgendwie abnehmen möchte. Uns gibt natürlich in 5 Jahren auch immer noch denselben Bedarf, wie wir ihn vor 5 Jahren auch hatten. Wir wollen irgendwie schreiben, lesen, kommunizieren, etc. Und das iPhone hat definitiv den neuen Weg gezeigt, wie man das lieber macht als bisher. Zumindest in neuen Situationen, aber eben auch mit dem iPad in vielen alten Situationen. Oder auch zu Hause neu, weil Sofa war bisher noch nicht unbedingt der Computing-Platz, aber so ein Laptop schon und das iPad dann schon noch eher. Es ist schwer abzusehen, wohin die Reise geht. Auf jeden Fall, wenn wir viel mehr Bandbreite haben in 5 Jahren over the Air, dann darf man dann wahrscheinlich auch bei Apple Podcasts mal runterladen, die 50 MB groß sind.
Vielleicht sogar 100.
Vielleicht sogar 100. 50 darf man jetzt schon.
100 ist bestimmt in 5 Jahren kein Problem sein.
In 5 Jahren?
Kein Problem.
Vielleicht sogar 150.
In 5 Jahren dürfen wir dann doppelt so lang reden sozusagen.
Tim kann sich in doppelter Speedart aufregen.
Nee, halb so schnell.
Halb so schnell.
Bei voller Bitrate.
Ich will Facelime ohne Video. Also ohne Face sozusagen.
Ich will Facelime ohne das Gerät zu halten. Aber so diesen Trikorder-Ansatz, den finde ich schon immer noch auch sehr spannend. Komplette Umgebungserfassung und Awareness, wo man gerade ist, wie man gerade ist.
Welches Feature am Trikorder?
Alles. Hältst du an deinem Kind dran, sagt der, was das hat. Wie es heißt.
Komm mal teile auch gleich.
Dieses Kind heißt Benjamin.
Wenn du so, weiß nicht, irgendwie, irgendwie, weiß nicht, hältst du halt so in einem, hältst dein Telefon in so einer Masse so vom, vom, vom Sprecherpult und der sagt dir, wie viele Leute im Raum sind und so Kram halt.
Oder wer dein Telefon geklaut hat.
Wer dein Telefon geklaut hat auch. Wie gesagt, so diese ganzen Sensoren, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen Nerd-Traum, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber warum nicht? Meines wird doch eh alles klein genug und warum nicht einfach mal ordentlich niesen?
So was könntest du vorhersehen.
In deinem iPhone niesen und er sagt dir gleich, welcher.
Wie lange du noch zu leben hast.
Ich will eigentlich auch, dass ich mir mein Telefon sagt, wenn ich mit dem Motorrad unterwegs bin, dass es mich warnt, dass es bald regnet und dass ich vielleicht mal früher nach Hause fahre.
Das werde ich ja sowieso mal haben. Eine App, wo ich eine Strecke angeben kann, da möchte ich jetzt hin, von da nach da werde ich nass. Einzige Information, die ich brauche. Ob Winter ist oder Sommer, weiß ich im Zweiten Sommer selber. Aber ich glaube auch, dass so integral, also nicht so über Sensorik, dass ich halt meinem Telefonraum sage, wie viele Personen da sind.
Na ja, es sind halt mit Kamera, Face Detection, wird halt alles besser, hochauflösender.
Da kannst du ja doch alle find friends, siehst du doch alle, dass die da sind.
Stimmt, einfach nach Bluetooth-Geräten scannen und schon weißt du das. Ich meine, du lädst die dann bei Facebook, der Kontaktdate. Aber ich glaube so, dass du diese Integration von, wir haben heute aus irgendeinem Grund ein LG-Telefon zugeschickt gekriegt, da ist so ein kleiner NFC-Aufkleber dabei. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz, ganz hübsch. Da ist so ein NFC-Aufkleber dabei und den soll man sich, ich habe den Aufkleber selber gesehen, wohl ins Auto kleben, quasi unter die Stelle, wo man das Telefon dann zum Laden reinpackt und dann weiß das Telefon immer, dass es im Auto ist und schaltet sich selbstständig in den Auto-Modus um. Was auch immer das heißt. Ich glaube, das ist dann so ein einfaches Interface, was natürlich geil wäre, wenn sie beim Aussteigen sich dann sagen, aha, der Auto-Aufkleber ist weg, ich bin aus dem Auto raus, da merke ich mir mal schnell die Position, damit ich die Karre wieder finde.
Also ist nicht nur ein Aufkleber, sondern so ein kleines RFID-Ding oder einfach passend für NFC.
Aber das zählt ja sozusagen auch so ein bisschen in der Insorik und Awareness von seiner Umgebung.
Also sowas muss auf jeden Fall kommen.
Ich hab noch zwei gute Dinge, die ich über die Podcast-App sagen kann.
Oh ne, nicht nochmal die Podcast-App. Der Zug ist abgefahren. Das Band ist durch, sag ich mal.
Das Band ist gerissen.
Ja, wir haben was falsch gesagt.
Wir? Ach jetzt wir.
Wir haben hier schön die Fresse gehalten, wer ist du?
Falsch gesagt.
Ihr seid mir Freunde.
Wer austeilt muss auch korrigieren können. Also erstens, was ich nämlich total übersehen habe, ich weiß bloß nicht ganz genau warum.
Magst du die gar nicht?
Kann man diese Ruhezustandsgeschichte, also wann er sozusagen sehr sleeping timer, auch einstellen mit nach Ende dieses Kapitels und nach Ende dieser Folge. Und wenn man das immer anhat, dann hat man endlich mal wieder automatisch ein Ende nach dem Abspielen. Das ist eigentlich ganz klug. Und was wir nicht erwähnt haben ist, man kann auch suchen. Das ist nämlich absurd. Also zum Beispiel fehlt das Instacast vollständig dieses Feature. Wenn du nämlich ganz viele Podcasts, ganz viele Episoden hast und du suchst einfach mal die Folge, wo über XY gesprochen wurde.
Über Willi.
Genau, über Willi. Dann kannst du halt hier das machen. Genau.
Ja, gut, Podcast korrigiert.
Und es scheint sogar die gesamte, die ganzen Show-Notes zu dich suchen.
Traum.
Core Data at its best.
Ah, jetzt ist er auch gleich abgestürzt dabei.
Also doch nur zwei Sachen. Die dritte nimmst du schon wieder zurück gerade.
Nee, ich hätte auch nur zwei gesagt, oder?
Gut, also abgesehen von Schulkaufen und ein bisschen Umgebungs-Awareness fällt uns jetzt auch erstmal nichts besseres ein für die fünf Jahre. Leichter, schneller, besser.
Also an Hardware irgendwie nicht, aber hier Siri muss einfach... Also ich finde, Siri, hab noch keinen gesehen, außer für Timer irgendwie ordentlich einsetzt. Oder irgendwie so billig, schnick, schnack.
Ihr habt euch ja die Google-Kino wahrscheinlich alle nicht angeguckt.
Nee.
Vielleicht ging es ja genau um das Thema.
Siri muss halt in Richtung Kommunikator weitergehen. Oder wie Mother by Alien, der Hauptcomputer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich... So dieses mit dem Computer reden, du hast das irgendwann mal creepy genannt. Ich bin da mittlerweile so dieses so... Mich mit meinem Telefon unterhalten, will man das? Also es geht doch über eine Tastenbewegung im Allgemeinen. Also wenn das nicht wirklich einen gigantischen Vorteil hat, weil man plötzlich so unglaublich viel mehr machen kann, wenn ich es mit dreimal aufs Display tappen wortlos auch im leisen Raum machen kann, warum soll ich dann...
Es geht da gar nicht so direkt ums Telefon an sich. Also wahrscheinlich ist es das Telefon, weil das hast du halt immer bei dir. Aber ich stell mir halt auch so vor, ich komme irgendwie nach Hause, schmeiß meine Jacke in eine Ecke, den Rucksack in die andere.
Und dann......schmeißst du du make me a sandwich.
Sonst schmeiß ich mich selbst auf die Couch und sag ich hier mach mal Fernseh an, hier Endspiel kommt gleich und mach mal, ich will Fernseh gucken und mach mal ein bisschen lauter noch. So, halt in die Richtung.
Aber meinst du... Aber gerade Fernbedienung. Stell du dir das mal vor, wenn du jetzt nach Hause kommst, du setzt dich auf deinen Sofa und dann sagst du, schalte doch mal bitte den Fernseher an, und zwar hier das Endspiel, achso und mach mal ein bisschen lauter und führst da so irgendwie eine komische Konversation mit so einem Gerät, das machst du doch nicht.
Ne eben, das ist ja auch das Ding, das ist halt eben kein Gerät mehr, ich wähl da halt ne Stimme, die sich mit mir unterhalten kann. Also das wird wahrscheinlich in den nächsten 5 Jahren...
Das ist aber irgendwie ein bisschen traurig jetzt, dass Dennis...
Du brauchst ne Freundin.
Du nutzt deine Freundin nur, um dein Fernsehen zu machen.
Aber so zur Unterhaltung und ne Frau...
Ich will mich ja nicht mit dir unterhalten, aber ich will schon, dass die versteht. Und wenn sie mich nicht versteht, dass sie nachfragen kann. Oder eher, ist mir doch egal.
Du verstehst mich einfach nicht.
Aber so wie bei...
Dann musst dich von deiner Fernbedienung trennen.
Du hast noch eine neue! Es gilt ja auch für andere Sachen. Sag mir, ob es regnet oder nicht. Alles Mögliche, was man wissen will. Ich will nicht mehr tippen, ich will sprechen. Zuhause, unterwegs vielleicht eher weniger.
Ich will das eigentlich... Ich will nicht mal sprechen, ich will, dass das gedankenmäßig gleich umgesetzt wird.
Also ich möchte, dass Siri mich warnt, bevor ich ein Rauchbier aufmache. Man kann es trinken, aber es ist trotzdem sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber bei Bier ist immer so eine Sache. Man muss erst mal zu Ende trinken und dann muss man gucken, ob es immer noch schmeckt.
Schöne Farbe.
Sieht aus wie Cola.
Mal testen.
So.
Das ist aber wirklich sehr speziell.
Das ist tatsächlich das. Ich war mal in der Brauerei. Das ist aus Bamberg.
Ich war auch schon mal.
Ich war in der Brauerei drin, wo das gemacht wird. Da kann man auch essen und so.
Das ist alles fränkische Biere. Das habe ich schon erwähnt.
Das gibt es ja irgendwo in Bamberg.
Das kannst du dir bestellen. Hier gibt es bier.de. Du bekommst eine ganze Kiste voll random. Die Kiste ignoriert die erste. Aber ich bekomme dann noch eine zweite. Seitdem bin ich vollkommen bekehrt. Da kriegst du dir eine random Kiste. Dann hast du eine Kiste mit irgendwie n verschiedenen Bieren aus Frankenland. Das ist der Ort, wo das mit dem Bier noch funktioniert. Das ist das gallische Dorf des Bierbrauens.
Geht auch gut mit Skittles.
Also Rauchbier ist echt speziell.
Echt speziell? Weiß man aber jetzt noch nicht, ob du das gut oder schlecht meinst.
Was wie?
Wenn du sagst, das ist echt speziell, da weiß man noch nicht, ob du das gut findest oder schlecht.
Also ne, die Brauerei ist... Der Laden war super, da gab es auch geiles Essen und sowas.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn das jetzt nicht jedem schmeckt, aber ich finde das eigentlich ganz cool.
Max hat sich kaufen lassen, ich hör schon. Das Bier schmeckte nicht, aber der Laden ist ganz geil, weil das Essen war gut. Das heißt, die haben dich gekauft.
Ich war davor... Das ist alles Apple NDA. Muss auch jetzt alle Bammdanger Brauereien gut finden.
Okay, ich seh schon, dass mit der Zukunftsvision, das kriegen wir hier nicht richtig auf die Reihe.
Und natürlich die Uhr, die fehlt ja noch.
Das Bier und die Vision, das glaubt man nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, da bin ich auch noch nicht so komplett raus aus dem Gedanken. So eine weitere Miniaturisierung und Tragbarkeit könnte durchaus auch noch irgendwie kommen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war.
Auf der WWDC hatte einer eine Uhr. Also auch so eine komplett programmierbare, die per Bluetooth 4 funktioniert. Und es gibt ja auch diese Pebble, wie hieß die gleich? Diese Uhr, die unglaublich viel Geld eingesammelt haben, wo wir dachten, was wird die denn alles können?
Die Uhr, die alle kaufen wollen und die kann gar nichts?
Genau. Aber die hat Bluetooth 4 und das Bluetooth 4 SDK schon in iOS 5 kann unglaublich viel. Es ist ja sehr, sehr schwer, Peripherie in irgendeiner Form ans iPhone ranzukriegen. Wenn man unten an Doc Connector ran will, dann muss man Knebelverträge mit Apple unterschreiben. Darum gehen ja auch viele oben über diesen merkwürdigen Mikrofoneingang, was ja eher so eine schlechte Lösung ist. Aber mit Bluetooth 4 geht dann plötzlich unglaublich viel. Und auch so ein SMS-Status und Telefon-Status und diese ganzen Sachen alle rüber schicken und so was. Und ja, da sind also ein paar Leute dran. Bluetooth 4 wird auch kommen.
Und was kann Bluetooth 4?
Sehr, sehr stromsparend sein.
Und sonst noch irgendwas? Das war auch generell so eine schnellere Discovery, ohne so einen komplizierteren...
Stimmt, die hatten einen schnelleren Verbindungsaufbau.
Die hatten einen unglaublich schnellen Verbindungsaufbau.
Handshake war schneller.
Genau. Was dazu führt, dass das Gerät, also zwischen zwei Datenpaketen, dass die auch die Verbindung wieder abbauen können, was unter anderem dazu beiträgt, warum die so laut und so unglaublich stromsparend ist. Also du kannst eine Tastatur bauen, die sich zwischen den Tastenanschlägen ausschaltet. Und dann wieder, sobald du gedrückt hast, eine Verbindung aufbaust. Es gibt so kleine... Es gibt da relativ viel zu kaufen. Ein Kollege von mir ist auf das Thema total abgefahren. Es gibt so kleine Bluetooth-4-Biegens, einfach nur. Das sind so einfach kleine Dinger mit Knopfzelle. Durchmesser, sag ich jetzt mal, so 4, 5... Also keine Ahnung, wie groß die sind. Also relativ klein, mit einer Knopfzelle drin. Halten angeblich ein paar Jahre durch. Schmeißt einfach irgendwo hin. Soll nicht die Welt kosten. Und dann erkennt dein iPhone sozusagen, aha, hier ist wieder ein Bluetooth-Gerät, ein Bluetooth-Biegen. Und jetzt kann ich irgendeine Aktion auslösen. Und die können auch Apps starten, diese Bluetooth-4-Geräte. So von sich aus, ohne irgendwelchen To-o-ba-bo. Also sobald das Gerät irgendwie in der Nähe ist, frag dich dein iPhone, hey, dieses Bluetooth-Gerät würde jetzt auf deinem Telefon, also nur, wenn es schon vorher mal gepährt hat, ist dann sowas, folgende App starten. Dann sagst du ja. Und dann startet die App. Geht alles mit iOS 5. Haben wir alle gar nicht mitbekommen.
Mhm, weil es niemand benutzt.
Weil es bisher noch niemand benutzt. Und weil es so total unauffällig war.
Ich frage mich ja, ob das, ob nicht Apple, wenn dieser ganze NFC-Kram, Near Field Communication, mit hier eigener Chip drin und so weiter für diesen ganzen Bezahlkram. Wozu braucht man da noch einen eigenen Chip, wenn man da auch Bluetooth nehmen kann?
Ich glaube auch nicht an NFC.
Also ich glaube schon an solche Terminals und gerade im Sinne von diesem Passbook.
Also Passbook wird, glaube ich, auch hoffentlich gut werden.
Ja und vielleicht setzen sie da auch einfach auf... Ich meine, wenn du so ein iPad hast als Kasse und du hast ein iPhone, wo das Ticket drauf ist, wäre das nicht das einfachste, dass das iPad, was die Kasse ist, einfach direkt über Bluetooth 4 mit diesem anderen Telefon kommuniziert und darüber irgendwie diesen Ticket austauscht.
Definitiv, ist eine gute Lösung auf jeden Fall. Also, das geht.
Brauchst du keinen neuen Stein dafür? Du hast jetzt schon Milliarden Geräte oder Millionen zumindest da draußen, die das schon alle jetzt schon können. Oder ist Bluetooth 4... Ist das eine reine Software-Geschichte?
Nee, nee, das ist schon Hardware. Also mein MacBook, das 2011er MacBook kann das, das iPhone, ich weiß nicht, ob es 4 schon, 4S auf jeden Fall. Also es ist relativ neu noch alles.
Also die ganzen coolen Features wie Stromsparen und schnellere Aufbau ist natürlich hardware-bedingt auch. Aber sonst können die auch runterschalten natürlich. Und das alte Protokoll nehmen.
Wo steht denn sowas eigentlich?
Aber NFC hat schon noch den Vorteil, dass es halt diese total passive, also dass du irgendwo einen Aufkleber hin machen kannst und der ist dein Gegendevice, dass du da nicht mehr...
Hast du gesagt, das geht mit Bluetooth auch?
Ne, da brauchst du immer noch eine Knopfzelle. Also das irgendwo auf ein Produkt kleben oder sowas, dass das standardmäßig draufklebt, das geht damit halt nicht. Ich weiß nicht...
Ja, das wollen die mal genau darüber nachdenken, weil es nämlich ganz gut wäre, wenn die irgendwann auch mal nicht mehr gehen. Weil stell dir vor, in 100 Jahren liegen überall Milliarden von NFC-Teilen rum und nichts geht mehr.
Woran kann man denn sehen, ob der eigene Computer Bluetooth 4 kann?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Bestimmt im System Profiler.
Weißt du, wie heißt das hier Mac?
Mein MacBook kann das auf jeden Fall. Was macht sich da jetzt so sicher?
Weil du ja auch einen 2011er hast, ne?
Also hier in deinem System Profiler, da steht alles zum Thema Bluetooth.
Da seh ich aber keine Information, ob Bluetooth 4 unterstützt ist.
Ist das nicht HCI 4 vielleicht? HCI Version?
Apple Bluetooth Software Version 405, aber ich glaub nicht, dass es mit Bluetooth 4 zu tun hat.
Das würd ich auch meinen.
Na gut, dann sagt der Profiler das nicht, aber vielleicht sagt der Mac-Tracker das.
Ja, Mac-Tracker sagt das bestimmt.
Der hat ja noch nicht mal die aktuellen MacBook Airs.
Macbook Pro, Late 2011 und das hat...
Bluetooth 2.1 plus EDR.
Das ist aber das Alte.
17 Inch.
Late 2011. Okay, was hab ich denn jetzt hier gerade? Ich hab einen Late...
Das sieht mir sehr nach einem 15 Zoll aus.
Ja, aber ich hab glaub ich einen Early 2000. Da steht auch 2.1 EDR.
Und steht denn bei dem aktuellen überhaupt hier Bluetooth 4?
Also das iPhone 4S hat Bluetooth 4. Und die neueren Macs seit 2011 haben Bluetooth 4.
Aber meinen sie noch nicht von März 2011, ne?
Da war wahrscheinlich der Break genau Mitte 2011. Mit den R's.
Nee, sieht so aus, als ob hier das... Nee, nee, das Laid 2011 MacBook Pro 15 Zoll.
Halt's auch noch nicht?
Wieso hat hier eigentlich noch keiner Retina auf dem Tisch?
Ich hab's in der Firma jetzt gesehen.
Und?
Wir sehen ja.
Also...
What a scene cannot be unseen.
Also was... Also ich durfte nur mal kurz spielen, ja. Und ich durfte da nicht an den Settings-Gruß rumdrehen, weil er hatte seinen Desktop da so mit den Fenstern und alles so perfekt hingeschoben. Und hätte ich da jetzt die Einstellung verändert, dann wär alles verrückt.
Und dann...
Alles wär total verrückt. Aber er hat das in der Best-Forretina-Einstellung gehabt. Und ich hab mal so ein bisschen geschaut und ein paar Sachen aufgeklickt. Also das Erste, was einem auffällt, ist, dass Text halt unglaublich geil aussieht. Also es ist wirklich eine Wonne an seinen Terminals schon alleine. Also ein paar Terminals schon offen und das ist einfach, so muss das aussehen.
Mal wieder zurück beim Drucker-Terminal, ja?
Ja, also besser, glaube ich, noch besser einfach. Sieht wirklich extrem gut aus.
Besser als 24 Nadeln?
Ich glaub schon, ja.
Das war damals High DPI.
Zum Thema Spiegelung, also ich bin da immer noch kein Fan von. Also was man halt sieht, wenn man jetzt vom klassischen Glossy-Screen sieht, dann sieht man meistens so seine Kante und dann noch so eine leichte Ghosting-Kante daneben. Also es ist so, man sieht so ein, also ich sehe es jetzt dabei, Dennis zum Beispiel, wenn ich in dein iMac-Display gucke, dann ist da immer noch so Dennis und dann noch mal so ein Schatten von Dennis so leicht versetzt. Und das ist...
Warten, ich guck jetzt nur einmal. Nee, ich seh mich nur einmal. Aber ich guck auch genau gerade vielleicht, deswegen.
Also ich seh ihn zwar mal. Ja, ich auch.
Und das hier bei dir und deinem Kopf, das ist ganz leicht.
Ich vermute, das liegt jetzt daran, dass ihr halt eine Scheibe weniger habt. Also ich hab mir das alles aus verschiedenen Winkeln angeguckt, aber letztendlich muss man sagen, es ist immer noch Glossy und ihr 75% weniger Glare-Claim ist kompletter Bullshit, aus meiner Sicht. Also ich hab dann nicht 75% weniger Glare gesehen, sondern ich kann mich dann immer noch rasieren in diesem Display, wenn ich es ausmache. Und das nervt mich halt schon extrem, deswegen bin ich da noch ein bisschen reserviert. Also Farben super, Auflösungen extrem geil, also es sieht wirklich gut aus, und auch so Ups, die es halt nicht unterstützen, also man fällt da jetzt nicht so spontan auf, dass da irgendwas jetzt noch nicht richtig ist. Habe ich jetzt Movies halt nicht geguckt. Na gut, Movies haben ja eh nicht so viele Pixel, also das ist auf jeden Fall...
HD hat doch 1920, da muss doch runterskaliert werden. Für so einen Macbook Pro.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber wie du immer sagst, das ist schon ein geiles Display, aber wie gesagt, ich mag das Glossy nicht. Und so Gewicht? Also so von der Haptik und so weiter, und ich hab's natürlich auch nochmal in die Hand genommen und mal so die Kanten abgefahren und so, ne? Ist auf jeden Fall sehr... Ja, mit dem... Nee, ohne Willi diesmal.
Hast du den Willi reingesteckt?
Nee, auch nicht, der hat da nicht erlaubt. Aber das mit dem Gewicht, also, sagen wir mal so, man merkt schon, dass es leichter ist, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so super dramatisch viel leichter, dass man jetzt sagt, ach, da war ich ja gar kein MacBook, eher so, wem sozusagen das Gewicht immer noch so eins der wichtigsten Faktoren ist, dem ist das wahrscheinlich immer noch zu schwer.
Ja, aber ein halber Kilo müsste sich schon doch bemerkbar machen.
Ja, aber es sind ja immer noch zwei, ne? Und das MacBook eher, wenn das ist halt noch mal ein ganzes Ecken weniger, also...
Oh, das 13 Zoll hat immerhin 1350 Gramm? Naja, aber ich hab...
Aber ist das wirklich ein halbes Kilo? Nee, das ist doch gar nicht ein halbes Kilo leichter.
Doch, von zweieinhalb auf 1,0 und ein bisschen sind, also mindestens 450 Gramm.
Ja, also man merkt, wie gesagt, man merkt es auch, aber ich denke, dass die Leute, die halt irgendwie da auf Ultra-Portabilität setzen, da jetzt auch nicht weich werden und sagen, ach ne, dann nehm ich doch wieder ein Pro. So war jetzt mein Eindruck so vom Anfassen.
Also hat es jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht die Normal-, die automatisch diesen Kaufreiz.
Naja, also ich hab ja sowieso, also wenn sich so viel bei einem Mac-Rechnermodell ändert, bei einem Generationswechsel, dann warte ich ja sowieso immer erstmal auf die zweite. Vor allem bin ich gespannt, wie groß sozusagen die Beschwerden von den ganzen Foto- und Film-Leuten sind. Also vor allem die Fotoleute, die machen ja immer den größten Aufschrei wegen dem Glossy. Ob sie nochmal weich werden und sich da irgendwas einfallen lassen bei der nächsten Generation. Also mein Rechner ist einfach noch auch gut genug. Der ist schnell genug, der ist einfach gut genug. Ich hab jetzt nicht unbedingt das Bedürfnis direkt, aber ich brauch's nicht. Wenn der jetzt irgendwie noch ein Jahr alt ist und die nächste Generation raus ist...
Aber die haben doch in Full HD-Spielen, also man weiß schon, in Rechina, das ist ja gut.
Es würden ein paar Leute geben, die wollen das unbedingt haben. Vor allem Programmierer, die jetzt für die Plattform was machen im Videobereich, Leute, die was davon haben, Photoshopper etc., die werden sonst nicht so ein Teil kaufen. Insbesondere wenn sie auf den anderen scheißen. Jetzt hier so Internet und so weiter erstmal scheißen.
Also ich denke auch, dass das eher so ein Gerät ist für Leute, deren Rechner jetzt eh schon 2 oder 3 Jahre alt ist und so langsam, man merkt ja irgendwann so, ist das nicht mehr schön, alles wird labberig und ranzig und komisch. Und jetzt so überlegen, ich kann mir mal einen neuen kaufen, dann ist das wahrscheinlich schon das Gerät.
Oder habt ihr da eigentlich eher so ein Kabelnetz?
Na, wir haben alle Ethernet am Platz und die Backend-Jungs, die haben auch alle ein Kabel im Rechner. Aber es gibt auch...
War das in dem Fall so einer?
Nee, der hatte noch keinen Adapter, der hatte WLAN. Also bei uns, wir haben auch... Ich find diesen Adapter echt störend.
Der so weit rausguckt, ja?
Ja, weil der so weit rausguckt.
Bei mir ist halt auch so... Bei mir steht das Notebook halt auf so einem Ständer-Dings da, aus so einem Podest, wie auch immer, damit das mit dem großen Display so einigermaßen auf der Höhe ist und man nicht die ganze Zeit so runterguckt und eult.
Weil ihr beide gleichzeitig benutzt.
Und ist halt auch angenehmer ergonomisch gesehen, wenn du halt so hochguckst, statt so eulich runterhockst. Und dann baumeln ja da schon jetzt so die Kadaver, die Kabeladapter so runter. Und, weiß nicht, also bei dem, wie du letztens schon meintest, mit der Hebel wirken, das könnte auch vielleicht nicht so gut funktionieren. Ja, das ist ja auch glossy. Und das Problem ist bei uns im Büro ist wirklich, wir haben halt von zwei, also vorne und rechts Fenster und ich hab Fenster an der Seite. Und dann musst du halt irgendwie, du siehst einfach...
Ich sollte da so ein glossy Büro machen, wo sich die Leute alle mit ihren glossy Laptops einsetzen und die Brose dann dunkel machen.
Also du kannst halt beim Kollegen nicht auf den Bildschirm sinnvoll gucken. Man muss da wirklich so hinter ihm, hinter seine Schulter kriechen, um dann noch eine Chance haben, was zu erkennen, oder die Schalusinen runter machen. Dann hast du ja irgendwie Sommer draußen und sitzt trotzdem in einer dunklen Bude. Also, ich find glossy einfach scheiße. Und die meisten, also wir hatten auch irgendwie, die Standard MacBooks waren irgendwie immer glossy für die Mitarbeiter. Und jetzt haben sich einfach auch so viele beschwert, dass jetzt der Admin da oder der Typi halt jetzt erstmal einen ganzen Stapel wieder non-glossy MacBooks geholt hat. Und ja, also da hab ich, ich hoffe echt, dass sie da noch irgendwas hinkriegen. Kann nicht die Antwort sein für die Zukunft, diese Spiegel-Scheiße. Ja, da bin ich auch gespannt, was sie dann mit dem, also wenn sie das auf Retina umstellen, wie sie das dann da machen. Ob man diese Scheibe da unbedingt braucht oder ob es nicht, also...
Auch ohne geht.
Ja, kann man ja echt nicht vorstellen, dass die Leute das da auch alle toll finden, das verstehe ich nicht, aber gut. Dennis find's ja auch gut.
Also ich hab ja nun das R und...
Ist das schon das Neue?
Nee.
Nicht das Zwölfer, nein. Also ich hab jetzt genauso wenig Upgrade-Urge, weil... Könnte vielleicht theoretisch unter Umständen sein, dass es etwas weniger lüftet, aber... Das Hauptproblem ist derzeit die Software, die hier irgendwie alles zum Lüften bringt. Ich glaube, das wird auch bei dem aktuellen Gerät genauso durchdrehen. Ich bin eh kurz davor, hier mal wirklich komplett wieder den Reset zu machen und wieder von Null auf Installation zu machen.
Zwei Wochen kannst du jetzt auch noch warten.
Wie zwei Wochen?
Mountainline.
Ach, du meinst, da ist noch was besser?
Nee, aber da musst du eh neu installieren. Aber es ist doch schön, das kannst du automatisch jedes Jahr machen, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ja, stimmt das. Die Scheiße kommt ja schon zwei Wochen raus. Ich hab ja Gutes gehört.
Über den Termin oder über Mountainline?
Über Mountainline.
Das geht?
Abgesehen davon, dass sie das mit diesem Fullscreen immer noch nicht gefixt haben.
Aber ich dachte, letztens hat doch einer im Chat behauptet, das wäre so.
Wäre was wie?
Na, dass Fullscreen irgendwie viel toller wäre.
Ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen Missverständnis. Das Einzige, was da toller ist, dass du wieder das machen kannst, was du vorher auch schon machen konntest, dass du sagen kannst, auf welchem Bildschirm er das machen soll, aber die anderen sind immer noch alles schwarz. Ja.
Dieses Base des Fullscreens haben sie verkackt. Das war bei Snow Leopard so cool und... Space ist ein Fullscreen, hab ich gesagt. Das gehört ja so ein bisschen zusammen, finde ich. Und es war so geil, weil Snow Leopard hat echt, ich hab echt das Prima im Griff gehabt.
Tja, früher war alles besser. Na gut. Ich hab noch eine Sache für Mac, eine Frage, bevor wir dann vielleicht mal zu Google kommen. Ich benutze ja gerne mal so VPN-Provider. Und hab mir auch mal so ein Jahresaccount hier bei BlackVPN geschoppt. Jetzt hab ich vor kurzem aber festgestellt, dass ich irgendwie die ganzen Dinge jetzt gar nicht mehr so richtig umgehen kann, die ich umgehen will. Weil die Webseiten alle jetzt mit IPv6-Adressen kommen und dann der Mac irgendwie IPv6-Routing macht, aber diese VPN-Dinger irgendwie nur IPv4 machen. So würde ich sozusagen mein eigenes VPN wieder umruten. Das ist zumindest jetzt meine Theorie, was passiert, weil anders kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr erklären, aber irgendwie sehe ich in diesem VPN-Setup halt keinerlei V6-Connectivity in dem Sinne.
Das darf man ja nicht im Podcast sagen, glaube ich.
Wenn du so zum Beispiel YouTube-Videos guckst, ist ja ein Ars absolut.
Das ist auch illegal.
Egal, was da jetzt hier irgendwie illegal ist oder nicht, du brauchst halt einfach VPN, um irgendwie deine Daten auf deiner Last-Mile irgendwie zu schützen. Und du kannst dich dann halt in verschiedenen Ländern durchwählen, womit du ja lustigerweise bei manchen Webseiten halt solche und solche Inhalte bekommst. Und es nicht unbedingt immer alles besser ist. Manchmal ist es auch schlechter. Ja, und da frage ich mich eigentlich, gibt es irgendwelche VPN-Provider, die jetzt so mit Mac out of the box funktionieren, die auch genauso V6 dann auch weiter routen?
Also, es gibt ja, also dieses Black VPN benutzt ja quasi OpenVPN, ne? Und da gibt es ja zum Beispiel hier diesen, also meinen Lieblings VPN Client, wenn es mal nicht in OS X direkt geht, ist ja Viscosity, als OpenVPN Client. Nee, geht auf dem iPhone nicht. Aber, na der Viscosity halt nicht, das ist für Mac, aber da steht zum Beispiel IPv6 is supported. Also es muss schon auf jeden Fall gehen so prinzipiell.
Mit OpenVPN, aber OpenVPN hat das Problem, dass es sich halt nicht in die Standardarchitektur einbinden lässt.
Aber BlackVPN geht mittlerweile?
Ja, die bieten halt PPTP und L2TP als Optionen an. Das ist halt bei Mac OS X serienmäßig und bei iOS auch. Das heißt, ich kann dasselbe Setup nehmen für alle meine Devices. Und wenn ich mal halt irgendwo VPN Zugang brauche, entweder weil ich an Inhalte nicht rankomme oder weil ich überhaupt nicht rauskomme oder ein beschnittenes Netz habe, Uni, Scheiße, Port 25, Sperre etc. Dann, na gut, Port 25 ist nicht mehr das Thema. Das wollte ich jetzt gerade gar nicht sagen. Aber ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Es gibt manchmal einfach Restriktionen, die sind ein bisschen sinnlos. Da steht halt gar nichts davon, genau. Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen rumgesucht und auch nichts gefunden. Also falls da irgendjemand gute Tipps hat, im Chat kommt jetzt gerade nichts, aber vielleicht hört das ja irgendjemand. Ich glaube, das könnte auch noch andere Leute interessieren. Also VPN mit IPv6, die so auf IOS und Mac OS X out of the box funktionieren. So, naja, also los, Google. Los Max, du bist ja Google-Fanboy hier.
Ach bei Google, ja stimmt, ich habe ja an NTA unterschrieben, dass ich als Google-Gut finde. Erstmal Chrome für IOS.
Ah ja stimmt, das war natürlich auch noch...
Das hat mich ja doch ein bisschen kalt erwischt, weil da hat ja so ein Feature drin, was ich mit meinem tollen Tabulertab so jetzt gerade eingebaut habe. Ich habe ja nicht damit gerechnet, dass er ernsthaft ein Chrome für IOS rausbringt. Ich dachte, der hätte noch ein bisschen Würde bei Google.
Mir ist schon gewundert, dass du überhaupt kommst. Ich dachte, du hättest dich schon längst irgendwie in die Karibik abgesetzt, hier mit dem Rummel und deiner App. Damit wird man schnell Millionär.
Oder nicht ganz so schnell.
Du wirst ja sogar auf Heise gefeaturet.
Reich bin ich nicht.
Reich an Erfahrung.
Reich an Erfahrung. Wenn man so einen üblichen Tagesatz ansetzt, dann hätte ich jetzt ein Drittel Tag der Finanzierung bezahlt. Sagen wir mal einen halben, wenn wir großzügig sind. Da muss noch einiges, bevor ich in die Karibik auswander.
Verstehe. Oder?
Ja, aber ansonsten...
Nein.
Ansonsten muss ich Chrome mir leider zugestehen, dass der, wie ich finde, ein sehr gut gelungener Browser ist. Ich weiß nicht, ihr habt den wahrscheinlich alle gar nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab nur gelesen, der ist dreimal so langsam wie Safari.
Na ja, er hat halt diese langsame JavaScript-Engine. Er hat nicht die Nitro-Engine. Also da gibt es ja dieses beliebte Spiel. Also Safari bzw. die Fullscreen Web Apps, die man sich so auf den Home Screen ablegt, die können auf die Nitro-JavaScript-Engine zugreifen, die weitaus schneller ist, weil sie JavaScript kompiliert. Aus Sicherheitsgründen erlaubt Apple das bei Third-Party-Sachen nicht. Also Apple sind die Einzigen, die das nutzen dürfen, weil die haben sich mit Safari angeblich besonders viel Mühe gegeben. Diese Einschränkung trifft auch auf Chrome zu. Die haben halt nur den normalen UI-Webview von iOS drinne und haben dann dementsprechend auch die langsame JavaScript-Engine. Nichtsdestotrotz ist Chrome auf iOS ein verdammt schneller Browser, weil die haben einige Sachen, also ich bin sehr beeindruckt, wie die es schaffen wirklich, also bei Safari, wenn man Safari so drei, vier Seiten aufmacht und eigentlich hat sich da auch mit dem iPhone 4S nicht so wahnsinnig viel gebessert und du springst wieder, machst eine Seite auf, machst überall eine Seite auf und springst wieder zuerst zurück und dann siehst du, wie erstmal die Seite komplett neu lädt.
Auf welchem Device jetzt?
Nee, ich hab grad gesagt, da macht das iPhone 4S keinen wirklichen Unterschied. Also ich hab's bei mir ausprobiert und ich hab so irgendwie vier, fünf Tabs offen gehabt und das hat Chrome einfach nicht. Du wechselst zwischen den Tabs und die sind sofort da. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die das machen. Ich hab da auch lange wirklich zwischen den Tabs hin und her gewechselt wie ein Bekloppter, um das dann mal zu sehen. Ich glaube, die arbeiten da irgendwie mit Screenshots im Hintergrund und haben da irgendwie einen Screenshot der gerenderten Seite oder sowas, aber auf jeden Fall macht das so einen sehr snappy Eindruck. Dann haben sie halt so diese Gesten, also dass man so vom Rand rüber wischen, dass man da mit den Tabs wechseln kann, das ist wirklich ziemlich gut gemacht. Der macht erstaunlich viel her. Es ist ein bisschen schade, dass man eben nicht da diese Nitro-Engine rein haben kann und es ist auch ein bisschen schade, dass man ihn nicht als Doofy Browser festlegen kann. Das sind aber nun mal Sachen, die Apple in ihrer Verantwortung haben. Aber so was Google da machen konnte, da haben sie sich echt ins Zeug gelegt. Also ohne Scheiß. Das ist guter Browser. Haben sie gut gemacht.
Und dann gab es ja diesen geilen Tweet, dass man irgendwie Google Chrome jetzt auf 94% der iPhones, aber nur auf 4% der Android-Devices installieren kann.
Chrome für Android ist auch final. Wenn man in glücklicher Lage ist, ein Android 4.0-Gerät zu besitzen, dann kann man das auch installieren. Ist auch da ein sehr guter Browser. Ach, über Android kann ich generell. Ein Kollege von mir, der ist jetzt... Der macht jetzt auch so ein bisschen Android-Entwicklung. Hier Rob, der neulich da war. Der macht jetzt auch ein bisschen Android-Entwicklung. Und hat da freiwillig gemacht. Wenn man wieder eine neue Plattform sehen und sowas. Und hat da jetzt so ein Samsung Galaxy S3 in die Hand gedrückt bekommen. Da braucht man schon sehr große Hände um die da rein. Und das ist... Ich hab da mal so ein bisschen drauf rumgespielt. Und es ist... Also ich meine jetzt... Es ist leicht, ja... Apple-Fanboy, bla bla bla... Und hast noch keine Ahnung. Aber ich kann das Ding nicht mit einer Hand bedienen. Es geht einfach nicht. Es ist wirklich nicht machbar. Es ist zu groß. Ich komme so... Geschätzt erreiche ich ungefähr die Hälfte der Fläche des Displays. Ich hab Rob jetzt mal gefragt, wie es jetzt nach einer Woche so ist mit dem Telefon. Und er meinte, er braucht immer noch... Also du brauchst wirklich, um das Telefon brauchbar zu bedienen, brauchst du zwei Hände. Das ist... Ich weiß nicht, was die sich dabei denken. Wahrscheinlich denken sie sich ha ha ha...
Na ja, es gibt vielleicht ein paar Leute, die wollen das halt haben. Den decken sie halt ab. Den Markt vor allem. Ich denke schon, dass es eine ganze Menge gibt, die es toll finden, weil sie es halt eben noch nicht hatten. Und die werden schon merken, wie es ist. Und wahrscheinlich wird sich dann irgendwann rausstellen, dass es halt eben doch zu groß ist.
Also ich hab's probiert, so ein bisschen mit einer Hand zu bedienen. Und ich hab danach echt so ein bisschen Ziehen im Daumen gehabt.
It's just a small tablet.
Ja, das ist irgendwie...
Genauso wie Microsoft Surface. Na du weißt auch, dass dem iPad vorgeworfen wurde. Ist halt auch nur ein Big iPhone.
Ach stimmt, ja genau.
So könnte man jetzt dem iPad vorgeworfen werden. Ah, Big iPhone, wir bauen ein Small Table.
Das stimmt.
Diese Sparte von dem John Gruber, wo er halt immer diese...
Wie war das?
Claim Powder? Vorstellt ist schon immer cool, oder?
So geil, der Typ, der das gezwittert hat, meinte da irgendwie Android-Fans, dass mein Tweet alles falsch war, weil ich 4% gesagt habe, wenn es eigentlich ein 7%-Wappen ist.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, hier klingt jetzt aber mal ein bisschen mager.
Besten Tweet war das?
Thomas Fox hat gesagt, ich such grad den Original.
Ja, was haben sie darüber hinaus noch? Jelly Belly? Nee, wie hieß das? Jelly Beans haben sie vorgestellt. Ihr neues Android 4.1, also um die Bärchen oder was?
Nee, Jelly Beans.
Jelly Bananen, kennst du nicht diese?
Wie heißt das nächste denn? Muss ja mit K sein.
Es geht ja immer buchstabenweise.
Keine Ahnung. Ist jetzt wohl...
Mit K vorne.
Muss mit K sein?
Ja klar, machen wir mal mit Buchstaben. Die nächste Version hat immer den nächsten Buchstabenalphabet. So wie bei Ubuntu.
Was ist denn dieser Tweet verdammt?
Ich weiß nicht mehr was. Weiß bestimmt der Chat.
Ketchup, da ist auch genug Zucker drin.
Dann ist dann dieser Chrome rausgekommen.
Neu jetzt zu dieser Google IO.
Zum EM-Spiel gegen Deutschland. Auf jeden Fall haben sie mit ihrem Project Butter ein bisschen flüssiger unterwegs. Auch jetzt mal smooth und alles scrollt ganz schnell. Und sind stolz drauf wie Bolle, dass es jetzt alles so schnell scrollt. Liefern wohl auch so ein paar Tools mit zur Performance-Messung. Haben ein Feature drin, was sich V-Sync nennt. Also dass das Display synchronisiert wird.
Außerhalb, also in dem Augenblick, wo es gerade nicht angezeigt wird. Damit du nicht Sneering-Effekte hast. Aber das braucht man nur beim Scrollen, oder?
Nee, damit nicht Bilder berechnet werden, die nachher gar nicht angezeigt werden. Also du hast ja 60 Bilder pro Sekunde so im Allgemeinen. Und wenn du wirklich einfach nur die Grafik voll beballerst und so schnell wie es geht Grafiken rausschmeißt, so gerade beim Scrollen oder sowas, dann wird der Prozessor auch massiv belastet. Und dann kannst du es halt damit ein bisschen drücken auf so 60 Bilder pro Sekunde und kannst wirklich auch gut time gegen ein Bild. Das weiß ich daher, weil das bei iOS, ich hab keine Ahnung wie lange dabei ist, aber schon auf jeden Fall eine ganze Weile. Und das, ähm...
Da ist der Tweet.
Ah, da ist der Tweet. Der Tweet! Dann haben sie noch ihr Tablet vorgestellt, was, wenn jemand von euch in Amerika wohnt, dann meldet euch doch bitte bei mir, dann würde ich nämlich über euch gern so ein Tablet bestellen. Dieses Galaxy 7, weil ich glaube, dass, ähm... Ich hab schon länger jetzt mal wieder überlegt, mir einfach mal so ein Android-Ding irgendwie zu kaufen, so einfach um so einen Blick auch. Ich dachte so was an so was iPod Touch-artiges, mit Android 4.1 drauf, oder 4.0 war es damals noch. Und, ähm, so 200 Dollar für so ein Tablet, ich glaube, da kann man nicht viel falsch machen. Also das macht ja einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Ich freu mich, wie viel Geld Sie an diesem Gerät verlieren.
Ist mir wurscht.
Ja, wurscht ist mir das auch. Ich frag mich trotzdem, wie viel Geld Sie daran verlieren.
Also Sie behaupten, dass es plus minus null rauskommt quasi. Ich nehme an, das wird nur bei einer entsprechenden Stückzahl auch eintreffen. Ich bin gespannt, ob Sie die Stückzahlen schaffen. Würde es dir einfach überall Geschäfte geben dann irgendwann mal das Ding? Oder wird das wie bei dem Nexus One dann nur über nur über die Webseite?
Das gibt es wahrscheinlich sowieso erstmal nur in den USA, oder?
Ja, es gibt es jetzt erstmal nur, also jetzt kann man vorbestellen, USA, Kanada und Großbritannien glaube ich geht es los so in der Richtung. Und ja, bin mal sehr gespannt. Also auf der einen Seite sind ja die Kritiken durchaus rundweg relativ positiv. Andererseits nochmal gucken. Ich meine, als Amazon damals dieses Tablet für 200 Dollar rausgebracht hat, haben auch alle gesagt, so jetzt muss ich Apple ja mal warm anziehen. Und das kam nicht so.
Ich frage mich, ob dieses 7 Zoll Format eigentlich ein Gewinner ist oder nicht.
Ich glaube, das hängt sehr von einer Einstellung.
Hast du schon mal was 7 Zolliges in der Hand gehabt? Also ein Fire? Also ich meine jetzt so ein richtiges Tablet.
Wir wollen nicht schon wieder über Veli reden. Jetzt nicht nur so ein E-Book-Reader, sondern so ein Kindle Fire in der Hand gehabt.
Die Dinger sind doch alle 7 Zoll, oder? Dieses Standard-E-Ink-Display?
Ich glaube, die sind 5 Zoll, oder?
Ich habe zu Hause noch einen Texta-Reader.
Er ist so wie 7, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Keine Ahnung, du hast das dafür programmiert.
Ne, für den habe ich nicht. Also ich habe das iPhone gekotet.
Gehen wir doch einfach auf kindle.de.
Also immer so ein Kindle Fire, den hatte ich schon in meiner Hand.
Aber du hast doch den kindle, der ist auch genau diese Größe.
Naja, von der Fläche des Gerätes her vielleicht schon, aber nicht unbedingt von der Fläche des Bildschirms darauf. Wir reden ja von einem 7 Zoll Display. Also wo der Bildschirm diese Diagonale hat. Und das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen praktischer als ein iPad. Ich meine, ich habe mir jetzt wirklich nochmal, um es nochmal irgendwie neu zu versuchen, mich für dieses iPad 3 entschieden. Und die Hülle ist auch toll. Bist du wieder nicht happy? Na was heißt happy? Das Problem ist, ich muss ja erstmal meinen Use-Case irgendwie mir so richten.
Das heißt, du hast dir was gekauft und hast keinen Use-Case? Noch nicht. Du wolltest also auch mal experimentieren.
Na klar. Ich hatte schon einen Use-Case. Der Grund, warum ich mir das iPad 1 überhaupt sozusagen offenen Auges gekauft habe, ist, um das Ding einfach als Controller einzusetzen. Für die Gerätesteuerung etc. Mittlerweile setze ich es primär als Uhr ein. Dafür ist es auch super.
Die Dekadenz in Tüten.
Wieso? Die Uhr, die das iPad simuliert, kostet im Original das Doppelte. Das ist schon gespart.
Es simuliert aber gar keine Uhr.
Mach mal da Doppelklick und dann gehen wir wieder auf die Uhr.
Simulierte und ein... Sync-Log.
Aber wozu brauchst du hier eine Atomuhr? Ich meine, unsere Sendungen fangen eh nie pünktlich an.
Ich stehe einfach mal auf korrekte Zeit. Ich meine, unsere Zeit ist so viel in Schwankung unterworfen. Schaltsekunden, Schaltjahre, Winterzeit, Sommerzeit und dann noch die persönlichen Schwankungen in einem eigenen Leben, die die Zeitwahrnehmung permanent verschiebt. Da ist mir einfach so eine Atomuhr, das schafft mir einfach Halt. Das gibt mir einfach Halt in meinem Leben. Das ist einfach etwas, woran ich mich einordnen kann. Ich mag das, das ist so schön digital. Das wird dich knallhart. Metallische Einheiten, weißt du?
21,42 Euro.
Und iPad 3, da sie jetzt den Bug mit dem Cover behoben haben, durfte das jetzt bei mir auch nochmal antreten. Ich meine, jetzt sehe ich hier schon die ersten Probleme mit diesem Cover, mit diesen komischen Linien da drin. Das drückt sich natürlich hier auf den Bildschirm ab. Das ist halt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen... Aber primär, wenn man das Ding benutzt, ist es natürlich eigentlich ein super Teil für bestimmte Anwendungen. Wie lesen, brausen, etc. Bloß das kann ich halt auch prima mit meinem iPhone machen, auch wenn das irgendwie eingeengter ist. Bloß das hab ich halt auch immer dabei, wenn ich dieses iPad halt immer mitschleppen muss. Ich muss immer dran denken, es dabei zu haben. Oder ich muss es irgendwo dahintragen, wo ich dann eine Weile sein werde. Das ist schon was anderes, als ob das Ding irgendwie immer in einer Hosentasche sitzt. Von daher, das iPhone wird schon irgendwie der King bleiben, finde ich.
Wenn ich aus dem Haus gehe, ist es immer Portemonnaie, Telefon, Motorrad-Schlüssel, Haustier-Schlüssel.
Haustierschlüssel.
Naja, so das Schlüsselbund sozusagen. Haustierschlüssel sag ich mal extra, sonst klimpert es ja so rum nach vorne.
Haustierschlüssel ist wichtig.
Hast du den Hund schon abgeschlossen? Trotzdem, das iPad muss ich für mich erst irgendwie...
Suchst also einen Käufer.
Nee, ich suche keinen Käufer, ich bin mir sicher, dass ich da...
Die Kids spielen die da nicht drauf rum?...
viele Anwendungen habe. Bitte?
Spielen die Kids da nicht drauf rum?
Das Problem ist, dass Apple ja immer noch keinen Multi-User-Modus eingebaut hat.
Dann dürfen nicht deine...
Ich werde doch nicht die Kids auf meinem Mailbox irgendwie rumklicken lassen und dann ist meine Mail weg.
Oh, jetzt wird ja alles mit IOS 6 besser.
Und das ist doch in einer Cloud- und Geback-App, du?
Na, da gibt es ja diesen Modus, wo du sagen kannst, hier darf die App nicht verlassen.
Ja, aber ich kann das ja auch nicht da rumliegen lassen.
Du kannst ja einfach nur sagen, Homebutton geht nicht.
Das wird sich zeigen, was man da sagen kann. Ich will einfach einen Modus haben, wo einfach nicht nur ein Spiel freigeschaltet ist, sondern die Spiele.
Ja, ich hätte auch gerne so ein...
Wo einfach gar kein Mail client installiert ist. Wozu auch? Auch kein Browser, nichts, einfach nur Spiele.
Ja, ich hätte gerne so ein Profil, wo halt meine persönlichen Sachen nicht erreichbar sind.
Was ist mit der Lima?
Oder drück mal die Maus.
Reib's nur rein.
Tim hat ja so lange gequatscht, dass sein Rechner in Sleep Mode ging.
Gut, wo waren wir aber eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Bei 7 Zoll.
Android 4.1, das Betriebssystem, was in den nächsten 2 Jahren serienmäßig auf allen Telefonen installiert sein wird.
Serienmäßig auf allen Telefonen. War da ein Ironitek drumrum?
Das ist doch die Realität. Was haben wir gerade gehört, wie viel Prozent?
7.
Wapping 7.
Ja, was Chrome betrifft und...
Nein, nein, Quatsch, Ice Cream Sandwich. Du brauchst ja, damit du Chrome nutzen kannst, brauchst du ja...
Mindestens Android 4. Jetzt haben sie 4.1 vorgestellt und bis 4.1 irgendwie mal auf eine Mehrheit aller Telefone installiert sein wird, wird es mindestens zwei Jahre dauern. Das ist ja jetzt kein Gebäsche, wenn ich das sage.
Dieses Android 2.3...
Na ist das so oder nicht?
2.3 irgendwas gewinnt noch an Marktanteilen. Also es ist nicht so, dass jetzt, wo man ja eigentlich erwarten würde, dass in dem Moment eben eine neue Version da ist, die alte kontinuierlich...
Aber wenn eine Sache auch voll gut ist, dann muss man ja auch eigentlich nichts mehr ändern.
Die User wollen auch gar nichts anderes. Die wollen auch gar kein Mutterneres.
Ja, Android 2.3, das ist so das MS-DOS-Telefon.
Wobei das wirklich so ein Problem ist. Ich meine, das ist so, dieses Android 4.0, das sah so unterschiedlich aus von Android 2.0 irgendwas. Und Gruber hatte das mal so schon erwähnt. Wenn du so einem normalen User sagst, so Over-the-Air-Update, hier hast du viele neue Features und dann kommt da so ein Over-the-Air-Update und dann sieht dein Telefon danach komplett anders aus, kann ich schon verstehen, dass die Hersteller da sagen so, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das so gut finden.
Das ist aber nicht der Grund.
Das ist nicht der Grund.
Die Hersteller scheißen da eh drauf.
Denen ist es sowieso wurscht. Aber es ist jetzt auch bei diesem Galaxy S3, das sieht auch eher aus wie ein Android 2 als ein Android 4. Also die haben da echt lange dran rumgeschraubt, damit das auch nicht mehr so aussieht wie dieses Betriebssystem.
Aber das ist auch, glaube ich, einer der Gründe, warum so viele Leute und so viele Hoster da draußen immer noch auf Ubuntu 10.4 Long-Term-Support sind. Weil zwischen diesen Ubuntu und diesen Linux-Versionen generell, also nicht alle Distributionen, aber die meisten, ändert sich dann so von Major-Version zu Major-Version so fucking viel. Neue Paketmanager, neue Interfaces zu IP-Tables, neue Device-Mapper und was auch immer, dass die Leute auch gar nicht upgraden wollen, weil sich dann so viel ändert, dass ihre ganze Software bricht. Und das geht bestimmt diesen Android-Herschein auch, da ändert sich dann zu viel.
Die Hardware-Anforderungen sind auch einfach gestiegen.
Ich meine, du kannst ja jetzt nicht...
Ich glaube, dass diese alten Telefone schlicht nicht in der Lage sind, das zu machen. Und da ist Apple sehr viel klüger vorgegangen. Ich meine, jetzt kommt iOS 6 raus und es installiert sich auf einem... Wie alt ist dieses 3GS?
2009.
Drei Jahre alt und es wird irgendwie vier Jahre alt sein am Ende dieses iOS 6 Life Cycles.
Die Android-Phones haben doch an sich... Du sagst sozusagen, das OS hat mehr Anforderungen, oder was?
Jaja, nach Rahmen und so. Grafik, muss ja dann auch diese ganze Treiber-Geschichte irgendwie noch auf die Reihe passen.
Eine ganz schlimme Krankheit ist bei Android, die haben ja meistens relativ wenig Speicher eingebaut. Und haben dann, dass man das irgendwie über eine SD-Karte machen musste. Und dann gab es ja ewig lange, das haben sie mittlerweile in den Griff gekriegt, dass du auch irgendwie Apps auf einer SD-Karte installieren kannst. Aber da war ja quasi dieser kleine Speicher, der da war, noch mal passioniert. Und viele Hersteller haben ja dann ihre Positionen von vornherein so falsch angelegt.
War nicht beim iPhone auch mal so?
Das war ganz am Anfang so, also wirklich so...
Beim ersten auf jeden Fall.
Am ersten. Aber ich glaube, das haben sie dann irgendwie einfach mit einer neuen Betriebssystemversion gesagt, okay, machen wir jetzt hier Partitionen anders. Und beißen wir einen sauren Apfel. Und die haben das halt nicht so richtig in den Griff gekriegt. Da gab es dann auch so zwischendurch, ja, und wir machen hier ein abgespecktes, sondern mussten irgendwelche Features rausnehmen und so. Also das ist schon alles... Es ist halt nicht ein Hersteller, der Scheiße bauen kann, sondern es sind sehr viele Hersteller, die Scheiße bauen können. Und in der Theorie können auch viele Hersteller was besser machen, aber das scheinen sie nicht so drauf zu haben.
Also Google baut ja selber schon genug Scheiße. Was haben sie da wieder rausgebracht zum komischen Homestreamer? So ein Kugelteil?
Den finde ich auf eine Art ganz interessant. Also dieses Galaxy Q heißt das Ding? Ist quasi ein runder Apple TV?
Ich denke, das heißt Homestreamer.
Nö, ich hab das bei dem Wort Homestreamer. Warum hast du das gerade?
Homestreamer?
Das heißt alles, nicht Galaxy, Nexus Q.
Auf jeden Fall Q.
Und?
Ja, und es ist so eine kleine Box. Quatsch, keine Box, sondern eine Kugel. Ist eine Kugel. Kostet 300 Dollar, wo ich mich am Anfang sehr gewundert hab, was kostet an dem Scheißding so viel? Weil es ist ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr als ein Apple TV. Was so viel daran kostet, ist, dass es ein Verstärker eingebaut hat. Also da ist noch so richtig Analog-Technik drin und man kann direkt Boxen anschließen. Das ist irgendwie bis zu 25 Watt.
Das ist die Erklärung, warum es 300 Euro kostet.
Ja, Uwe meinte auch schon, es kann irgendwie weniger als ein Apple TV.
Da ist ein Boxen-Verstärker drin.
Ein brauchbarer Verstärker kostet schon mal Geld, oder?
Ja, na klar kostet der Geld, aber warum ist da ein Verstärker drin und keine Box?
Damit du richtig gute Boxen anschließen kannst.
Aber richtig gute Boxen sind doch sowieso aktiv.
Wie, na so klassische Standboxen, die man sich so hinstellt?
Ja, aber wenn du klassische Standboxen hast, dann betreibst du das bestimmt nicht mit so einem 299 Euro-Plasse Ball von Google. Da kaufst du ja ordentlich einen Klass-Afer-Stärker, der da auch ordentlich Wumm macht und diese fetten Teile auch bewegt bekommt. Ich meine, was willst du denn aus so einem kleinen Pasteball?
Ich meine, so kleine Boxen.
Ich hab kleine Boxen heutzutage sowieso alle aktiv. Sind sie?
Keine Ahnung. Ich hab eine kleine Anlage zu Hause. Wo schließt man die dann an?
An Strom!
Es hört sich aber nicht jeder 50-Hertz-Rauschen an, sondern manche Leute wollen auch Dateneingang haben. Also die wollen dann auch was aus den Boxen raushaben. Woran schließt man das dann an?
Na, an deinem Apple-TV, an deinen Mischpult, an deinen Receiver, an deine Stereo-Anlage halt.
Na, eine Stereo-Anlage hat doch sowieso noch mal einen Verstärker drin.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was meistens heutzutage so ist, aber...
Es hat einen 25-Watt Class-D-Verstärker.
Class-D?
Na, ist auch für digitale Verstärker gut, oder nicht?
Boah, ich kümmer mich da nicht mehr aus. Ich dachte, Class-A ist die Referenz.
Ich glaube, Class-D ist das Gute.
Also, ich glaube, Class-A war ein bisschen besser als Class-B, aber mit dem Nachteil, dass Class-A die ganze Zeit ordentlich Strom verballert, auch wenn gar keine Musik an ist. Und Class-B ist irgendwie, wenn keine Musik spielt oder das Signal nicht stark ist, dann verbraucht es auch keinen Strom.
Also, Class-D ist, glaube ich, schon das effizientere, bessere.
Was ich finde, was ich Apple meine, also sie haben ein anderes Bedienkonzept als Apple und das ist auf der einen Seite besser, viel besser, und auf der anderen Seite viel schlechter. Weil es hat halt, also beim Apple TV hat man ja, oder bei diesen Airplay-Boxen hat man ja immer dieses, du nimmst dein iPhone und sagst hier, da sind deine externen Boxen und alles, was ich jetzt hier auf diesem iPhone abspiele, kommt als Sound da quasi auf dem Airplay raus. Und jede App streamt darüber. Und was auf der einen Seite hat es den großen Vorteil, vielleicht hänge ich das mal hinten dran, sagen wir erstmal, was der Vorteil ist von diesem Google-Ding.
Was war denn dieses Google-Ding eigentlich, außer, dass es ein Verstärker ist?
Na du kannst da Playlisten drauf verwalten.
Kannst du den Willi reinstecken? Komm, gib mal zu, dass Willi einfach der coolste Name für ein iPod Shuffle ever ist.
Das ist ein bisschen... Es geht so ein bisschen in so einen Bereich, in dem ich eigentlich diesen Podcast nicht bringen möchte, aber...
Weil eure komische Fantasie da irgendwelche Dinge macht.
Nein, aber jetzt hast du gesagt, der kann man in Willi reinstecken.
Was macht dieses Nexus Q? Was für ein Gerät ist das? Ich hab das noch nicht verstanden. Das ist ein Lautsprecher mit was? Mit Ethernet?
Na, mit Ethernet und WLAN und HDMI.
Macht der auch selber... Ist ja auch selber ein Access Point. Macht der selber das WLAN oder...
Nee, ich glaub, der macht keine WLAN, aber das weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Was der halt macht, ist, du kannst darauf... Wiederum, so ähnlich wie auf einem Apple TV, kannst du deine Musik drauf abspielen, kannst da Filme dran gucken. Per Google Play Store kannst du da YouTube-Videos drauf abspielen. Was der große Unterschied ist zum Apple TV, ist, dass das Gerät die Musik sozusagen selber verwaltet. Also du sagst, du hast auf dem Android-Gerät deiner Wahl eine App drauf, wo du dann sagst, so, jetzt spiel mal dieses Musikstück ab. Und dann spielt die dieses Musikstück ab. Und das wird dann nicht irgendwie vom iPhone auf diese Box gestreamt oder vom Android-Gerät, sondern... Die Box, dieses Q-Ding, verbindet sich direkt mit dem Google Play Store und lädt sich die Musik runter und spielt die dann ab. Nee, bei Apple TV ist ja dein Telefon streamt die Sachen ja rüber. Nee, wenn du es über Airplay spielst...
Du hast gesagt, da gibt es eine App auf dem Telefon, das ist die Remote auf dem iPhone.
Nein, nein, du steuerst nur die Playlist damit.
Mit der App.
Das Gerät selber kümmert sich darum. Wenn du dein Telefon ausschaltest, sind wir drin. Bei einem Apple TV ist es so, wenn du mittendrin, nehmen wir mal an, also einen Fall, den ich tatsächlich schon gehabt habe, machst du ein Party, irgendjemand sagt, jetzt möchte ich gerne mal Musik spielen, dann ist es ja sowieso schon dieses ja, dann muss ich erstmal aus dem Airplay raus, dann geht der nächste ins Airplay rein. Nicht Airplay. Ja, aber wenn du Musik abspielen willst, wenn jemand Musik abspielen will, dann geht das nicht anders als über Airplay. Was remote, was willst du?
Na die Applikation namens Remote.
Nein, du hast Musik auf deinem Phone.
Nein, du hast Musik auf deinem Telefon.
Wo ist denn bei dem Google die Musik?
Na, im Google Play.
Ja, genau, wie bei Apple, im iCloud.
Nein, aber bei Apple ist das nicht so, weil bei Apple kannst du nämlich, kann ich nicht einfach hingehen und kann sagen, du, ich spiele jetzt mal auf deinem Apple-TV Musik ab.
Nein?
Nein, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie es geht.
Geht das nicht mit diesem iTunes-Klimbim? Wie heißt das nochmal?
Match.
Ist das nicht genau das, was es tut?
Ich kann natürlich dahingehen, kann mich auf dessen Apple-TV einloggen und dann kann ich auf meine Musiksammlung zugreifen, dann kann ich da meinetwegen auch Musik drauf spielen. Aber du kannst nicht sagen, hier, ich hab dieses Musikstück gekauft, ich spiele das jetzt mal auf deinem Apple-TV ab. Und das, finde ich, ist ein sehr geiles Feature.
Zumindest, es geht natürlich aber nicht, wenn wir dauernd wechseln. Jetzt musst du halt immer raus und wieder rein. Und das ist halt nicht so ein supersmoother Prozess.
Und das meine ich mit. Also bei diesem Nexus Q ist das so, es gibt eine Playlist auf dem Gerät. Jeder kann seine Musik in diese Playlist reinpacken. Und dann können aber alle diese Playlist auch verwalten. Also man kann die auch umsortieren und kann auch...
Das ist so für Nerd-Partys, wo wirklich jeder einzelne Party-Teilnehmer selber DJ sein muss.
Oder wo man sagt, danach möchte ich gerne das hören. Das heißt Nerd-Party. Ich erlebe das öfters mal auf Partys, dass Leute sagen, jetzt hätte ich gerne das Lied. Und das sind tendenziell eher nicht Nerds, die das sind.
Was ist deine Nerd-Party?
Haben die denn auch schon GEMA-Anschluss, die Würfel? Naja, ich nehme an, die werden das mit diesem Google Play Store da gemacht haben. Und dass die darüber schon ihre GEMA-Rechte abgedrückt haben. Dann kannst du halt darüber noch Videos abspielen. Was ich ganz irre finde an dem Ansatz ist, dass Google jetzt immer genau den Weg geht, den man an Apple jahrelang vorgeworfen hat. Und zwar, das ist eine komplett geschlossene Box. In der Keynote haben sie gesagt, da hat ein Micro-USB-Port für Hackability. Und dann immer alle Entwickler, Hackability, Hackability.
Aber, ähm...
Die als Google-Entwickler reagieren, wenn sie irgendwo ihren Mini reinstecken können.
Wir reden immer noch von Mein-Port-Schaffeln. Ihr seid da irgendwie anders sozialisiert. So, warte mal jetzt.
Wir haben über USB geredet. Also auf jeden Fall. Bei Airplay ist es ja mittlerweile so, du kannst ja, bau deine App fürs iPhone und du kannst einfach auf Airplay zugreifen. Du kannst das nutzen und hast alle Features und kannst die Fernsteuerung nutzen und hast das ganze Zeug. Und das Ding ist, kann natürlich sein, dass die das noch irgendwann öffnen, aber im Augenblick ist es eine reine Google-Box. Du kaufst das hin und du kannst ausschließlich Content haben, der komplett über Google kommt.
Wie, die können nicht mal Airplay? Na was, das wär's doch mal. Wenn man halt alles kann, was da so existiert.
Und das ist auch, die haben ja auch dieses Google One, diesen Serie-Konkurrenten vorgestellt. Quasi. Und der ist auch, der hat keiner, soweit ich das mitgekriegt hab, keine API. Alles nur Google-Dienste.
Ich seh schon die Partie vor mir, da ist der dicke Google-Cube da irgendwie und alle holen ihr iPhone raus und so.
Und jetzt?
Ja, keiner wird das benutzen. Ich meine, diese Funktion raus, so zweimal im Jahr und dafür kauft sich kein Mensch so ein Gerät.
Also das finde ich nämlich, wenn ich, ich hab ja diesen Zeppelin gehabt, was nicht funktioniert hat. Und da war aber auch einer der großen Nachteile, als ich angefangen habe, auf dem iPad Musik zu spielen, da bin ich mit dem iPhone durch die Wohnung gelaufen, dann hätte ich gern auf dem iPhone andere Musik ausgewählt. Dann ging das natürlich nicht, weil ja nur das iPad die exklusiven Spielrechte drauf hat. Und ich muss erstmal zum iPad hin latschen, um denen sagen, jetzt hör die Verbindung auf, um da überhaupt irgendwas dran machen zu können.
An dieser Stelle wäre nochmal die Software Shareport empfohlen für Linux, da kann einfach zwei gleichzeitig spielen. Und während das gleichzeitig spielt, kann man dem anderen sagen, ey du, dein eigenes kannst du jetzt langsam mal runterfahren. Und dein eigenes spielt weiter. Das spielt einfach gleichzeitig ab.
Aber da finde ich diesen Google-Einsatz zu sagen, ok, es gibt da so eine Playlist und ich kann von jedem ein Gerät...
Aber für den Preis kannst du dir drei Apple-TVs kaufen.
Ja, die dann alle gleichzeitig Musik klaren, habe ich auch nichts von.
Den Fader kannst du ja auch noch dazu kaufen bei dem Preis. Also mit der gemeinsamen Playlist würde ich schon eigentlich ganz cool finden, dass man so eine Art Master DJ hat pro Party, der halt sagt, was nun wirklich in der Playlist bleiben darf und was nicht. Aber dass Leute da schon so digital Vorschläge reinmachen, wäre ja schon cool, wenn du so eine riesen Party hast, also so eine größere Wohnung. Und die Küchenfraktion halt sich entscheidet, wir wollen jetzt mal den Song reinspielen. Dann sagt der DJ eigentlich cooler Vorschlag oder er sagt, nee, passt das gerade.
Ich wollte ja immer mal eine Liquid Feedback DJ-App bauen, wo man so per Liquid Feedback bestimmen kann, welche Musik jetzt kommt.
Ich war auch schon auf Partys, wo sich keiner um die Musik kümmern wollte.
Ja gut, dann kümmerst du dich halt um die Musik und dann ist das so. Aber dann brauchst du halt nicht dieses Feature. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Nischen-News-Case.
Vielleicht hast du die Musik ja auch gerade gar nicht da, was die anderen spielen wollen und die haben es halt in ihrer Cloud.
Aber den Fall, dass Leute nicht Nerds auf unseren Partys waren und gesagt haben, jetzt würde ich gern mal das und das spielen als nächstes danach.
Ja, das will man ja nicht, dass andere Leute in deine Playlist reinquatschen.
Also ich will auch nicht solche Leute haben, die auf meine Party kommen und dann auf einmal Musik wünschen. Ich meine, wo sind wir denn da?
Das ist ja wie eine Disco mit irgendwie.
Wieso?
Ich meine, man macht da irgendwie gute Musik an und fertig. Und wenn man irgendwie besonders gute Musik haben will, die dann auf die Leute eingeht, dann holt man sich einen richtigen DJ. So macht man das, aber doch nicht von Google.
Ich lasse doch nicht Google an meine Musik.
Wann sagt Willi? Das hatte jetzt gar keinen Bock mehr.
Und wenn sie alle Insekten wegjagen, dann kann der Blütenstab nicht vertreten.
Ja, aber es sieht so aus, als ob... Wir sind mit Google noch nicht durch, ne?
Warten wir mal noch nicht?
Die Brille...
Die haben noch, die haben... Also erst mal dieses Google One Zeug, eben dieses Siri-artige Dingsbumm, was jetzt...
Aus dem Zeppelin springen, ja und...
Ne, das ist ja noch was anderes. Also Google One ist ja erst mal hier so dieses Suchfunk, also dieses Siri-artige Dingsbumms, was so Sachen rauskriegen soll automatisch, wie hey, du fährst doch um diese Uhrzeit normalerweise immer nach da und da ins Büro und da ist heute Stau auf der Strecke, also fahr mal ein bisschen früher los und sowas. Bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie gut das in der Praxis funktioniert.
Aber die Stimme...
Aber die Stimme klang echt erschreckend. Also wenn das die... Also es war die authentische Stimme, weil ich hab's auf Videos oft...
Deine Schwiegermutter ist bei deiner Frau angekommen, ist heute der richtige Tag, mal ein paar Überstunden zu machen.
Also Siri hört man ja nun deutlich an, dass es eine Computerstimme ist. Bei dieser Google-Stimme hat man das irgendwie schon nicht mehr so richtig gehört. Da war das wirklich...
Bei Siri ist ja auch...
Nee, viel besser als Siri.
Ja, ich sag ja, die nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre, da wird da richtig was passieren. Ich glaub, das ist nicht unterschätzt, weil es zurzeit schon noch scheiße ist, aber ich denke, da ist viel Potenzial. Bin ich ganz überzeugt.
Da ist noch viel Potenzial, ja. Und auch so dieses intelligente irgendwas raussuchen. Entweder geht es in eine total falsche Richtung, weil es nie das machen wird, was man eigentlich wollte und man schmeißt es irgendwann gegen die Wand oder sie kriegen es halt wirklich so hin, dass es funktioniert. Ich glaube, dazwischen gibt es nichts. Also ich finde diesen, solange das noch nicht geht, finde ich diesen, ich starte eine App, die ich jetzt gerade haben will, finde ich eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt. Aber das ist, vielleicht schaffen wir es irgendwann.
Hast du auch dieses Watson-Ding gesehen von IBM oder was diese Jeopardy-Quiz-Fragen da beantwortet hat? Was gegen diese echten Jeopardy-Gewinner da angetreten ist und glaube ich auch am Ende sogar gewonnen hat.
Irgendwie, also irgendwann auch mal verloren.
Einmal hat es verloren, das erste Mal glaube ich sogar, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Und danach hat es aber glaube ich dann nur noch gewonnen. Google Now heißt es nicht Google Won. Stell dir vor, du kannst sowas halt an Siri fragen. Also die komplexen Fragen, alle möglichen Bereiche und der kann es halt vielleicht jetzt nicht so schnell wie bei dieser Quiz-Show da, aber wenn es halt manche Sachen würde ja auch einem schon reichen, wenn man nach einer Minute oder nach fünf irgendwie eine Antwort kriegt oder überhaupt irgendwann mal. Und ich stelle mir das schon cool vor. Wenn man die Fragen halt auch noch wirklich mündlich stellen kann, das ist schon, ich finde das...
Passt dann erst ab, geht in Sachen Recherche. Das wird einmal komplett...
Da hast du was nicht mehr gegoogelt, sondern hast du das halt, ja keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt, wirklich ein neues Wort für ergeben, je nachdem, welche Marketing-Abteilung sich da das Coolste einfallen lässt.
So, dann sind sie noch mit... mit Nerd-Brillen aus dem Zeppelin gesprungen.
Ja, hab ich gesehen, das Video war ganz witzig, haben dann schon Action gemacht.
Also erst mal aus dem Zeppelin rausgesprungen, dann da gelandet.
Mit aufgesetzter Brille von mehreren Leuten, die das auch mal schön gefilmt haben.
Und wo es auch schön geruckelt hat beim Stream, also mit anderen Worten, es war auch authentisch. Also es war nicht schlimm geruckelt, aber es war schon geruckelt. Man sah auch, dass die Kamera in der Brille noch nicht so perfekt ist. Dann unten gelandet, dann irgendwie aufs Fahrrad gestiegen und weitergefahren. Das ist auch das Mosconi, oder?
Genau, sind auf dem Dach gelandet, weil das Dach ja auch schon ein bisschen größer ist. Es waren auch Radfahrer am Start, damit alle Ecken und Enden von dem Dach schnell erreicht werden.
Genau, dann sind sie die Hauswand drunter gelaufen.
Eingesammelt, genau. Haben sich das Hausdach abgeseilt, dann hat es der nächste Radfahrer bekommen und der ist dann durchs Haus geradelt und durch die Eingangshalle musste er erstmal um die Leute rumschippern. Dann in die Halle rein, dann musste er sagen, dass er die Gänge frei hält und dann ist er am Ende die Treppen ganz elegant hochgehüpft. Mit so einem Mountain-Dings.
Kann mal einer sagen, was bitte die Botschaft von diesem Stunt war?
Na wir sind halt cool.
Wir haben eine Brille und wir wissen nicht, was man mitmachen soll.
Wir sind jung und sportlich. Neureiche Millionäre.
Ja, du kannst doch jetzt... Die Nerds, die machen es zwar. Unsportlich, übergewichtig. Und mit Brille.
Was wollten sie demonstrieren? Wollten sie demonstrieren, dass irgendwie OMTS auch noch in 2 Kilometer Höhe funktioniert?
WLAN, weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, sie wollten demonstrieren, dass sie eine Brille haben, die leicht genug ist, dass man sie wirklich... Also die Binde, die man auch noch beim... Oder die Tampon, die man auch noch beim Reiten tragen kann.
Und beim Schwimmen.
Ich glaube, die hatten ja irgendwo noch einen Rucksack drin, was die Datenübertragung gemacht hat.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das 3G da drin steckte. Rucksack.
Ich weiß es nicht, das ist jetzt reine Vermutung. Also wir haben nichts dergleichen gesagt. Ich weiß auch überhaupt nicht, was das Ding kann.
Was haben die eigentlich gesagt, transportiert mit dem Fahrrad? Das war nicht die Brille, oder?
Doch, doch, die haben dann immer die Brille weitergefahren. Das war ja das Dämliche. Die haben nicht die Person weitergefahren, sondern die haben immer diese Brille weitergefahren, die dann irgendwie angekommen ist. Also das war schon ein bisschen bekloppt.
Ja, aber das heißt ja schon, dass die Brille mehr oder weniger fertig ist. Also es ist jetzt nicht noch so ein riesen Kasten mit dran und so weiter, sondern die wollten damit zeigen, dass es wirklich nur noch die Brille ist, oder was?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie...
Also die Fotos, die damit gemacht werden, also sie haben ja so ein paar Beispielfotos, die so von Mitarbeitern gemacht sind, da sind schon ein paar coole Bilder dabei, und die Videos und sowas. Also immer einfach hier oben kleines Knöpfchen drücken zu können und dann was filmen zu können oder was draufnehmen zu können. Das ist die Pornobranche revolutionär. Das stimmt, ich weiß, wer die Brille kauft. Jetzt ist mir das Geschäftsmodell plötzlich klargebrochen.
Ja, Jauporn kriegt wahrscheinlich eine eigene Kategorie dafür.
Aber hier so, Huckel hat hier gerade mal so die Sachen offen, das sind schon teilweise ganz coole Bilder, die damit entstehen.
Was ist bei Jauporn?
Wir haben jetzt schon seit Ewigkeiten Willi nicht mehr erwähnt, jetzt fängst du hier jetzt einfach Jauporn an.
Die Frage ist ja, ob sich da jetzt auch wieder so eine Art neue Gesetze ergeben. Es ist ja auch beim Telefonieren so, man darf ja glaube ich seine Telefonate nicht einfach so aufzeichnen, ohne dem Gegenüber Bescheid zu sagen, richtig? Deswegen zum Beispiel musst du auch, wenn du hier bei Apple zum Beispiel anrufst und so, und die wollen wieder mal ein bisschen ihre Statistik verbessern, dann sagen die, ja zu Schulungszwecken oder sowas wird das Gespräch aufgezeichnet. Das ist natürlich totaler Blödsinn, sondern die wollen, glaube ich, irgendwie mal so reinhören können, aber müssen sie halt sagen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sowas dann demnächst für die Brille auch kommt. Also weil ich würde es auch nicht so cool finden, wenn mich einfach jeder filmt, nur weil er so eine scheiß Brille auf hat.
Ja, das wird kommen, das wird Alltag werden.
Also zum Beispiel kriege ich dann hier so einen Bluetooth-4-Tag, womit automatisch alle Brillen in meiner Umgebung ausgehen.
Na ja, das wäre aber, weiß ich nicht, ob ich davon so ein Freund bin.
Oder gibt es ein Gesetz, was dann auch sagt, na ja, der hat die Brille auf der Typ, sieht dich, also kann er auch ein Bild von dir machen, weil er sieht dich ja eh. Also wenn du nicht gesehen werden willst, da musst du halt nicht...
Ich glaube, das ist nur das Problem der Veröffentlichung. Das Foto machen ist nicht das Problem.
Na, das ist ja bei Fotos auch so, oder?
Ich glaube schon.
Na, mal gucken, was da so kommt. Aber sonst gibt es noch keine Ankündigungen für die Brille, dass sie sagen, bringen wir dann und dann raus, oder wir vermarkten das nicht selbst, sondern wir haben einen Hersteller, der das in Lizenz irgendwie macht für uns oder irgendwie so was. Da ist überhaupt noch gar nichts zu hören, oder? Ich denke auch, dass die Hardware wahrscheinlich schon einigermaßen okay ist, aber die noch ewig an dieser Software fallen werden.
Also, was die Software angeht, haben sie nichts gezeigt. Also ich habe keinen Screenshot gesehen, was man da im Display sieht. Der einzige Anwendungszweck, den sie auch so richtig da hatten, waren Fotos machen und Videos machen damit. Das war alles, was sie... Irgendwie kann man an der Seite so auf diesem etwas dickeren Balken, ist wohl so eine Gestenerkennung, also so ein Mini-Trackpad quasi.
Du meinst, alle werden dann wie Pantau später so da irgendwie...
Sich die ganze Zeit so am Brillengestell rumnuckeln. Keine Ahnung, also das macht mir einen sehr, sehr unfertigen Eindruck alles. Die wollen da irgendwann mal hin und so was, aber die haben keine richtige Idee, wie es losgehen soll. Aber das kommt an, das ist echt ein beliebtes Thema. Wo war denn das?
Ich finde Head-Up-Display schon eine spannende Sache für die Zukunft.
Google konzentriert sich irgendwie auf Produkte, deren Relevanz ich einfach überhaupt nicht sehe.
Früher wäre das Microsoft gewesen, oder?
Ja, weiß nicht, Google ist auch irgendwie noch mal so ein eigenes Ding. Ich meine, sie versuchen jetzt so total auf Konto zu machen und im Prinzip tun sie ja wieder mal nichts anderes als Apple da zu kopieren. Mit kleinen Nuancen.
Aber mit der Brille nicht.
Ja, aber wo ist diese Brille? Die Brille gibt es in Videos, wo irgendwelche Millionäre aus Zeppelin springen. Wo ist das Teil? Alles, was sie bisher auf ihre IO angekündigt haben, war nach einem Jahr später irgendwie tot oder teurer oder anders. Irgendwas, was sie mal vorgestellt haben, außer den Android-Releases, ist irgendwie Wahrheit geworden.
Was haben sie denn so großartig angekündigt?
Google Music und tausende Dienste. Und es ging jedes Jahr wieder anders. Jetzt heißt es Play und nichts kam irgendwie zusammen. Ich kann nicht ausschließen, dass sie jetzt wirklich einen Datendil haben, dass es funktioniert mit dem Fernsehen und so weiter. Aber am Ende kommen sie dann genau bei demselben Business-Modell an, wo Apple nämlich schon seit Jahren ist. Nämlich, dass sie da Verträge machen, da den Content schön auf irgendeinem Device drauf spielen und letzten Endes in derselben Relation zu den anderen Unternehmen stehen, wie es Apple derzeit auch macht. Nur, dass sie einfach überhaupt keine nennenswerte Userbase haben.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich Apple da als ernsthafte Konkurrenz sehen. Ich meine, dieses Tablet hat die Größe eines Amazon Kindle-Fires, es hat den Preis eines Amazon Kindle-Fires, es hat das Format und es hat das Geschäftsmodell. Also ich würde sagen, das ist eher ein Angriff auf Amazon als ein Angriff auf Apple.
Vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur eine fette große Werbeaktion und diese Brille kommt sowieso nie raus. Und Werbung hat das Ding jetzt schon genug gemacht, alle reden über diese fucking Brille und verbinden das mit Google.
Ja, aber was nützt es groß am Ende?
So wie Werbung halt immer ist, Google ist in aller Munde.
Naja, sie wollen halt auch mal ihre Zukunftsvision zeigen.
Wir quatschen ja seit einer Viertelstunde oder schon noch viel länger darüber.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen, ja.
Das ist doch schon der Sinn der Sache, dass man sich halt drüber unterhält.
Ja, aber das hält halt nicht lang. Weil du kannst nichts kaufen und keiner wird irgendwelche positiven Erfahrungen machen. Und das ist das, was letzten Endes Leute überzeugt, in so eine Plattform einzukommen. Aber bei Google gibt es relativ wenig Gründe, sich in diese Plattform einzukommen.
Ich glaube, das geht bei dieser Brille jetzt darum. Und eigentlich ist das ja was Unterstützenswertes. Sie haben da irgendwas, oder was Lobenswertes. Sie haben da was entwickelt und Glauben. Also haben offensichtlich selber keine Ideen. Also so kann man es negativ formulieren. Man kann es positiv formulieren. Sie wollen die Welt früh einbeziehen in diese Entwicklung und Ideen einsammeln, was man mit dem Ding machen kann. Und darum verkaufen sie es schon mal an Entwickler. Ja klar kostet das da ein Schweinegeld. Das ist ein Prototyp einer kleinen Auflage.
Wie lange reden die denn jetzt davon? Wir reden jetzt schon seit einem Jahr von diesem Teil.
Nö, von dem Glas. Wann ist denn das vorgestellt worden? Im April das erste Mal, dass das erwähnt worden ist oder sowas?
Das wurde schon mal vorher erwähnt, aber da war halt noch gar nichts zu sehen. Und dann kam zum ersten Mal richtig die Brille selbst. Erwähnt wurde das aber schon mal vorher.
Ich guck grad mal.
Ich glaub wahrscheinlich sogar auf der letzten Google-Messe.
Also ich weiß nur, dass du das jetzt irgendwann...
Doch, aber ihr fragt auch schon, da war schon mal was vorher.
Also ich...
Sollen sie machen. Ist doch... Zeigen sie mal ein bisschen ihre Zukunft.
Soll ab Januar 2013 zur Verfügung stehen. Zum Preis von 1500 Dollar pro Stück. Soll.
Nee, und im Augenblick kriegst du es ja sowieso nur.
Ich sag nur, ruft mich an, wenn es da ist, dann fang ich an, mir darüber Gedanken zu machen. Bis dahin ist das alles heiße Luft aus Google. Eine Firma, die bisher genau ein Produkt auf die Reihe bekommen hat und alle anderen müssen sie noch dran arbeiten.
Naja, aber entweder wir machen... Also wir haben doch vorhin darüber geredet, was ist unsere Zukunft.
Ihr Produkt ist Werbung.
Ja, naja eben, genau.
Was haben sie gut hingekriegt?
Ihr Income ist Werbung und Werbung funktioniert am besten über Suchen, so, für Sie.
Aber wir haben vorhin über Zukunftsvision geredet, was so in fünf Jahren sein wird. Und ich meine, Google zeigt, was Sie glauben, was möglicherweise in fünf Jahren Ihre Zukunftsvision zeigen kann.
Genau, Apple bringt in fünf Jahren einen Tag vorher raus, was Sie gehabt haben, in fünf Jahren alle kaufen.
Apple tickt da anders. Aber ich finde das nicht jetzt automatisch.
Ich finde das okay, weil ich glaube ich auch bald eine Brille brauche und dann wird es auch sowas haben.
Funktioniert das Ding eigentlich auch als Brille?
Ich hoffe, sonst kann man das gleich mal geben.
Dann lassen sich bestimmt irgendwelche Leute sich da einen Brillengläser anbringen. Aber sie haben noch was vorgestellt. Und zwar haben sie Kalenderevents, die man jetzt über Google Plus sharen kann. Das muss ich mir am Stuhl festhalten. Dass wenn man über Google Plus eine Einladung bekommt, dann hat man den Termin, ohne dass man ihn jemals gesehen hat, in seinem Kalender drinne stehen. Und selbst wenn man ihn explizit ablehnt, wird er nicht aus dem Kalender gelöscht.
Was in welchem Kalender?
In deinem Google-Kalender. Du hast einen Google-Kalender. google.com/kalender.
Da hab ich viele Kalender.
In deinem Hauptkalender davon.
In meinem Privat?
Jeder kann da Termine reinballern. Und dann ist das Ding voll. Dann könnte jeder da auch Werbung reinballern.
Such mal nach dem...
Hast du diese drei Mails bekommen, wo mir jemand sagt, er hätte wie eine Veranstaltung reingetragen?
Such mal nach dem Rand von Scobble. Da siehst du mal, wie man rantet.
Das ist aber auch nichts, was dir nicht mit einer Zeile Code ändern könnte.
Na ja, aber wie kann man sowas bringen? Also wirklich, wie kann man... Ich hab plötzlich einen Termin hier. Der erste, der es hatte, war Niko Lummer, der mir irgendwie, mir und 4000 anderen sehr guten Freunden, mich zu irgendeinem Werbeevent eingeladen hat, für seine neue Drecks-App. Und dann krieg ich drei Stunden später, mitten in der Nacht, eine Terminerinnerung dran, dass jetzt dieses Event anfängt. Und ich hatte nicht mehr...
Du hast nichts getan. Gar nichts.
Ich hab geguckt, wo ich... Bei dem Termin konnte ich nur ja oder vielleicht sagen, es gab kein Ablehen. Also das war auch der einzige Termin, bei dem es so war. Und ich hab nichts getan. Nein, ich hab den nicht mal per Mail bekommen. Der ist bei Google+, Share, bla bla bla. Jemand hat mit mir ein Event geschert. Ich krieg gar nichts davon mit, außer dass ein Termin in meinem Kalender drin steht.
Das ist doch eine geile Werbeplattform, dein Kalender.
Google ist wirklich super. Die machen sich echt Gedanken um die Zukunft.
Und das find ich echt mal lustig.
Um ihre, ja.
Und das find ich lustig. Weil es haben ja alle immer davor gewarnt. Social Networks, vertraut dir nicht so viel Daten an. Dann sind die Daten bei denen in Händen. Und wer weiß, wo die die hinkopieren. Okay, ist tatsächlich scary. Aber der eigentliche Scary-Punkt ist ja jetzt, wenn es ihnen passt, dann ändern sie deine Daten nach Belieben. Also dann tragen sie ihr Kalender ein.
Du hast das schon falsch verstanden. In dem Augenblick, wo die in diesem Netzwerk da sind, sind das nicht mehr deine Daten.
Habt ihr das bei Facebook mitbekommen? Facebook hat mal eben in allen Profilen die E-Mail-Adressen geändert auf die entsprechenden Facebook-E-Mail-Adressen.
In welchen Profilen?
Na, in deinen Facebook-Profilen. Also wenn du da irgendwie eine öffentliche E-Mail-Adresse hattest in deinem Facebook-Profil.
Also in deinem...
Wenn da Tim Admeta eben stand bei Facebook, dann stand danach Tim at Facebook.
Genau.
Steht da überhaupt eine E-Mail-Adresse von mir?
Ja, du kannst eine E-Mail-Adresse eintragen. Und jetzt haben einige Telefone ja die Funktion, dass sie automatisch sich ihr Adressbuch mit Facebook abgleichen. Was ja an sich auch eine praktische Sache ist. Wenn jemand seine Telefonnummer erinnert, brauchst du nicht großartig überall Telefonnummer zu erinnern. So, jetzt hatten plötzlich massenhaft Leute.
Bei mir steht immer noch meine eigene.
Vielleicht haben sie es jetzt mittlerweile wieder rückgängig gemacht. Also ich hab zwischendurch definitiv gesehen, dass so alle Freunde plötzlich Facebook-Adressen hatten angeblich.
Wahrscheinlich war es nur ein kurzer Fuck-Up, welches Fails sie genommen haben.
Und dann gab es nämlich das Problem, dass es Software gibt, die das Adressbuch mit Facebook abgleichen und die plötzlich keine Mails mehr an die Firmenadresse schicken konnten, weil sie nur noch diese Facebook-Adresse hatten. Das kriegst du natürlich auch erstmal nicht mit, dass das passiert. Weil man guckt ja nicht jedes Mal, dafür hat man ja so ein Adressbuch, dass man nicht jedes Mal die E-Mail-Adresse nachgucken muss. Ja, also jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt, wo die Social Networks anfangen, unsere Daten hinter unserem Rücken zu ändern und sich nicht mehr zu schämen.
Aber Facebook war auch noch an einer anderen Stelle ganz schön schlau. Und zwar haben sie eingeführt, dass ab und zu müssen mal auf Facebook-Accounts verifiziert werden, ob die stimmen. Und dazu mussten die Leute ihre Mobilnummer angeben. So hat Facebook erstmal alle möglichen Mobilnummer eingesammelt.
Ach, dass man sich zum verifizieren?
Genau.
Ich glaube, an die wären es auch einfacher angekommen.
Es gibt besseres als wenn der User die eintippt. Da musst du ihn nicht mal um Erlaubnis fragen. Wenn er sie selber eingibt.
Auch das ist halt, um Verified-Developer auch zu sein.
Also ich hab auch irgendwie heute mich kurz mal wieder eine halbe Stunde mit Facebook beschäftigt. Nee, jetzt wo das gerade kommt irgendwie. Ich bin ja ein totaler Facebook-Noob und ich benutze das ja nur zum Beobachten von Facebook und zum Ausprobieren, was man alles sozusagen für Einstellungen zurücknehmen kann.
Tims einziger Freund auf Facebook ist Facebook.
Und ich versuche zwischendurch dann immer wieder so impulsiv bestimmte Dinge zu verstehen. Ja, also ich lese mir jetzt nichts groß durch, sondern ich gehe immer davon aus, dass ein System auch selbst erklänt sein muss. Ja, also impulsiv, was so meine Herangehensweise betrifft. Und dann setze ich eben auf nur das, was intuitiv ist. Und ich versuche jetzt nicht das ganze Internet nach Webforen abzugrasen, wo andere Leute schon mal das gleiche Problem hatten und irgendwie 3-4 Monate hat mal irgendjemand einen Link gepostet, wo vielleicht steht, wie es geht. Sondern entweder das funktioniert, so wie ich mir das vorstelle, oder nicht. Und zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt so einen Spam. Erstmal habe ich festgestellt, es gibt irgendwo so einen im Internet was finden und dann wieder was wiederfinden. Also irgendwo kann man sich so einen Log anzeigen lassen von seinem eigenen Profil. Kennt ihr das? So ein Log. So ein Aktivitätslog. Was man so getan hat in den letzten Monaten und Wochen.
Ist das nicht das eigene Profil?
Die Timeline.
Nee, nicht die Timeline, sondern so... So ein Aktivitätslog, ich find's jetzt grad nicht wieder.
Das ist, wenn du klickst da auf deinen Namen. Und dann gibt's da rechts das Aktivitätslog. Also oben im Menü, in dieser blauen Leiste, klickst du auf deinen Namen.
Ja, auf mein Bildchen sozusagen.
Genau, und dann kommt auch da deine Timeline und dann ist da rechts oben...
Unter deinem Coverbild quasi, wenn du eins hast.
Hier gucke, da wo meine Maus ist.
Guck mal, wie der Huckel das macht.
Da rechts oben.
Aber irgendwie sieht das Facebook ganz schön zusammengeschustert aus, oder? Also ich meine, modernes Design sieht auch ein bisschen anders aus.
Das ist ganz schön zusammengeschustert.
Und wie sieht das anders aus?
Du hast noch gar keine Timeline. Du hast das alte Profil.
Ich hab das alte Profil, ich hab das, was da ist, hab ich...
Du musst dein Facebook-Account halt mal updaten.
Ich sagte, das ist das Timbit.
Ja, und? Also ich meine, trotzdem wollte ich hier irgendwo einen Aktivitätslog einstellen und jetzt find ich's nicht mehr. Ist vielleicht wieder Kontoeinstellungen oder sowas. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall mein Aktivitätslog ging irgendwie bis 2010 oder so zurück. Und ich hab nichts da drin. Nichts. Kein einziger Eintrag. Finde ich geil. Und dann hatte ich auch das Problem, es gibt ja irgendeine komische Seite für Chaos, Radio, Express. Irgend so ein Vogel hat das eingerichtet. Warum auch immer. Ja, unter gemeinnützige Organisationen. So, jetzt frag ich mich, kriegt man diesen Scheiß da wieder weg?
Das ist der ewige Speicher, das geht nicht.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Ist das deine Seite?
Aber du kannst den claimen.
Sag dem doch mal Bescheid, der sie eingerichtet hat. Hey, gib mir mal Admin-Rechte, damit ich die dicht machen kann.
Du kannst auch so eine Seite claimen.
Ich hab den irgendwie mit dem oder ihr geschrieben und es gibt halt keine Antwort.
Der ist auch schon gestorben.
Keine Ahnung, hier steht ja auch nicht von wem die ist. Du kannst dich bei Facebook beschweren und claimen. Wenn ich sage Seite melden, dann kann ich nur auswählen zwischen es schikaniert mich. Das wäre schön, wenn sie diesen Button mal für Facebook als solches hätten.
Ja, Facebook keine eigene Seite.
Es schikaniert mich. Es schikaniert einen meiner Freunde. Oder irgendwie Spam oder Betrug, Hassreden, Gewalt oder verletzendes Verhalten, sexuell explizite Inhalte, doppelte oder falsch kategorisierte Seite. Und nichts davon trifft zu. Dann gibt es wiederum unten noch einen Link mit Ist dies dein geistiges Eigentum? Wo so eine komische Hilfe-Seite kommt und die mir auch irgendwie irgendwas erzählen will, was ich angeblich tun kann. Dann kann ich hier auf Content von Imitatoren klicken. Und da wird mir dann erzählt, ich sollte wieder das Rädchen klicken, melden, blockieren, auswählen und Dinge auswählen, die es da gar nicht gibt.
Sitzt doch einfach weiter aus.
Ich meine, warum, seit ich in diesem System einen Account habe, habe ich noch nicht ein einziges Mal irgendwas verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Intuitiv. Nichts.
Das ist das Gute, wenn du in einer Firma arbeitest, wo Facebook sozusagen zum Grundgeschäftsmodell gehört, da gibt es ganz viele Leute, die da einfach alles machen. Da kannst du sagen, wo muss ich klicken? Und dann kommt jemand und macht das für dich.
Ich meine, bin ich jetzt doof und alt?
Nein, klar, die Zwölfjährigen können das.
Ich meine, was mache ich denn falsch? Ich wollte mal eine Facebook-Seite anlegen, auch für meinen Bookmark-Service. Als ich da angefangen habe, wo ich noch dachte, ich code jetzt mal meinen Bookmark-Service, und dann habe ich bei VUGA angefangen, dann habe ich ja damit aufgehört wieder, aber ich habe schon alles vorbereitet, den großen PR-Marketing-Rollout, und dazu gehörte auch eine Facebook-Seite natürlich anzulegen. Und das habe ich gleich beim ersten Mal direkt verkackt. Also da habe ich irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle den falschen Haken geklickt, bin falsch abgebogen, dann war es keine Facebook-Seite, sondern irgendwas anderes, was so seitenartig aussah.
Das ist versehentlich eine Google-Plus-Seite.
Nein, und das Ding war, man kam nicht davon zurück. Dann habe ich meinen Kumpel gefragt, der meinte, mach eine Facebook-Seite. Der Robert, den ich schon lange nicht mehr erwähnt habe, Future of Robert, weil er auch nicht mehr mein Kollege ist, aber ihn gibt es noch. Auf jeden Fall hat er mir gesagt, wie ich diese Seite wieder wegkriegen könnte. Und zwar müsste ich mindestens 25 Fans oder Likes, nee Fans war es glaube ich, 25 Fans auf dieser Seite bekommen und dann könnte ich sie wohl claimen oder irgendwie so und könnte es dann wieder rückgängig machen.
Die Seite, die du selber eingerichtet hast.
Ja, das war totaler Wahnsinn. Oder, nee, umbenennen, umbenennen.
Umbenennen kann man nur bei einer bestimmten Anzahl von Leuten.
Ja oder so, es war total absurd.
Ich habe eine angelegt und da hat er mir schon gesagt, dass ich sie nicht umbenennen kann. Beim Anlegen hat er mir das schon vorher gesagt, dass ich sie nicht umbenen kann, woraufhin ich sie nicht angelegt habe.
Also es ist halt einfach auch komplett unklamier gewesen, wie diese Seite jetzt entsteht, wer welche Kontrolle drüber hat und wieso ich da nicht einfach volle Kontrolle habe. Wie auch immer, da gibt es Mittel und Wege und so weiter, aber es ist definitiv nicht super intuitiv und offensichtlich. Vielleicht haben sie das mittlerweile geändert. Also ich muss mir jetzt keine Sorgen machen. Ich war froh, dass ich den Roboter damals noch hatte, der mir dann zumindest aufklärende Weise erzählt hat, wie das alles so funktioniert.
Jeder bei Facebook sollte einen Roboter haben.
Oder bei einer Firma arbeiten, die ihr Geld mit Facebook macht, da gibt es dann auch genug Experten.
Also meine Freundin hat neulich ihrer Mutter eine Facebook-Seite, die war hier in Berlin, und da hat sie ihr Facebook-Profil eingerichtet. Nee, nicht zum Geburtstaggeschenk. Naja, die Mutter ist durchaus interessiert. Und ich glaube, das ist der Hauptantriebspunkt, warum die Leute das machen, dieses Facebook-Weise mit anderen Leuten Kontakt bleiben wollen. Und wenn deine Tochter auf Facebook relativ aktiv ist, dann ist es für eine Mutter auch vielleicht ganz interessant, da mal rein zu gucken, um zu sehen, was die Tochter so treibt. Genauso aus dem gleichen Grund, auf den meine Eltern bei Twitter reingucken. Und auf jeden Fall meinte sie danach, sie hat wirklich so schockiert zu mir gesagt, ich hab das doch probiert, alles meiner Mutter zu erklären, und das ist ja wirklich so kompliziert. Da blickt ja wirklich keiner durch. Also es ist einfach scheiße kompliziert. Aber die Leute sind offensichtlich bereit, diese ganze Komplexität auf sich zu nehmen, wenn der Ansporn groß genug ist.
Ich hör aber auch von ganz vielen Leuten, dass sie das ganz schön viel benutzen und irgendwie da raus sind, wo die Leute gerade im Urlaub sind, und die Kinder sind da, und haben sich zwei getrennt, und die es jetzt wieder zu haben. Und überhaupt, auf Partys wird halt nicht Telefonnummer getauscht, sondern die tauschen erst mit, also die liken sich erst mal alle auf Facebook, wie die Mitsalis danach noch treffen können. Also die blicken das schon.
Den Kasten mit K hier und PM-Nachnamen kennt ihr beide, der auch, ne? Ich hab über Facebook erfahren, dass der jetzt in Japan ist und da erst mal sesshaft geworden ist. Über Facebook, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Ich bin mit dem fast zur Schule gegangen, nicht wirklich.
Sesshaft geworden sogar, in Japan.
Der bleibt jetzt seit drei Jahren, mindestens. Bei NVIDIA hat er angeheuert und hat da wohl auch eine Japanesin kennengelernt, die Ausschlag geben für den...
Zusammen mit dem David, oder was?
Der hat da auf jeden Fall seine Finger im Spiel gehabt. Ja, hat er auch auf der Hochzeit von dem David kennengelernt, die Japanesin. Und das musste ich über Facebook erfahren, ja. Und da dachte ich mir, okay, gut.
Das funktioniert auch gut über Facebook, muss man ja leider sagen.
Ich hab auch gegen die Funktionalität gar nichts. Ich hab nur was dagegen, wenn halt meine Daten irgendwie noch weiter verwurstet werden. Ich hätte gerne meine Verwertungsrechte selber.
Was hab ich denn davon, wenn ich auf dieses neue Leeraut umstelle?
Du nichts, weil du hast ja nichts in deiner Timeline.
Deswegen, sie wurde nicht angezeigt, weiß nicht, was ich denn...
Da steht irgendwas an meiner Timeline. Wir können jetzt mal Tim irgendwie in Fotos taggen oder so. Und anfangen seine Timeline einfach von außen zu... Wo ist denn meine Timeline? Wo ist denn meine Timeline?
Und seine Verwandtschaftsgrade irgendwie zu klären und sowas.
Aber lass uns das mal mit dem Facebook nach der Sendung machen. Wir haben jetzt schon ein paar Folgen immer über dieses Facebook.
Tabula Taps hat jetzt ja auch eine Facebook-Seite. Habt Tabula Taps alle lieb auf Facebook.
Fabula Taps?
Wo ist denn meine scheiß Timeline?
Du musst ja erst irgendwie aktivieren. Du bist ja noch auf dem alten Profil.
Was ist denn mit dem alten Profil?
Also davon, dass du dich nicht die Bohne für interessiert hast, aber du bist so ein Anfänger.
Weil er nicht die neuen Features hat, ist er ein bisschen angetickert.
Ich versteh diese Sprache nicht.
Ihr solltet immer so einen 15-jährigen Podcast-Mitmacher rein. So ein Schüler, der uns auch den neuesten Shit erklärt, der gerade so angesagt ist.
Also Zeug, was richtig Porno ist sozusagen.
Die wissen es nämlich. Weil wir sind nämlich alle zu alt hier.
Lass uns doch mal über was anderes reden.
Das ist eine Behauptung, dass sie das wissen.
Ja, ich glaub schon, dass sie da eine Menge Zeug anders benutzen als wir. Und auf jeden Fall natürlich auch, sich eine Menge auch gar keine Gedanken machen, was da hintersteckt, was interessiert die einfach gar nicht. Die wollen es einfach benutzen und klicken sich da einfach durch. Aber von denen kann man ja auch was lernen, so ist ja nicht.
Ich schließe das ja nicht aus, dass ich nicht da irgendwas lernen kann. Ich versuche ja auch schon die ganze Zeit, irgendwelche Informationen zu bekommen, aber es kann mir ja keiner irgendwas erklären.
Wir machen das nach der Sendung.
Du befreundest dich da mit deinen Freunden und dann guckst du dir in die Timeline rein, was die so alles getrieben haben, und da guckst du auf deiner Startseite und dann siehst du, was die so die ganze Tag über machen. Das ist das, was die Leute da mitmachen, mit diesem Facebook.
Okay, lass mal, lass das nach der Sendung. Komm, wir gucken nach der Sendung. Ja, wir gehen mal nach der Sendung kurz ein bisschen in dein Facebook.
Ja, warte mal, ist meine Timeline im Sinne von, wie in Twitter, meine Timeline das, was diese sogenannten Freunde alles schreiben? Oder ist meine Timeline das, was ich schreibe?
Das, was du schreibst.
Das, was die über dich sammeln. Also nicht nur schreibst, sondern auch, naja, was halt so alles passiert ist.
Ob du deinen Beziehungsstatus geändert hast.
Beziehungsstatus geändert, das gibt ein Hallo.
Facebook und Facebook, genau.
Beziehungsstatus?
Ja, das ist das Geile, als ich bei Buga...
Auf was kann man seinen Beziehungsstatus denn setzen?
Ich hab den zum Beispiel mal auf Verlobt gesetzt, das gab ein Hallo.
Ey, das war bei mir auch so. Ich hab bei Buga, muss ich ja dann mir meinen Stalker-Facebook-Account ein bisschen upgraden mit sinnvollen Informationen. Und dann dachte ich halt so, okay, Beziehungsstatus, ich hab den einfach auf Merit gestellt, weil ich hatte vorher alles eingestellt...
Und schon hat sich deine Freundin von dir getrennt.
Nee, nee, nee, dass niemand irgendwas sieht, ja. Hab ich alles gleich so eingestellt. So und dann setze ich das halt auf Merit, weil letztendlich ist das jetzt auch nicht weit weg davon.
Vergeben, vergeben, ja.
So. Und dann, ey, boah, da ging auch so ein Alarm plötzlich los. Was? Boah, herzlichen Glückwunsch und Ba-Bang! Von allen Seiten irgendwie.
Dieses Facebook, da kann man nicht einfach mal so rumspielen, wie man das sonst digital macht und so Zeug, sondern das wird alles gleich so für wahre Bohne genommen.
Das wird alles der Welt geteilt.
Voll ernst, die Mutter gratuliert von Oma, werden schon geschenkellos geschickt.
Wenn du dich selber als gestorben markierst, dann jede Wette, dann kommen Leute auf seine Beerdigung.
Cool, das heißt, wenn ich von Verwandten, die ich als Tod setze, kriege ich schon automatisch das Erbe.
Nicht umsonst will die Schufa diese Daten auswerten.
Ich glaube, das hat schon... Er stimmt wollen schon, die nur das Institut macht nicht mehr mit sowas. Ja, das wird aber trotzdem alles kommen.
Natürlich wird das kommen.
Beziehungsstatus Single in einer Beziehung.
Ich wundere mich schon, weil ich Ärger kriegen werde, weil ich keinen Facebook-Account habe.
Der Lob verheiratet, es ist kompliziert.
Aber sie haben immerhin den Status, es ist complicated. Das finde ich ja doch irgendwie ganz sympathisch.
In einer offenen Beziehung. Verwidwet. Getrennt, geschieden.
Das ist alles?
Das gibt es ja noch so.
Pssst, Menge also.
Pony.
Ich will ein freies Textfeld haben natürlich.
Discordisch.
Dann kann man seine ganze Familie da angeben.
Hab ich gestern in der Hand gehabt, den Flieger.
Ja und über Familie kriegst du darüber echt alles mit.
Das ist ganz cool, oder?
Der Hucke guckt irgendein Video, pack das mal im Chat.
Ne, das soll ich nicht verlinken.
Dann lese ich einfach die Uhr 11.
Nein, nein, nein, warte, weg ist sie.
Ah, Emails. timbrettlawetfacebook.com, da haben sie tatsächlich was hinzugefügt. Aber das kann man auch nicht löschen, ne?
So, haben wir denn jetzt noch Themen?
Ja, ich hab... Komm, lass mal dieses Facebook jetzt hier sein.
Das macht keinen Spaß.
Ich hab wieder was gefunden, was ich ausschalten kann. Das ist doch geil. Alles andere ist leer. Ich find das gut.
Okay, wir warten jetzt einfach mal, bis du da Facebook fertig geklickt hast.
Ich erzähl dir das hier so lange mal von UI Shape. Die haben mir nämlich lustigerweise da so einen kleinen Bastelbogen zugeschickt, wo man so ein ausgedrucktes iPhone in Original gerüstet raus hat. Also damit man so... Wie heißt das, Prototyping? Jaja, die gibt's immer mal wieder.
Man könnte ja die ganze Zeit...
Ich hätt gerne schon vor Jahren so einen Stenzel irgendwie, um sich so was auszumalen. So eine Schablone.
Ja, es gibt das auch als Schablone.
Oder so aus Alu, so ein Alublech mit dem...
Also das hatte ich nicht. Also das ist halt so ein Schreibblock quasi und auf jeder Seite ist so ein iPhone drauf gedruckt. Also nur die Konturen. Dann auch mal die Hälften so eingezeichnet. Man sieht auch so kleine Marker, wo oben die Statusleiste ist, damit man da so glatt meine gerade Linie rein machen kann. Und wenn man so hochmodern prototypt auf Papier und mit Bleistift, dann kann man sich da einfach hinsetzen und kann damit ja so prototypen. Wollte ich jetzt nur mal sagen.
Voll dufte.
Ich hab's aber noch nicht mal ausgepackt, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich hab die Tüte schon aufgemacht, hab's gesehen, aber ich hab noch nichts drauf rumgekritzelt. Aber kann man bestimmt auch ganz, ganz toll machen.
Ich halte dir auch immer noch was ganz anderes zu berichten. Und zwar für die Herrschaften, die gerne auch mal zur Programmiertätigkeit schreiten. Da gibt's ja im Internet glücklicherweise dieser Tage auch so viel von Konferenzen auch als Videoaufzeichnung. Und bisweilen gibt's ja auch echt immer mal coole Talks. Und es gibt im Speziellen gerade drei coole Talks, die ich kürzlich gesehen hab, die von gleichen Typen sind. Und zwar nämlich Rich Hickey, das ist jetzt mein neuer IT-Star. Das ist der Erfinder oder der Erschaffer von der Programmiersprache Closure. So ein Lisp, was auf der JVM läuft. Aber die Talks, die handeln nur sehr begrenzt von dieser Sprache, sondern eigentlich vom Programmieren im Allgemeinen. Und da gibt es drei Talks, die schmeiße ich jetzt auch einfach mal in den Chat. Und der Chat verlinkt die hoffentlich bestimmt auch gleich. Hulk. Hulk, genau, der nicht. Und zwar einmal Simple Made Easy, das ist der hier. Zack, dann der. Ich pack die aber gleich schnell hintereinander rein. Der und der.
Dann klink ich die mal alle ein.
Genau, und das sind wirklich echt extrem gute Talks, weil die halt nicht einfach so irgendwie jetzt so der nächste, also ich weiß nicht, bei ganz vielen Konferenzen wiederholen sich auch die Talks so über, der 1000. Talk über Agile Development oder Test Driven Development oder der 1000. Talk über, ja weiß schon, ne? Ja, was auch immer. Und das sind halt so eher generelle Talks und eher so ein bisschen philosophische Talks, wie zum Beispiel in dem einen geht es halt darum, dass er halt so sagt, dass Zeit in objektorientierten Programmiersprachen eigentlich total falsch behandelt wird und dass eigentlich Zeit sozusagen konzeptionell ganz anders behandelt werden müsste heutzutage.
Ah, davon habe ich mal was gehört, von diesem Vortrag, aber ich habe nie gesehen.
Und dieses genau Value, Identity und State dieser Talk, der ist halt richtig cool. Und da geht es dann eben noch so ein bisschen darum, warum vielleicht objektorientiertes Programmieren jetzt so populär geworden ist, aber warum funktionales Programmieren vielleicht trotzdem immer noch die bessere Alternative ist und wie man vielleicht so ein paar Sachen, wo man gemerkt hat, dass sie gut in objektorientierten Programmieren sind oder dass es halt die dazu geführt haben, dass die Leute objektorientiertes Programmieren total toll finden. Dass es vielleicht auch möglich ist, so ein paar von diesen Sachen mit ins Funktionale reinzuholen und dann sozusagen best of both worlds zu haben. Und erklärt aber, also er ist ein extrem guter Speaker, bringt auch seine Punkte gut rüber und er hat auch immer einfach schöne Themen. Also es ist halt immer so leicht programmierphilosophisch und sollte man sich, wenn man es mal mit dem Programmieren ernst meint, auf jeden Fall angucken. Und dann gibt es noch einen Talk, den habe ich glaube ich schon mal vor Ewigkeiten vielleicht erwähnt, aber ich weiß es nicht genau. Und das ist ein Talk, der heißt Herding Tigers. Und wer auch immer von euch in einer Firma arbeitet, mit Projektmanagern, wo ihr das Gefühl habt, naja, ob das jetzt wirklich alles so ganz zielführend ist und ob man das nicht vielleicht auch mit viel weniger Gequatsche hinbekommt, dem sei dieser Talk ans Herz gelegt.
Wo kommt mir das jetzt bekannt vor?
Moment, ich muss das mal kurz raussuchen, die URL ConFreaks. Ah, scheiße, wo war es denn hier? Mist, ich hatte doch die URL extra rausgesucht. Moment.
Das scheint Google, ich hab ja auch probiert, so eine Zeit lang DuckDuckGo zu verwenden, aber die ist nach wie vor nicht so gut wie Google. Muss man leider sagen.
Warte, ich hab's gleich, Herding Tigers, komm. Ja genau, die ist auch bei ContFreaks zur Aufzeichnung, mit irgendwie schön zum Downloaden und Video und so weiter. Also die Talks davor, das ist richtig cool. Die bei InfoQ, die bieten nämlich ihre Talk-Aufzeichnung auch als MP3 an und die Talks sind so, dass man nicht auf die Slides gucken muss, das heißt, man kann die sich auch quasi fast als Podcast auf ein Player holen und das ist echt super geil. Bei Herding Tigers, der Talk hier, den ich hier jetzt reinpaste, da kann man sich immer in die Videos runterladen, das ist auch schon mal ganz nett. Und diesem Herding Tigers ist nicht ganz ernst zu nehmen, der Talk ist schon sehr speziell weird und es geht halt so ein bisschen darum, wie Danny Blitz, so heißt der Vortragende in Lederjacke und Rockabilly-Frisur, sein Software-Team managt.
Da ließ man den Titel zu Ende.
And the Art of War, genau. Also er bringt auch so ein paar Kriegsbeispiele oder Referenzen, aber insgesamt ist der Talk schon echt geil und er hat auch einfach sehr viele wahre Punkte drin. Und wenn man das einfach in die breite Masse streut, dann kann die Welt nur besser werden. Also ich fand diesen Talk sehr gut und ich hab den auch schon sehr vielen Leuten gezeigt und alle fanden ihn eigentlich auch, also außer so ganz stark, pazifistisch eingerichtete, eingestellte Leute, die dann sagen, ja, aber diese Kriegsreferenzen, also das muss ja nicht sein. Muss ja auch nicht, aber ich glaube, er meint es auch nicht so ernst. Also ich glaube, man sollte das schon so mit so einem kleinen Filter vor den Augen angucken, aber er ist sehr unterhaltsam, ich finde, und hat sehr wahre Projektmanagement-Dinge.
Jetzt wird es in ordentlichen Dateien.
So, hatte ich noch einen Talk, oder? Nee, das war's jetzt mal. Rich Hickey-Talks gucken, Herding Tigers-Talks gucken und sowieso einfach mehr gucken. Dann hab ich ja noch eine kleine Meldung am Rande. Nämlich, wir hatten ja diese Editor-Sparte hier immer mal wieder. Und jetzt ist dieser eine Editor, den ich auch schon vor langer, langer Zeit schon mal angesprochen hatte. Dieser Chocolate ist jetzt in der 1.0 Final Version draußen.
1.1 sogar mittlerweile.
1.1 sogar mittlerweile. Und ich hab den jetzt auch noch mal wieder eine Weile probiert. Und für alle Leute, die so auf TextMate abgefahren sind und mit TextMate 2 vielleicht nicht ganz so warm geworden sind und sich denken, na okay, 21. Jahrhundert, soll das jetzt wirklich TextMate 2 sein? Die sollten sich mal Chocolate angucken. Also das ist für mich gerade der beste TextMate-Ersatz, wenn man denn wirklich schon dieses TextMate an sich toll fand. Die haben dann ein paar coole Sachen. Sublime ist aus anderen, also ich mag Sublime gerade lieber noch, aber aus Gründen, die jetzt eher so persönliche Präferenzen sind. Also es hat jetzt nicht so objektive Vorteile, würde ich jetzt sagen. Also generelle objektive Vorteile. Also Chocolate ist ein echt schon sauguter Editor. Hat halt, es fühlt sich schön OSXig an, hat auch coole Features wie eben so Split-Views und die sind auch schön implementiert. Also das ist nicht so wie in Vim, wo du dann erstmal einen V-Split aufmachen musst und dann mit E deinen File auf oder in Sublime, wo du auch irgendwie erstmal den View ändern musst, sondern in dem Moment, wo du im Project-Draw zwei Files anklickst, dann gehen die halt gleich sofort nebeneinander auf und es klickt sich echt ganz schön. Und sie haben auch Features für bestimmte Sprachen drin, zum Beispiel Ruby hat hier im LNCSS, dass du rechts gleich die Doku dazu brausen kannst und so bestimmte Sachen, die ich glaube auch gerade für Programmieranfänger einfach echt hilfreich sind. Also so ein bisschen auch dieses Coder, das ist ja auch so ein super integrated, hast du nicht gesehen, aber es ist eigentlich auch schon viel zu viel und nichts davon richtig. Und bei Chocolate ist schon das, was sie eingebaut haben, auch, finde ich, sehr gut umgesetzt. Und wie gesagt, das ist eben auch sehr ähnlich zu TextMate, so dass man sich nicht groß umgewöhnen muss, ist auch schneller und das ist insgesamt irgendwie viel runder. Also TextMate 2 zum Beispiel finde ich, der hat irgendwie seine Zeit einfach verpasst.
Und sich vielleicht ein bisschen viel vorgenommen, ne?
Ja, also schaut euch mal vielleicht die Trial an, das geht ja schon mal 14 Tage und dann, ich weiß nicht, was sie wollen für Geld, ich glaube 39 Dollar oder so was.
Ich glaube 40 Euro waren das.
Oder 40 Euro.
Mir sind gerade prompt gecrasht hier, als ich einfach nur den öffnen Dialog aufmachen wollte.
Doch, hat er natürlich. Folding gibt's. Klickt mal erstmal auf der Chocolate-Seite, da siehst du die Features. chocolateapp.com Da gibt's auch Folding. Na, da haben sie scheinbar tatsächlich keine Dreiecke in der Timeline.
Aber ohne Dreiecke geht's doch wirklich nicht.
Unmöglich. Ne, aber es gibt... Es gibt auf jeden Fall Folding. So, und wie gesagt... Sublime ist von den GUI-Editoren, also von den neuen Generationeditoren gerade immer noch so mein Favorit, weil er einfach so scheiße schnell ist und sich so ein bisschen... Weiß nicht, er ist mehr konfigurierbar, sag ich mal. Chocolate ist für mich auf Platz zwei, aber wie gesagt, ist auf jeden Fall der beste Text-Made-Ersatz und hat sehr coole Features. Probiert den mal aus. Kostet nichts ausprobieren.
So, falls jemand was hat, wie man so eine gute Einführung zu Google App Engine, bzw. besser gesagt eine Google, eine gute Referenz. Ich probier mich gerade mal so ein bisschen da reinzuarbeiten. Und ich stell mich so doof an. Also, bzw. ich hab mir Roddi gefragt, weil der hatte von Google App Engine eigentlich Gutes erzählt. Er fragt, wo find ich denn da mal brauchbare Dokumentation? Und er meinte, ja, klingt jetzt vielleicht doof, aber gibt's nicht. Also, man muss sich da wirklich selber durchgucken. Vielleicht hat ja jemand trotzdem mal einen guten Tipp.
Ich hab auch noch einen guten Tipp. Ich bin heute total vorbereitet. Ich hab auch einen guten Tipp. Ich hab mir heute dieses Mal so ein kleines Sticky hier im Dashboard, was es bestimmt bald nicht mehr geben wird, aber ich hab mir da ein Sticky gemacht mit Tim. Und zwar waren wir letztens hier bei Co-op, Tim und ich, hab ich den Tim zufällig getroffen.
Co-op ist ein Co-working-Space in Berlin.
Einer der prominentesten, sag ich mal, einer, der auf jeden Fall schon relativ früh am Start war und auch schon...
Auch einer derjenigen, die extrem auf Coding hin sind. Also wo du auch in anderen Co-working-Spaces viele Leute findest, so Beta-House und so weiter, ist es meistens mehr so die... Ja, also sehr universelles Berufsbild zu finden ist, ist es da halt sehr spezifisch Coding.
Genau, und sehr stark auch in der User-Group-Szene quasi, also irgendwie hatten, zeitweise hatte man das Gefühl, dass jede User-Group in Berlin irgendwie zumindest schon mal da war, oder vielleicht sogar auch regelmäßig, also JavaScript, Ruby, diese Front-Entler, die sind ja da dann hier. Hans mit seinen Lispern war ja da auch eine ganze Zeit lang. Ja, könnte man auch mal machen, durchaus. Also wie gesagt, die sind auf jeden Fall schwer involviert. Und die haben jetzt ausgebaut ein neues Stockwerk dazu genommen. Und da gab es Puddy und deswegen waren wir da.
Ach, die haben ausgebaut, krass. Das ist bestimmt trotzdem noch komplett ausgebucht.
War das da Adelbert-Straße, das Ding? Da, wo hier dieses Pottlauf-Dings war.
Das nächste Ding. So, und da haben wir ein Bierchen getrunken. Und ich war gerade mit Sven Fuchs am Reden. Die Rubiisten unter uns, die wissen, wer Sven Fuchs ist. Tim wusste es nicht. Und dann haben wir, weil Tim das nicht wusste, und ich war ganz überrascht, wollte ich das gleich nochmal hier, oder meinte Tim zumindest, dass ich das gleich nochmal im Podcast sagen, dass der Sven nämlich ein saukules Projekt gemacht hat. Erstens hat er bei seiner Firma aufgehört, wo er vorher war. Dann hat er gesagt, so jetzt... Das ist das Projekt? Ja genau, was auch, warte, warte. Ist echt eine coole Story. Dann hat er sich irgendwie überlegt, okay, jetzt mach ich erstmal ein bisschen Pause und das Arbeitsamt bezahlt mir erstmal noch ein paar Monate. Und in diesen Monaten, wo er sozusagen vom Start gelebt hat, hat er dann aber das nächste coole Projekt gestartet. So und das Projekt ist folgendes. Zwar in der Ruby-Community gab es mal ein Service, ich weiß, ich hab jetzt gerade vergessen, wie er heißt, aber du konntest deine Projekte da kostenlos auf verschiedenen Rechnern und verschiedenen Plattformen testen lassen. Also quasi Continuous Integration as a Service. Genau. So und die haben das erst kostenlos gemacht und irgendwann wurde es aber kostenpflichtig und irgendwann hat es sich nicht mehr gerechnet und dann haben sie es zugemacht. Und Sven war ein großer Fan davon und dachte sich, ja, scheiße, was macht man jetzt? Und so ein bisschen aus diesem Gedanken heraus hat er dann angefangen sozusagen ein Open Source Distributed Continuous Integration zu bauen. Und das heißt Travis CI, wie der Name Travis und CI für Continuous Integration, weil Tim hat gleich erstmal bei der Party, bei der Musik und ein Bier Travis TI verstanden. Und Travis, weil das irgendein Bauarbeiter in irgendeinem Kinderbuch oder so war und das war so das erste, was ihm nach hinten kommt. Wie das funktioniert, ist aber eigentlich der Knaller, weil ihr müsst eigentlich gar nicht viel tun. Wenn ihr einen GitHub-Account habt, dann könnt ihr auf Travis CI gehen, mit dem GitHub-Account einzeigen und dann seht ihr eine Liste eurer Projekte und klickt auf den Schalter auf ein, also, wie sagt man, klickt auf euer Projekt da halt in der Liste und dann schwuppdiwupp, wenn ihr das nächste Mal nach GitHub pusht, wird automatisch bei Travis gebaut. Und wie das funktioniert, ist, dass sie eine Farm von Servern haben und sie supporten echt viele Sprachen. Ruby, PHP, JavaScript, Erlang, verschiedene Java-Dialekte auch und auf diesen Bildmaschinen starten sie pro Testsuite eine eigene VM mit allem, was ihr braucht. MySQL, React, Redis, also mit einem ganzen Arsch voll von Dependencies wird supported. Das heißt, ihr könnt auch wirklich so einen Full-Stack-Integration-Tester drauf fahren. Dann wird die hochgefallen, eure Testsuite wird gebaut, ihr könnt spezifizieren, mit welchen Kommandos dann eben die Tests gefahren werden und dann werden die halt gebaut. Und sie haben natürlich momentan noch eine begrenzte Zahl von Workern, weil sie noch stark in der Entwicklung sind. Deswegen kann es dann halt mal natürlich auch ein Moment dauern, bis der Build durch ist, aber es wird halt gebaut. Und der Plan ist dann auch, dass sie zu einem Punkt kommen, wo sie einfach beliebig viele Boxen sozusagen dazustecken können. Und das Coole ist halt, er hat halt, wie gesagt, da vom Start finanziert angefangen und jetzt haben sie einen Spendenaufruf gemacht, um die nächsten coolen Features zu bauen, eben um zum Beispiel auch Pro-Accounts zu machen, dass du private Builds machen kannst und so. Und haben da halt einfach aus dem Stand quasi 100.000 Dollar eingesammelt, weil das einfach von sämtlichen Communities als supercooles Projekt angesehen wurde. Und wie gesagt, es könnte halt auch nicht einfacher sein. Gerade für Ruby-Projekte, super trivial, ich hab's jetzt mit anderen Sprachen noch nicht probiert, aber ihr seht halt auch, wenn ihr auf TravisCI Org geht, da baut halt alles möglich, auch mittlerweile einige Erlang-Projekte, Java-Projekte, zum Beispiel Rails selbst baut auf TravisCI und auch ganz viele andere namhafte, ich glaub PHP sogar, selbst das PHP-Projekt an sich will demnächst PHP sozusagen auf TravisCI bauen.
Was stand da C-Geschichten?
Na im Prinzip, ich weiß nicht, ob sie C schon supporten, aber es sollte definitiv möglich sein.
Und das Coole ist halt auch, zum Beispiel bei Ruby kannst du es halt auch gleich bei denen auf allen möglichen Implementationen laufen lassen, also auf JRuby, Rubinius, auf den unterschiedlichen C-Standard-Ruby-Implementierungen. Das heißt, du musst dich halt einfach selber nicht kümmern. Wenn du ein Gem schreibst, also eine Library, du packst es auf TravisCI, sagst, hier teste du das mit allen Implementationen, kriegst einen Report. Du kannst sogar auch hier live zugucken, wie es gebaut wird. Also sie streamen den Shell-Output auf die Webseite. Du kannst ja dann halt im Nachhinein... Also du siehst, kannst du hier live, wenn du auch gerade rauf geht und gerade die Builds, die gerade bauen, zugucken, wie sozusagen der Shell-Output da rein streamt.
Kommt mit sich das dann auch auf das Apple TV, so auf ein Großbild?
Und sie bauen jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch ein Feature ein, dass du für Gitter-Pull-Requests, also wenn du ein Open Source Projekt hast und jemand schickt dir einen Patch, dass du einstellen kannst, dass der automatisch auf Travis.ci vorher gebaut wird, dass du das, bevor du auf Merge klickst, schon weißt, ob deine Test-Suite bricht oder nicht. Also sie machen sozusagen einen Pre-Test für einen Pull-Request.
Und hat da auch schon die gleiche Irk-Integration. Es gibt da ganz viele Irk-Channels, viele Programme, wo gleich hier so ein CRD-Robot ist, der immer gesagt hier folgender Patch hat, hat nicht gebaut, irgendwie schuld ist der und der, weil der hat den letzten Patch gemacht.
Also das ist halt, es gibt eine API natürlich und ich hab das schon, also ich denke schon, dass du das zumindest in dein Irk-Bot mit einbauen kannst. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da jetzt schon einen gibt, der das supportet. Die Docs sind halt echt cool, also das ist wirklich insgesamt einfach ein sau-cooles Projekt. Und wenn ihr noch nicht wisst wohin mit eurem Geld und ihr wollt das mal vielleicht noch ein bisschen sponsern, da gibt es noch diese Seite love.travisci.org und da gibt es dann so schöne Sachen wie eine Coding-Session mit namhaften Ruby-Programmierern oder andere tolle Vorteile, was auch immer. Also wie gesagt, sie haben jetzt schon 109.000 Dollar eingenommen, von daher wird es wahrscheinlich auch erst mal ein Momentchen reichen.
Also es ist auch nicht mehr der alleine, sondern es sind auch schon mehr jetzt.
Genau, es sind mittlerweile drei Leute, aber die sind alle...
Nein, nur er und seine Badewanne voll Geld.
Ja, noch machen sie kein Geld, aber ich meine gut, wenn dann halt Private-Builds kommen, dann soll der Ruder machen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall wirklich ein sehr cooles Projekt und hat auf jeden Fall einige Karma-Punkte gebracht den Jungs. Ja, so, das war das da.
Vorhin hatte noch jemand im Chat, ich weiß leider nicht mehr wer es war, ich glaube Soda oder so hatte Hinweise darauf, dass es Gerüchte gibt über einen zweiten Apple-Store in Berlin, obwohl es den ersten gibt.
Habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Also haben sie irgendwelche...
Es ist ja fast auch schon Hinweis, dass es den ersten gar nicht mehr geben wird.
Nee, der zweite sieht kleiner aus. Also ich habe so ein Bild, es kommt daher, es gibt ja am Leipziger Platz dieses Rieseneinkaufszentrum. Leipziger Platz ist der kurz vor dem Potsdamer Platz. Wenn du die Leipziger Straße runterfährst, dann kommst du zum Potsdamer Platz.
Das ist ja so eine tote Stelle, wo man irgendwie nie ist, außer wenn man durchbrettert, oder?
Ja, und da bauen sie jetzt ein Einkaufszentrum hin, damit sich das ändert. Auf den Führerbunker obendrauf quasi.
Da, wo sie das Coffee-Drive-Buyers...
Also das ist dein Apple Store auf dem Hitlerbunker.
Da ist nicht der Hitlerbunker. Der Hitlerbunker war da, wo jetzt das Mahnmal...
Topografie des Terrors?
Nein, wo das Mahnmal steht. Welche? Die schwarzen Stelen.
Du meinst dieses...
Das Mahnmal für den Holocaust. Das Holocaust-Mahnmal.
Ja, das ist dabei. Ich dachte, das wäre eher... Ich dachte, das wäre früher auf Ostseite gewesen.
Das ist die Ostseite.
Aber haarscharf.
Haarscharf, das ist auf dem Todesstreifen. Der ganze Todesstreifen war Ostseite. Im Westen gab es keinen Todesstreifen.
Ist mir auch wurscht.
Sobald ich weiß.
Auf jeden Fall...
Also der...
Ist da ein Rendering aufgetaucht, nicht auf dem Hitler...
nicht auf dem Führerbunker entsteht.
Wäre ja auch zu lustig gewesen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da ein Rendering davon, wie da so ein Apple-Store drin rumglänzt. Nun kann das natürlich sein, dass die das da nur gemacht haben, um andere Kunden anzuwerben, andere Potenziale. Aber es ist wohl irgendwie... Aber könnte auch sein, dass es echt ist.
So voll die tote Gegend da, oder?
Das war ein Steckerlärm hier.
Potsdamer Platz, da ist niemand. Das ist total tot.
Das ist ja eben nicht der Potsdamer Platz, sondern die Ecke davor.
Direkt daneben. Die andere Seite vom Potsdamer Platz ist der Leipziger Platz. Ach, da wo auch immer die iPad-Werbung ist? Da wo diese ganzen Potemkinschen Gebäude sind, diese ganzen Gerüstbauten.
Die immer so zugehangen waren mit Werbung, weil da die Gerüste noch dran waren. Ich dachte, der nächste Straßeneck, ihr meint schon direkt die andere Seite. Straßenseite. Das heißt schon gleich anders.
Da ist der Leipziger Platz, von oben siehst du der Platz. Hier ist der Potsdamer Platz.
Ich weiß keine Ahnung, ob das da ein Einkaufszentrum hinkommt.
Also da ist schon ein riesiges Einkaufszentrum. Und tendenziell ist natürlich dieser Platz A erstmal ein totaler Touristenmagnet, B ist es ein potenziell wird es halt immer noch ein bisschen wilder werden, weil irgendwann ist es halt auch S-Bahn mäßig noch besser erschlossen, wenn erstmal die S-Bahn über den Hauptbahnhof fährt, etc., Und diese neue Mall da, die wird ja nochmal so richtig fett. Das ist das ehemalige Wertheimgebäude im Übrigen, wo der Tresor war, der so hieß, weil er halt im ehemaligen Tresor- Gebäude des Wertheimgebäudes war. Und dieses Areal, das wird sozusagen jetzt neu bebaut, halt wieder mit einem Warenhaus, insofern ist das quasi Kontinuität. Und ich kann mir das ganz gut vorstellen, dass sie da einen Store reinmachen, auch wenn ich jetzt keine Ahnung habe, ob das irgendwie passt. Ich finde das ganz interessant, dass sie dann von vornherein gleich irgendwie zwei Stores in Berlin planen würden, aber das wäre dann zumindest mal einer im Osten. Knapp, aber im Osten. Ja, ich meine, gut, wir wissen ja, Apple geht generell mit ihren Stores immer nur in Bereiche, wo wirklich High-Ton-Over ist, wo wirklich viele Leute durchkommen oder wo es große Kaufkraft gibt.
Kannst du ja mal auf den Link klicken, das sieht schon ganz schick aus.
Ja, ich kann nicht auf den Link klicken.
Mach mal Screensharing an.
Ja, und wir hatten noch eine andere lustige Sache. Gestern war ja der 1. Juli und Schallsekunden.
Das war ein anderes Rennring, als ich gesehen habe. Ich hab eins gesehen, wo das wirklich der Haupteingang unten war. Also sozusagen direkt zum Platz. Das wäre ja jetzt sozusagen nur so ein Innenmall, ein Etagendingsbums.
Vielleicht haben die auch einfach an mehrere Stellen Apple-Stores gerendert.
Wobei das könnte ich mir auch ganz gut vorstellen, dass sie sowas machen. Weil es einfach...
Oder die haben in dem Gebäude...
Dass sie da einfach noch mal so ein Mini-Teil reinbauen. Also ich glaube, was mich jetzt überraschen würde, ist, wenn sie noch mal so ein Megamonster wie am Kudamm bauen. Weil ich glaube, das Kudamm-Teil wird schon so ein bisschen ihre Zentrale sein, auch was so diese ganzen Trainings und so weiter betrifft. Und das wäre halt so der optimale Ergänzungs-Store, um die Touris damit zu nehmen, beziehungsweise die Leute, die da halt rumshoppen. Passt schon.
Wollen wir noch kurz über Linux-Absturztag reden? Gestern?
Gab's einen?
Ja, ich war selber auch betroffen. Mein Server war auch weg.
Diese Debians haben sich echt weggelegt, weil da eine Sekunde falsch war.
Das war kein Debian, das war ein Ubuntu.
Ist doch Debian oder nicht? Mehr oder weniger schon.
Na ja, klar, es basiert auf Debian, aber ich dachte, die wären mittlerweile mal weit genug.
Gab's den Back im NTP-Server?
Gab's den nur im NTP-Server, oder war das wirklich ein Kernel-Bug? Ich hab's noch nicht so richtig verfolgt.
Hätte ich gesagt, hab ich das auch nicht gelesen, scheiße.
Ich hab das gelesen, weil ja auch Parabay irgendwie Probleme hatte.
Das hatten alle Probleme. Du meintest, dass man das Twitter-Probleme hatte?
Also mein FreeBSD-Server loft.
Jungs, FreeBSD rockt.
Die hatten Probleme wegen der Gewitterstürme.
Ach, die hatten wegen der Gewitterstürme?
Ja, Amazon ist auch wie ein kompletter Kernel-Bug.
Kaum blitzt es mal in der Cloud.
Kernel-Bug, und was für ein Kernel-Bug war das?
Also, wisst ihr, alle haben sich eingeschissen wegen Jahr 2000. Und dann kommt so eine Schaltsekunde daher und nimmt hier mal irgendwie das halbe Linux-Universum runter. Das ist ja hart.
Das ist aber nicht so schlimm, die Schaltsekunde kommt nur alle paar Jahre.
Du, Jahr 2000 kommt nur einmal.
Aber wie hat sich denn diese Schaltsekunde in dem Moment bemerkbar gemacht?
Also bei mir war das so, wenn ich einen Pin gemacht hab, kam kein Pong.
Das Netzwerk war weg.
Ich meine, wodurch wurde diese Schaltsekunde sozusagen bekannt gegeben? Dass sozusagen die Referenz-NTP-Server gesagt haben, jetzt ist eine Sekunde später, als es vorher war.
Ich vermute mal, dass die die Länge des Tages anders angegeben haben.
Ist die zusätzlich?
Die haben ja Tabellen in allen US, weil die müssen ja auch wissen, welche Zeitzone, wo gerade wie ist und wann umgestellt werden muss, an welchem Datum. Das müssen die alles vorher wissen. Das holen die sicherlich per NTP. Und wenn halt gerade kein Netz hat, dann geht dein Rechner erstmal eine Weile falsch. Sondern die können auch ohne NTP das umstellen, weil die wissen das schon. Und da gibt es so eine offizielle Stelle, wo die Schallsekunde announced wird. So wie so ein Amtsblatt oder so. International wird das halt bekannt gegeben. Und das findet halt am 1. Juli um 0 Uhr GMT statt, was bei uns dann 1 Uhr nachts war. Das heißt, wir hatten sozusagen 0 Uhr 59 und 60 Sekunden. Also die 60. Sekunde, also nach 59 kam dann 60 und dann kam erst die 0. Genau. Und das weiß der Rechner anhand von so einer Tabelle, die er schon kennt eigentlich.
Ah, 60 Sekunden.
Ach, das hast du nicht mitbekommen, dass es eine 60. Sekunde gab?
Na, ich hab mitbekommen, ich wusste nicht...
Hat dir das deine Atomuhr nicht mitgeteilt?
Bei der Atomuhr kann ich euch auch erklären, wie es da funktioniert.
Mein iPad läuft noch, also...
Ja, aber interessant ist ja, was er in der Sekunde gemacht hat. Also wahrscheinlich ist er nämlich erst mal eine Weile falsch gelaufen, bis halt dein NTP auf deinem iPhone, da sich... auf deinem iPad sich neu korrigiert hat.
Nee, der holt sich ja die richtige, der holt sich ja live die Zeit.
Ja, aber wie oft? Nicht pro Sekunde.
Ah, der holt die... Alle gleiche Tabelle, oder?
Hat das keiner getestet vorher?
Dieses Atom-Clock, die er hat, die macht ja ihre eigene Zeit, deswegen singt die auch am Anfang, war eigentlich die Zeit vom iPad ja schon da. Und deswegen ist unklar, wie die Uhr da genau läuft, weil die wird ja unabhängig von der Systemzeit da laufen. Also deswegen mit Uhren ist alles komplett kompliziert.
Zeit ist sowieso so eine komplizierte Sache.
Hast du über Kalender geredet?
Hast du gerade Kalender zu mir gesagt?
Torette. McTorette.
Diese kulturelle Anspielung habt ihr nicht verstanden? Dennis, auch du? Auch du, Brutus.
Ich hab's akustisch nicht verstanden.
Und das an einem Tag, in dem Tim schon durchdreht wegen der Facebook-Seite.
Da verbringt er schon seine halbe Jugend mit dem Schauen von Filmen und dann kennt er diese Anspielung nicht. Cleaning Woman. Putzfrau. Cleaning Woman. Siehst du mal da, kommt gleich hier. Steve Martin. Tote tragen keine Karos.
Ich finde Steve Martin nicht so cool.
Du hast... Tote tragen keine Karos nicht gesehen. Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch, habe ich bestimmt gesehen, aber erstens war ich bestimmt jünger und da gab es das im Fernsehen und wahrscheinlich nicht auf Englisch.
Wir sagten nur Kaffee machen.
Und zweitens bin ich wirklich nicht so der Steve Martin Fan.
Ich finde, das war wirklich einer der lustigsten Filme, die ich überhaupt kenne. Also es ist wirklich...
Wie heißt der?
Ich verstehe gerade, ob man sich den antauscht.
Man schaut so, oder? Auch nur irgendwie erdenkbaren Top 10, wo es irgendwie um Humor geht, muss dieser Film vertreten, weil... Tote tragen keine Karos. In Englisch? Und das Großartige an diesem Film ist, dass er komplett aus alten Räuberpistolen, Schwarz-Weiß-Filmen zusammengeschnitten ist und Steve Martin wird sozusagen noch mit dazu geschnitten. Das heißt, dieser Film besteht eigentlich aus alten Filmen, aber er erzählt eine komplett neue Geschichte.
Also so wie Forrest Gump so reingeschnitten, ja?
Ja, nicht genau so wie Forrest Gump und es gibt auch noch so ein paar originäre Szenen, aber es kommt halt immer mal wieder irgendwelche alten Heroen, Burt Lancaster und diese ganzen anderen Räuberpistolen, Helden und so weiter, die da einfach mit drin sind und da wird dann halt so eine Detektivgeschichte erzählt. Und es ist halt wirklich sehr lustig.
Also für eine Komödie hat dann eine 6,7, was auf der IMDB schon relativ gut ist. Weil Komödien sind generell auf IMDB immer sehr miessbewertet.
Also 6,7 ist dann schon gut.
Also es ist schon solide, sag ich mal, für Komödie.
Und Kaffee. Kaffee machen und Cleaning Woman. Na gut, aber auch dieser Witz kam nicht so richtig an. Aber die Hörer sind wahrscheinlich schon alle viel weiter. Und lachen sich jetzt schon wieder kaputt. Aber ob die Erinnerungen an diesen Film. Gut, wo wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz reden sollten, weil wenn ich mich recht entsinne, haben wir das hier noch nicht besprochen, ist Super Fav.
Ich dachte du sprichst jetzt auf den Super Fav. Ich dachte du sprichst jetzt die Neuigkeiten, nein nicht die Neuigkeiten, aber die Meldung schlechthin von letzter Woche an. Und dann kommst du mit Super Fav.
Was ist denn die Meldung schlechthin, letzte Woche?
Nein, ich mein für uns ja, also die, die wir ja schon lange voraus wissen, was die Zukunft in petto hat, sag ich mal, ist diese Meldung, die ich jetzt in den Chat paste, eigentlich natürlich überhaupt gar keine News gewesen. War uns ja alles komplett klar. Aber das war sozusagen nochmal der letzte Sargnagel auf diese epische Geschichte, die so verheißungsvoll begann mit dem Versprechen, dass Flash auf Mobile ja eine rosige Zukunft haben würde. Und das war wirklich jetzt nochmal so der, also für alle, die es immer noch nicht begriffen haben, war das jetzt nochmal...
Aber hat's doch, Rim hängt und hält weiter an Flash auf Mobile fest.
Das ist absolut bedrückend, wie viele Webseiten einem immer noch irgendwie Flash in den Browser reinschmeißen, die explizit sagen, dass sie es nicht haben.
Das sind alles schlechte Seiten, wenn man die nicht gucken kann.
Wir müssen es auch noch mal kurz sagen. Es geht darum, weil die Leute, die jetzt hören, die haben vielleicht den Link noch nicht geklickt. Adobe hat confirmed, dass es Flash nicht mehr auf Android quasi supporten will. Also mobile generell so, mehr oder weniger. Und das war sozusagen die Meldung. Ich fand es schon nochmal schön, dass du aus Adobe's Munde auch am Ende zu hören hast. Also all diesen, ihr könnt euch alle erinnern an diese tollen Presseversprechen und dass Apple ja so doof ist.
Aber so war das nicht.
No Keyboard war das. Viel realistischer.
Du musst mal wieder das einmal eintun, wir haben das schon so lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Ah ja, hier geil, der Link von Gruber ist natürlich auch schön. Der hatte da auch so einen schönen Post.
Aber es sind ja gerade so Seiten, die noch Flash verwenden.
Ich hab das schon so mit abgeschlossen. Das haben wir doch schon vor drei Jahren hier diskutiert.
Eben, für uns nicht, aber ich glaube...
Aber Seiten, die noch Flash verwenden und Seiten, die nicht fürs iPad optimiert sind. Meine Freundin hat gestern Ferienunterkünfte rausgesucht, wo wir im Urlaub hinfahren. Und hat sich in der bevorzugten Region die entsprechenden Ferienhäuser angeguckt auf dem iPad. Und liebe Ferienhausbetreiber, hätte...
Break-and-Bed-Fest-Ride.
Nein, Bad-and-Break-Fest-Ride.
Kommt das doch mit Airbnb?
Ich glaube, das gibt es da nicht so auf dem Dorf. Auf jeden Fall hat sie sich immer die ganzen Dinge, die Ferienwohnungen angucken wollen. Und alles, was nicht auf dem iPad lief, ist wirklich so gnadenlos zugemacht worden. Also ich glaube, wenn man das so als Ferienwohnung-Betreiber gesehen hätte, würde man sofort zu seinem Webdesigner gehen und ihn schlimm schütteln, damit er endlich die Webseite iPad-Tablet macht.
Also bei uns in der Firma gibt es ja auch viele Flash-Developer, weil für Spiele ist es ja nach wie vor ein Thema. Und da meinte einer letztens bei Mittagessen auch, dass es jetzt bei den Agenturen ist das jetzt wirklich einfach auf dem Abstellgleis. Und es wird jetzt einfach gnadenlos aussortiert. Und die einzigen, die jetzt noch so wirklich das haben und wahrscheinlich noch zwei Jahre haben werden, sind Autokonzerne. Also kannst auf jeden Autohersteller auf die Webseite gehen. Die haben alle Flashes. Bei Motorradhersteller auch so. Und die meint er, die haben das halt noch so. Die haben sich das irgendwie mal so eingehandelt und haben da so vielleicht auch so eine Agentur am Start. Aber auch die werden so in spätestens zwei Jahren davon runter sein.
Aber das sind ja nicht nur Auto- und Motorradfirmen. Ich glaube, das sind ganze Menge Firmen, die so Produkte haben, die ja auch irgendwie mit Technik beworben werden müssen, wo du so ein bisschen auch Videos und Zeug und Animationen einspielen willst und so. Die nehmen alle Flasche, oder?
Ja, aber es stirbt halt aus.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das war schon mal ein Fehler, das so zu bewerben.
Da finde ich ja von Google gerade diese ganzen Seiten für ihre neuen Geräte. Die ist echt hübsch geworden. Also sie haben da so ein bisschen mit HTML5 auch nicht zu übertrieben, aber schon ganz, ziemlich grandiose Effekte. Und das ist natürlich alles in HTML5 brav gemacht.
Ich brauche mal noch was zu trinken.
Sag was zu Superfuff.
Ihr wisst, wovon ich rede.
Was trinkst du?
Ich nehme noch...
Ach, bring mir noch so ein Bier mit, bitte.
Huckel weiß nicht wovon. Naja, also wir hatten doch hier schon mal... Du weißt nicht, was du trinken sollst, Huckel? Du weißt, was du trinken willst. Huckel, ein Mann, der weiß, was er trinken will.
Nee, kein Rauchbier, bitte.
Wieso ist da noch mehr Rauchbier?
Ja, da waren auch diverse Rauchbier.
Diverse?
Dann kann ich jetzt hier kurz...
Also, ich glaub, drei waren da insgesamt.
Ich find das wittig. Um schnell mal eine Lücke zu füllen.
Ach ja, ihr Lückenfüller. So, jetzt ist es. Superfuff ist auch ein Lückenfüller.
Was hast du denn für kurze... Ich hab dir diese kurzen Hosen noch nicht gesehen. Die zeigen ja mehr als sie verbergen.
Bist du sexuell geschockt jetzt, oder was? Hätt ich meinen Bein etwas mehr einatmen können?
Ich bin jetzt hier mit Geschlechtsrumpfel.
Na, bei Max hört der sexy über den Knie auf.
Tut mir leid, ich bin zu sexy für diesen Podcast, willst du sagen, oder?
Alter, sexy vor dem Podcast.
Ich bin zu sexy für diesen Podcast, willst du sagen, oder? Ja, ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Ich spur mal kurz zurück, wir haben uns hier auch schon mal über dieses Flatter-Problem mit Instacast und so weiter unterhalten. Und soweit ich mich erinnere, haben wir auch irgendwie über Modelle nachgedacht, wie man denn das so generell in den Griff kriegen könnte. Und eins dieser Modelle ist ja, dass man das, was Instacast derzeit tut, abbildet auf eher ein allgemeineres Konzept von Favoriten und History. Weil genau genommen ist ja genau das, was Instacast gemacht hat. Du fandest etwas toll und hast gesagt, bitte flattern. Oder du hast gesagt, alles, was ich hier ohnehin konsumiere und flatterbar ist, flattern. Automatisch. Und manche haben sich für das eine und manche haben sich für das andere entschieden. Also entweder explizite Beglückwunschungen oder eben so hier alle sollen was abkriegen, die in irgendeiner Form zur Party beigetragen haben. So und um jetzt sowas zu machen ohne den Segen von Apple im App Store, kann man erst im Prinzip ja auch genau auf sowas reduzieren und das haben ja auch viele andere Netze. Gibt ja fast kein Social Network, was nicht in irgendeiner Form so einen Stern hat und wo du sagen kannst, ist toll. So und da erwuchs dann so die generelle Idee und Debatte, die so auch im ganzen Flatter-Universum geführt wird. Und einer ist dann hier aus Berlin, der Udo, der ist dann irgendwie auch einfach mal tätig geworden und hat so eine kleine Webseite aufgesetzt, die heißt superfuff.com. Und superfuff.com erlaubt es dir, dich kurz einzuloggen mit deinem Twitter-Account und auch mit deinem Flatter-Account und damit sind die beiden dann quasi verbunden. Und SuperFuff liest halt regelmäßig von deinem Twitter-Account deine Fuffs und flattert die. Das heißt, du kannst Tweets flattern mit jeder beliebigen Twitter-App, in dem du einfach die Favoritenfunktion benutzt. Du sagst einfach, das finde ich toll und später wird dann hintenrum, ohne dass irgendeine App irgendeinen Flatter-Support braucht, im Backend automatisch daraus ein geflatterter Tweet. Und das geht halt deshalb so.
Und dann wird immer die Adresse geflattert. Weil man könnte ja auch theoretisch, wenn man da…
Welche Adresse?
Die Twitter-Adresse.
Ja, genau.
Aber nicht, wenn man eine URL postet, dass der auf die Seite geht und guckt, ob da ein Flatter integriert ist.
Da ist ja kein Flatter integriert, aber das ist auch nicht erforderlich, weil Flatter kann ja das eindeutig einem User zuordnen in dem Moment, wo du in deinem Flatter-Account dich auch dort mit deinem Twitter-Account nochmal autorisiert hast. Das heißt, du hast einen Flatter-Account, du gehst da rein und sagst hier, auf diesen Twitter-Account habe ich Zugriff, genauso wie du das auch in SuperFuff machst und damit weiß Flatter eben, also Flatter hat explizites Wissen über die Struktur von Twitter-URLs.
Ja, wenn nicht sind es halt auch diese nicht eingesammelten Flatters, so wie...
Genau, die sind so lange auch erstmal unclaimed, aber wenn du halt jetzt in deinem Twitter-Client, also wenn du einmal durch SuperFuff durchgegangen bist und du sagst dann hier, geiler Tweet irgendwie, bester Kommentar ever, Klicksternchen, so, dann irgendwie eine Stunde später kommt ein SuperFuff vorbeigerollt, sammelt von dir deine Fuffs ein, zieht diese URL und schickt die zu Flatter und sagt hier einmal flattern und Flatter wiederum macht dann eben den Look ab über den Twitter-Namen und sieht, ah, welcher Flatter-Account ist denn diesem Twitter-Account, der jetzt hier geflatht wurde und so weiter. Ja, klingt erstmal kompliziert, ist es natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch, aber für den User muss ja nichts davon tun, du musst nur einen Flatter-Account haben und den mit deinem Twitter-Account assoziiert haben und für denjenigen, der flattert, der muss eben denselben Spaß andersrum bei SuperFoF gemacht haben. Das interessante daran ist, dass das ja eben auch ganz gut auf andere Systeme skaliert, die unter Umständen noch nicht mal im Web sind. So was weiß ich, so was wie Instacast zum Beispiel.
Jetzt wo du gerade skaliert sagst, ich seh gerade das mit Node.js gemacht, ich glaub da muss ich gleich mal so einen Flatter-Button klicken, damit ich dann mal ein Erlangbuch leisten kann, der gute Optik fluffelt. Und das noch mal ordentlich macht. Aber ja.
Solange es funktioniert, ist es ja auch erstmal ganz gut, läuft irgendwie auf irgendeinem Heroku-Stuntz und...
Da musst du ja erst recht flattern.
Ja, es gibt auch keine besseren Implementierungen als die, die real existieren. Ja, so und jetzt kann man natürlich auch ein bisschen weiter drüber nachdenken. Allerdings ist jetzt flatter quasi da am Zuge, weil sie jetzt eigentlich eben dieses Claiming erweitern müssen auf möglichst viele Dienste. Und wenn du jetzt diesen ganzen Climbim von Social Networks und Content Sharing Sites nimmst, die alle irgendwie so einen Favoriten-Feature haben und auch ohraus bieten und eine API, die Favoriten liefert, das sind quasi die Voraussetzungen.
Geht das bei Facebook ja auch, ne?
Naja, also bei Facebook ist es ein bisschen schwierig.
Die Likes abgreifen?
Naja, gut, aber diese Likes sind natürlich ein bisschen was anderes als FUFs.
Also ich würde Likes, nee. Naja, für mich nicht.
Das könnte man so sagen, nur dass natürlich an diesen Likes-Sachen...
Du kannst ja optional machen, aber das ist...
Das ist ja auch so ein temporäres Abo-auslösendes Element. Also du benutzt ja diesen Like-Button, selbst wenn du Sachen nicht likest. Na, um Dingen so zu folgen.
Das ist ja so ein Subscriber auch.
Damit die deine Timeline da hängen und so.
Eine höhere Stufe als Like haben die denn nicht? Also das ist nicht nur Folgen, wenn man es auch wirklich toll findet.
Na, da fragst du natürlich mit mir den richtigen Facebook-Expert.
Nein, haben sie nicht. Bucke, was sagst du dazu?
Like ist das höchste Gefühl auf Facebook.
Du kannst deinen Status auf Merit setzen.
Oder dummes Wortspielen mit Willi.
Genau. So, okay, ja, nee, aber prinzipiell auf jeden Fall eine coole Idee.
Das heißt, man braucht keine Special-Apps, keinen gar nichts, sondern ich nehme einfach meine Twitter-Apps, fahr fertig.
Genau, und das könnte man natürlich dann theoretisch auch auf so Sachen wie YouTube zum Beispiel ergänzen. Weil du ja bei YouTuber auch Favoriten hast.
Klar, Facebook, OAuth, wenn man bei YouTube mit Login arbeitet, oder wie? Hast du einen?
Echt, wieso? Ich glaube... Google-Account, ja, irgendwie brauchte man auch einen. Ich wollte mal irgendwas posten und das sollte dann irgendwie, und dann musste ich einen Account machen.
Wenn man was hochspielen will, genau.
Ich hab da immer das andere Leute machen lassen, die einen YouTube-Account haben. Ich hab den, mein Google-Account mir nur besorgt wegen diesem Google-Wave und danach irgendwie in die Videobeschreibung.
Nee, es war doch auch immer so, bei YouTube gab's auch Videos, die irgendwie so eine Altersbeschränkung oder irgendwie sowas hatten und du brauchtest einen Account.
Stimmt, dafür braucht man das auch irgendwie.
Es gibt alle möglichen Gründe, warum man so einen YouTube-Account haben kann. Aber ich wollte das jetzt einfach nur mal einbringen, erst mal als generelle Überlegung. Einerseits, wie man eben so Flatter auch überall mit reinbringen kann. Es gibt dann einfach die Möglichkeit, noch ganz andere Leute mal mit Geld zu versorgen.
Ich hab dem Travis CI Leuten auch schon gesagt, sie sollen mal Flatter-Button einbauen.
Aber es hängt halt so ein bisschen. Aber was könnte man denn bei Travis CI so flattern?
Oh, grüne Bilds flattern, irgendwie automatisch. Kannst du sagen, hier, wenn das Projekt grün ist, dann gibt's einen Klick Nein. Aber, ne, erst mal das Projekt selber natürlich. Also, die sammeln ja konstant auch immer noch so Geld, sozusagen, um ihr Projekt weiter zu treiben. Und es ist ja auch ein Open Source Community-Projekt vorrangig.
Das heißt, wenn man ein Projekt ist, muss man sich da auch erst mal einen Account machen?
Nee, wenn du einen GitHub-Account hast, dann nimmst du einfach den. Also, sie benutzen GitHub oauth-basically. Und dann musst du wirklich, also wenn du eingeloggt bist, klickst du nur das Sign in, nur das GitHub, bist automatisch drin, siehst dir, dass du deine Projekte klickst auf Go. Also, das ist sozusagen deren Ding. Aber ich meine ja sozusagen, für Travis die Ei selber ein Flatter-Button. Also, dass die Travis-Jungs Flatter-Kohle kriegen.
Ach so, naja gut, das ist ja einfach. Aber noch cooler wär's ja, wenn sie auch für andere Leute das bieten würden und dann daran mitverdienen.
Ja.
Die Frage ist nur, welche Aktivität da abgebildet werden kann, weil GitHub gibt's jetzt schon in Flatter. Also GitHub-Claiming ist jetzt schon möglich. Die Frage ist nur, was du quasi abbildest. Aber wenn du deine eigene, in deinem eigenen System, also in dem Falle in Travis die Ei auch über GitHub machst, dann kannst du eben auch alles, was irgendwie über GitHub und so weiter. Also das ist vielleicht mal eine interessante Anregung. Ich hatte vorhin schon drüber nachgedacht, was da so ist, aber ich dachte immer nur, das ist so, naja, da passiert ja eigentlich nichts. Man macht ja nicht auf Travis die Ei Dinge, sondern man lässt es da nur geschehen. Und es gibt da keine Aktivitäten. Super wäre es natürlich, wenn GitHub selber mal eine Favoritenfunktion hätte für commits. Und derzeit gibt es das nur für, ich weiß nicht, was kann man da sternen? Da kann man irgendwie... Du kannst was watchen.
Die Gists kann man, oder?
Genau, wobei ich jedes Mal wieder vergiss, was das ist.
Na, das ist so was wie so ein persistentes Pasty oder so. Das könnte man sagen. Also du kannst halt Code Snippets da reintun, aber kann man die? Die kann man starren, ja, genau.
Genau, die kann man starren. Und wenn man irgendwie mal GitHub überreden könnte, dass sie mal, dass man jeden commit starren kann, dann wäre sozusagen GitHub automatisch komplett flatterbar. Da müsste man nur noch das bauen. Und soweit ich weiß, also eins der nächsten Ziele von SuperFuff ist auch explizit GitHub-Support. Da müsste man halt nur noch GitHub dazu bekommen, dass sie mal ein Sternchen auf jeden Punkt... Alles. Eigentlich alles. Also jegliche Aktivität, die ich toll finde, würde ich halt gerne so einen Stern drauf werfen. Ich meine, wenn jetzt jemand einen... einen Komet macht, in eine Codebase, von einer Software, wo halt ein Bug war, der mich total genervt hat, so, und ich find's toll, dass er das gemacht hat, dann gibt's da einfach... Stern.
Und Arsch.
Toll, machen wir alles Sternschen. Also, super, fahrfahr, haben jetzt alle verstanden, wie es geht?
Ja, meldet euch da an und......flattert Tweets.
Ich hab ja hier noch mal so eine Lebenserfahrung zu berichten, nachdem wir letztes Jahr... letztes Mal ja über iPad und Fernsehen und Apple TV und sowas geredet haben. Ich hab jetzt... saß irgendwann zu Hause und dachte doch, jetzt kann man ja eventuell mal Fußball gucken.
Auf dem iPad?
Auf dem iPad nicht, sondern schon auf dem Fernseher. Aber auf dem Fernseher hab ich halt nur... ich hab kein HD, weil da bräuchte ich so extra so eine Box, weil der Fernseher hat kein DVB-Dingsbums-Dreck, sondern hat nur analoges Kabel drinne. Und ich hab da auch keinen Bock jetzt irgendwie. So, und dann hab ich mir einfach kurzerhand... Satu einen Tag die HD-Version gekauft. Und per Airplay draufgespielt. Also Satu so auf dem... Weil Huckel guckt etwas fragend. So nennt Satu nicht mit Doppel-T und Doppel-O. Zatto! Und ja, da kann man Fernsehen gucken. So alle möglichen Sender, gerade die öffentlich-rechtlichen. Und die haben auch eine ganz okere iPad- und iPhone-App. Und dann hab ich halt die iPad-App gestartet und hab da gesagt, ok, mach mal HD hier und dann hab ich gesagt, zeig mir das mal per Airplay auf dem Fernseher an. Und das Bild, also es war halt kein HD, das war kein 720p. Aber das war deutlich besser als das normale, so Palldreck, was man normalerweise hat. Also war schon ein massiver Qualitätsunterschied. Ich konnte leider keinen Langzeit-Test machen, weil dann irgendwie meine Freundin, die eigentlich, ich will ja gar kein Fußball gucken, eigentlich guckt ja nur meine Freundin Fußball, die meinte dann so, als sie dann irgendwas mit Latenz mitgekriegt hat, wie Latenz, nee, dann gucken wir doch Kabel.
Wenn die Nachbarn schon fünf Sekunden früher jubeln.
Ne, ne Minute ist es.
War eh nur Italien, England. Ich hab mal gestoppt, das waren so 25 Sekunden Latenz.
Achso, ist das wenn man hier, ich hab gerade zart mal geklickt, jetzt hier sieht man gerade Sean Bean hier. Genau, man muss ja nicht die HD-Version kaufen, die kostet 1,50 Euro oder was? Dann kann man 24 Stunden lang Zattu HD gucken, egal welcher Sender kann man sich halt aussuchen. Man kann aber auch da ganz normal den halt in klein gucken, ohne HD, jeden Sender, alles mögliche, jetzt ist gleich mal die Batterie leer. Und dann hab ich mal gemessen und das war so eine Minute. Und das ist beim Fußballspielen ganz schön fies, weil du weißt, also es hat Vorteile und hat einen Nachteil, ich weiß nicht, wenn es jetzt um Fußball geht, aber es ist halt nun mal so. Das hat einen Vorteil und einen Nachteil, der Nachteil ist, du brauchst nicht so richtig hingucken, weil es ist nicht spannend, weil du weißt, da wird eh grad kein Tor geschossen, weil sonst hätten alle anderen schon gejubelt. Das Coole ist aber, du kannst, wenn alle anderen jubeln hingucken, und dann kommt das Tor bald. Es macht das spannend und aber auch wieder nicht.
Ja, also man kann mal so wie ein echter Experte fühlen. Jemand, der immer hinguckt, wird es gerade die spannenden Sachen passieren.
Diese Art von Vorteil, das ist für so eine kleine, super kleine Nische ein Vorteil und für den Rest der Welt irgendwie so ein Nachteil.
Du siehst ja, wann ein Tor kommt. Nur ein bisschen später halt. Aber ich glaube, wenn man die HD-Version kauft, dann ist es ein Stück schneller. Das sind so 500 Kilobyte Sekunde, die sie einem da so reinballern und man kann es wirklich auch im Browser-Fenster gucken. Es gibt aber wohl auch eine Special-App dafür und auf dem iPhone glaube ich auch. Die habe ich nicht benutzt.
Aber sag mal, dieses ARD und ZDF, haben die nicht irgendwie im Web so Streams, die auch auf dem iPad und so gehen? Die waren noch so ganz iOS-agnostisch empfänglich.
Ich hab gleich Strom, ich hab gleich leer.
Du, Timmerl, weißt du das?
Stimmt, irgendwas kommt an.
Weiß ich fast.
Geht ARD und ZDF diese Web-Sachen, da gehen die auch auf dem iPad oder iPhone?
Wie live ist das, wie der T-Kaschechen?
Nee, ihre Streams.
Also bei der Zartu, im Fußball konnte man auf jeden Fall die ARD-Webseite gehen irgendwie. Wir standen in San Francisco am Flughafen und Gernot hat probiert auf seinem iPad, in dem er eine LTE-SIM-Karte drinstecken hatte. Per VPN hat er sich nach Deutschland getunnelt und ist dann auf die Tagesschau.de-Seite gegangen und hat da probiert, das Spiel zu gucken, was nicht funktioniert hat. Also es hat immer für ein paar Sekunden funktioniert und dann war die Bitrate nicht mehr gut genug. Wahrscheinlich war das Netz am Flughafen in San Francisco relativ schlecht. Also prinzipiell scheint das zu gehen, ja. Und ich hatte mir auch die ZDF-Mediathek, weil ich wollte dieses Finale gestern, das habe ich komplett verpennt, also wirklich verpennt schlafenderweise. Dann wollte ich mir, was 4 zu 0, dann wollte ich mir doch wenigstens die Tore angucken und dann konnte ich mir schön in der ZDF-Mediathek-App die Tore angucken. Also das ist die Fernsehsender, die sind da zumindest die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die sind da schon gar nicht mal mehr so hinterher.
Ich will auch noch ein bisschen, wenn wir schon bei Fernsehen sind, auch was erzählen. Und zwar auch wegen Fußball wollte ich halt mal wieder gucken, was halt hier so abgeht mit IPTV. Und es ist ja so, dass irgendwie, wenn du zum Beispiel bei der Telekom bist, kann man für 5 oder 10 Euro dieses Entertain-Paket kaufen. Und dann kriegt man halt auch HD-Fernsehen und auch die ganz normalen Sender. Und zwar per, also die verkaufen ja dann gleich so ein Gerät damit. Ich weiß nicht, ob man es nehmen muss oder nicht. Aber die Sender kommen dann halt per Multicast rein. Und man kann aber auch dieses Gerät weglassen. Du guckst mit deinem Laptop und startest einfach VLC und announced dich da zu so einem Multicast-Channel. Und dann kriegst du das halt irgendwie reingestreamt. Und das finde ich eigentlich total cool. Und dieses ganze Antennen-Gebimmel, da können sie eigentlich alles mal abschaffen. Weil IP ist ja voll okay. Qualität ist... Na ist zwar wahr, willst du da alles nicht mehr haben. Oder jedes Kabel und auch eigentlich Ethernet und so. Also Kabel müssen einfach weg. Und ich meine, ich hab halt WLANs zu Hause, dann können sie das direkt von meiner kleinen Station irgendwie zu meinem Rechner streamen. Und ich brauch da nicht noch einen DVB-T-Empfänger und wat die nicht noch alles da irgendwie am Start haben. Also IP kann noch echt alles möglich übertragen. Ich hab über so einen anderen Trick mir ein Fußballspiel in HD angeguckt. Und die Qualität ist wirklich, also gerade wenn du es auf dem Laptop guckst, ist es besser als fast Blu-ray, würde ich sagen.
Oder was heißt denn die?
Fast besser als Blu-ray.
Wenn du HD guckst schon.
Nee, kann ja nicht sein.
Doch, es sieht verdammt gut aus.
Hast du jemals in deinem Leben eine echte Blu-ray gesehen?
Da haben sie halt mit irgendwie komischen Kameras gefilmt und alles ist mit Grain voll und so weiter und so fort. Und da hast du bei diesem Fußball, hast du einfach irgendwie ein super geil scharfes Bild in bester Auflösung. In übertragen mit irgendwie 15 bis 20 MBit oder sonst wie viel. Also vielleicht ist es nicht besser als Blu-ray, aber es ist...
Okay, gut, jetzt sind wir wieder auf so einem Level, wo wir miteinander reden können.
Wenn du dich um 10% streiten willst, zwischen gut und schlecht, muss ja nicht so viel Unterschied liegen. Also zwischen besser und schlechter.
Na, ich will das erst mal sehen.
Ist egal, es ist verdammt nah dran oder dran vorbei. Weiß nicht, kommt immer auf den Filmern, denen die natürlich auf die Blu-ray packen. Das ist auf jeden Fall verdammt gut. Und ich finde, das sollte mal die Zukunft von Fernsehen werden. Weil IP hat inzwischen wirklich irgendwie jeder, finde ich. Und so eine Scheiße. Für DVB-T brauchst du halt so eine komische Box. Und dann hast du vor 10 Jahren, wie ganz Deutschland, Milliarden von Leuten haben sich diese Scheiß-Box gekauft. Und jetzt switchen sie auf HD. Und jetzt muss sich schon jeder wieder so eine dicke Box kaufen. Und wer weiß, wie viele Boxen sie sich dazwischen gekauft haben, weil sich was geändert hat.
Gibt es jetzt DVB-T HD?
DVB-T HD? Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt da HD, glaube ich nicht. Aber es ist V2. Und sie stellen halt auf H264 um. Ist ja alles noch MPG 2.
Ich glaube, die werden demnächst noch viel öfter umstellen. Gerade wenn jetzt halt irgendwie... Ist ja wirklich, was ich schon in der letzten Sendung meinte, es war ja nicht so wirklich ein Witz, dass H265 kommt. Und ich will doch nicht jedes Mal irgendwie meine Box da neu kaufen. Auch wenn jetzt wirklich nicht mehr so viele kosten. Aber ich hab doch alles da. Ich hab einen Rechner, ich hab einen Bildschirm. Kannst du da alles mitmachen?
Einen Rechner kaufst du ja auch alle zwei Jahre neu.
Ja, aber sowieso. Den kaufe ich ja nicht fürs Fernsehen und nur fürs Fernsehen neu.
Aber dieses Fernsehen, das ist schon irgendwie durch. Also da bist du ja mal auf einem anderen Kontinent und schon kannst du das einfach nicht mehr gucken, weil die das da nicht einspeisen und so. Das ist schon, das hat Dennis schon absolut recht. Das muss IP.
Natürlich der Trend geht zum IP, das steht vollkommen außer Frage.
Ist doch mit Telefonen genau das Gleiche, oder? Gab's doch sowieso schon schon ein Spruch von den AT&T-Typen?
Ich hab mir so DVB-Teile gekauft, um einfach unterwegs was zu gucken.
Du meinst jetzt diesen kleinen Stick oder was?
Ja, ja, aber DVB-T ist auch schon im Zug eine vollkommene Zumutung. Also sobald du dich überhaupt schneller als 30 kmh bewegst, ist DVB-T komplett zu vergessen. Abgesehen davon, dass es eigentlich auch bei Stillstand eigentlich schon komplett zu vergessen ist.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß, dass ich bei mir zu Hause, ich wohne halt auch erdgeschoss, muss ich sagen, ich hab nicht so einen guten Empfang mit DVB-T. Aber es ist nicht ungewöhnlich, dass das Bild irgendwie kurz... Oder nee, das Bild geht meistens, aber ab und zu hab ich irgendwie Tonaussetzer, wo er wieder mal irgendein Bit nicht durchkommt. Das ist schon merkwürdig. Bei mir geht der Ton einfach weg und er macht nach 5 Sekunden wieder an.
Das Komische ist auch, ja, also wenn ich mal so irgendwie, wenn irgendwas nicht so Spannendes ist und ich guck... Das ist bestimmt nur Zufall. Und ich guck DVB-T, dann ist das alles super. Wenn dann so was wie Champions League-Finale ist oder EM-Finale, dann hab ich irgendwie plötzlich Scheißempfang. Also es ruckelt und hackt irgendwie. Es kann wirklich, also vermutlich, es kann ja nur eigentlich wahrscheinlich mit dem Wetter oder sowas zu tun haben.
Das ist 2012 und ich spring hinter meinem Fernseher rum und versuche meine Scheiß-DVB-T-Attende an die richtige Stelle zu stellen. Sag mal, was ist denn das 2012? Ich will eigentlich VLC auf meinen Favorite Sender klicken und dann hab ich da HD-Fernsehen.
Das Ding ist auch bei diesen...
Und die Retina-Displays sind sogar besser als 4K. Das muss man sich mal reinziehen. Die sollen mal ein bisschen mithalten und nicht irgendwie...
Man muss erst mal Kameras bauen, die diese Scheiße auch eingefangen bekommen.
4K gibt's ja.
Da gibt's ja auch...
Ich weiß nicht, ob du so viel Detailfülle auch echt am Ende haben willst. Für Fußball ist 4K, glaube ich, völlig in Ordnung. Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie... Ich meine, jetzt siehst du ja schon jeden Pickel bei den Schauspielern, aber wenn du auf 4K gehst, das würde ich gar nicht drüber nachdenken.
Dann sollen die mal mit ihrer Schminke da sich ein bisschen anstrengen, wenn die wissen, dass man so nah rangeht.
Das geht dann nur noch mit CG, da müssen wir einfach alle entlassen.
Das kommt doch eh.
Wir haben nicht genug Auflösungen, wir müssen sie durch ein Computermodell ersetzen.
Aber haben wir diese Kamera da schon erwähnt, die jetzt demnächst rauskommt?
Diese Kamera?
Diese Kamera! Diese Kamera!
Welche Kamera?
Die Black Magic Cinema Camera. Eine Kamera, die den Videomarkt disrupten wird. Nee, aber diesmal wirklich. Also es gibt ja diese Red-Kameras, das ist ja gerade sozusagen der Industriestandard, wenn es um digitales Video geht.
Ach, dieses Thunderbolt-Teil, was wir auch auf der Keynote gezeigt haben.
Und diese Red-Kameras, da bezahlt man halt kleinen bis Mittelwagenpreise, um überhaupt so ein Setup zu bekommen, womit man mal arbeiten kann. Also der Body kostet schon zig. Und jetzt noch Blackmagic. Blackmagic ist eine Firma, die schon sehr lange Track-Record in der Videobranche hat. Die bauen halt einen Arsch voll. Und die haben auch ihren eigenen lossless-Codec, der zum Beispiel von Filmscannern benutzt wird, ganz häufig.
Und auch für Final Cut-Lizenziertes, Black-Codec oder so.
Genau, die sind schon schwer dabei. Und die haben jetzt einfach gesagt, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass jetzt zum Beispiel Redfin SSD-Festplatte irgendwie 6.000 Euro oder 3.000 charge. Wir bauen jetzt mal selber eine Kamera. Und die haben eine 2,5K-Kamera gebaut. Die ist kompatibel mit Canon und Zeiss-Objektiven. Das heißt, irgendwie Leute auch mit kleinerem Budget können einfach mal schon direkt ihre Linsen, die sie schon haben, draufschrauben. Warte, Moment. Dann ist halt SSD-Slot drin und eben Thunderbolt-Connector. Das Ding kostet 3.000 oder soll, glaube ich, 3.000 Dollar kosten und die Software, um dieses RAW-Video davon zu processen, die kostet halt eigentlich ansonsten auch schon 1.900 Dollar und die ist mit dabei. Das heißt, du hast irgendwie für 3.000 Dollar einfach mal eine echt verdammt geile Kamera, die mit deinem existierenden Photogear wahrscheinlich sogar auch noch kompatibel ist.
Das heißt, die Objektive kann man von normalen Spiegelreflexkameras oder hat auch immer das so gibt, kann man nehmen, weil es egal ob Film oder Foto, ne?
Genau, und du kannst halt dann eben auch noch die fetten Dinger raufschrauben, falls du da mal Bock auf mehr hast. Naja, so sagen wir mal, so 3K für eine Kamera. Also ich bin jetzt nicht so häufig am Videodrehen eigentlich eher selten, aber ich hätte sie einfach verdammt gerne trotzdem. Ja, nee, es ist einfach, dass so muss das... So muss das sein, einfach. So muss Videokamera im 21. Jahrhundert sein. Also einfach mal korrekte Features zu korrekten Preisen und... Ja, mit korrekter Software.
Hast du da eigentlich...
Was willst du eigentlich fragen mit der Fotofrage?
Das wartet mit den Objektiven, hab ich doch.
Ob man die gleichen Objektive übernimmt. Aber sag mal, hast du dir diese andere Kamera geholt, die gleichzeitig die Bilder in allen tiefen Schärfen macht?
Nee, die zweite Generation davon vielleicht.
Wie hieß die?
Litro oder so.
Aber die hat wohl eine sehr schlechte Auflösung. Also alle diese getestet haben.
Das ist halt mal der erste...
Kannst du mit der Kamera ausstreamen oder kannst du mit der Kamera nur übertragen?
Was heißt streamen? Du meinst über Thunderbolt streamen auf den Rechner?
Wenn da auch eine Platte reingeht, kann man ja wohl...
Naja, so sagen wir mal so, Capturing könnte ich mir schon... Also live capture meinst du sozusagen?
Also als Videokamera sozusagen auch benutzen, nicht nur als Recording.
Weiß ich jetzt so aus dem Hut nicht, aber wir gucken mal. Also ich könnte es mir zumindest vorstellen, wenn ein Rechner die Datenrate verarbeiten kann. Warum nicht, ne?
Und meinst du, die ist auch gut genug, dass da demnächst Filme mitgedreht werden? Oder ist schon auch wieder eher sowas für die reichen Leute, für zu Hause oder für so Hobbyisten?
Naja, sagen wir mal...
Die sind das ja schon so, die machen ja wirklich so Fernsehfilme und teilweise auch Kinografe, oder?
Ja klar, und die macht 4K, ne?
Oder das war glaub ich die erste, die da mitkam, oder?
Also ich mein, das ist... Also ich mein, muss man so sehen, ne? Für eine Canon-Spiegelreflexkamera, die auch Filme aufnehmen kann, so eine 5D, die auch ein echt korrektes Bild macht, ja. Da bezahlt sie halt in etwa auch so viel. Die kann nur Full HD aufnehmen. Und das ist halt eine Kamera, die eigentlich für Foto ist und immer noch diesen komischen Klappspiegel da drin hat. Und so ein paar Eigenschaften hat die einfach für Video nicht so wirklich optimal sind. Aber das ist ja gerade das, was sozusagen die semi-professionellen Videoleute gerade nehmen, weil das sind Kameras, die zumindest ein geiles Bild machen, wo sie viele Objektive für haben. Und die wir halt bezahlen, weil das ist ja gerade das, was sozusagen die semi-professionellen Videoleute gerade nehmen, weil das sind Kameras, die zumindest ein geiles Bild machen, wo sie viele Objektive für haben, und die wir halt bezahlbar sind. Und das ist jetzt einfach mal so, einfach eine ganze Ecke drüber, aber zum gleichen Preis. Also du kriegst halt einfach das Raw-Video darunter und das kriegst du halt bei den Kanons nicht, da kriegst du ja dann auch schon MPEG sozusagen. Und ich glaube, dass es schon, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es für wirklich Spielfilm reicht oder vielleicht nur für Fernsehproduktion, aber es ist auf jeden Fall für alle Leute, die jetzt so mit Spiegelreflexkameras rumrennen und Videos drehen, ist das irgendwie nochmal zehnmal geiler. Mindestens.
Und den Roster natürlich richtig cool.
Und mit SSD und mit Thunderbolt, also so genau will man, also ich weiß ja, bei den Canon-Kameras, ok, du kannst die Chipkarte rausnehmen und so weiter und so fort, aber da ist einfach eine fucking SSD drin. Das ist schon, so will man das haben.
Ja, die Zukunft. Ja, ich hoffe, dass hier auch im Podcasting-Bereich demnächst die Zukunft Fuß fassen wird. Sieht auf jeden Fall ganz gut aus. Denn die Podlauf-Wordpress-Geschichte kommt langsam voran. Das wird echt jetzt langsam, langsam wird's wahr. Und ich hoffe, dass da auch relativ bald Konkretes anzukündigen gibt. Aber wer so nachdenkt, so in den nächsten Wochen mal einen neuen Podcast aufzusetzen, so mit WordPress und so weiter, sollte vielleicht nochmal die Hufe stillhalten. Ohne jetzt hier irgendwelche Zeit zusammen zu machen. Aber ich plane halt da bald zu migrieren und dann gibt's auch echt neue, endlich mal wieder neue Features. Da dürste ich ja schon lange danach. Endlich mal Feed-Kontrolle wieder herstellen und so weiter. Das ist so furchtbar, wenn man so ein schlecht gewartetes Plugins ausgeliefert ist. Das macht einen echt krank.
Wenn man nicht alles selber macht, wa?
Wenn man nicht alles selber macht, genau.
Wollen wir jetzt selber auch mal so langsam...
Schicht im Schacht?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich bin nämlich durch am Durchesten.
Dann noch zwei Bierchen hier. Den Nothelfern.
Die Nothelfer, die haben ja geholfen, mich hier auf Vordermann zu halten.
Im Sattel zu halten.
Genau, das Lager. Schon irgendwie eine interessante Bierexperience. Überhaupt nicht so wie...
Prolo-Bier oder so, ne?
Es gibt Bags-Eis-irgendwas, das ist...
Transparent, ne?
Steht da nicht sogar Ice-Water drauf, was ist das wirklich? Also wirklich Wasser mit Biergeschmack, so nach dem Motto, ja.
Ihr solltet jetzt vielleicht mal, weil wir müssen reden, auf fränkisches Bier umsteigen.
Gerne, schickt uns was zu. Eine Kleinigkeit hab ich noch.
Jetzt aber schnell.
Ganz kleiner Apptip. Und zwar Satellite Ice heißt das, wie Satellit mit Doppel L. Ich pack mal den in den Chat.
Ice oder Eis? Also Eis.
Ich hab mal die URL in den Chat geschmissen.
Satelliten Augen.
Das ist so eine App, bringt nur auf dem Laptop was, auf dem MacBook. Lässt man immer laufen und die macht als Bildschirmhintergrund immer eine Satellitenaufnahme von der Stelle an, in der man gerade ist. Also ich seh jetzt hier, wenn ich jetzt meinen Bildschirmhintergrund habe.
War das Berlin nicht so...
Von Google Maps oder was?
Ne, von Bing. Und es sind gute Aufnahmen. Ich zeig jetzt mal, wie es aussieht. Was total geil ist, wenn man ein Multi-Monitor-Setup hat, dann verteilt er auch die schönen... Dann macht er auch anschließende Karten über mehrere Monitore. Hat verschiedene Modi. Hat zum einen Bing Maps. Zumindest in der Ecke von Berlin, in der ich mich im allgemeinen so aufhalte. Es gibt aber auch diese Toner- und Watercolor-Modi für Open-Street-View. Open-Street-Map. Open-Street-View wird es auch mal Zeit für. Da gibt es ja diesen Kartendienst, der da irgendwie so, dass so ein bisschen wasserfarbenmäßig aussieht. Und das haben die halt auch drin. Als Alternative.
Und man kann den Zoom-Level einstellen.
Man kann den Zoom-Level einstellen und ist so ganz süß.
Aber bisher sehe ich noch nichts.
Gut, da warten wir jetzt gleich nach Ende der Sendung noch. Das erscheint während wir Tims Facebook-Seite aufsassen.
Warum braucht der denn, um das zu laden?
Geht eigentlich sofort.
Waiting for Location Fix, sagt er. Jetzt braucht er wieder W-Lan.
Jetzt ist der in GPS abgestürzt.
Dass der sich auch ohne W-Lan nicht orten kann.
Scheiß W-Lan. Scheiß W-Lan. Scheiden Sie auch nächstes Mal wieder ein, wenn Tim kurz vorm Herzinfarkt steht.
Ich stand dich kurz vorm Herzinfarkt.
Irgendwann macht Tim uns noch den Steve.
Ich bin ruhig und gefasst.
Dank Nothilfer Bier.
Dir mach ich noch mal den Steve, Max.
Den Vidi.
Den Ball mach ich.
Die Wallerpass, die Wallerpass, die Wallerpass.
Freuen wir uns schon auf in zwei Wochen, wenn Roddi wieder dabei ist und die Sendung wieder auf Stilkurs bringt.
Auf was?
Stilkurs.
Roddi doch auch noch oben.
Okay, haben wir's.
Wir rannten doch auch alle nur mit Wasser.
Meine Ohren kweilen.